foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
what a beautiful tactic the Indian yogis
are the first team to make it to the
playoffs
welcome back to
back people a unique collection of teams
each with their own personality of
different colors shapes and sizes there
are gnomes and nights
sprawls and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
rookie what are stunning move this is
just unbelievable what he does entering
its Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot
the PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion
it was a huge pottery
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
and the bee Pawn comes oh my goodness
Miley way to go girl that's huge
that is huge for us
ladies and gentlemen welcome it's
Thursday it's more PCL action time 2
scintillating matches for you today it's
early morning for me it's a little bit
later for my co-host Grand Master Amana
Hamilton joins us today I'm on welcome
to the show glad to be commentating with
you again thanks Dania I've been uh fist
bumping ever since that moment uh when
the chess Frost got the victory uh
riding a high from that but happy to
jump in the booth with you Dania and
cover uh more exciting matches today I
think the PCL just never disappoints
it really never does and a big part of
the reason why is the teams that have
been assembled and I think the two
matches today are not going to
disappoint either we start the day off
with Hikaru Nakamura Levy rosman's team
the Gotham Knights facing the only other
perfect score team the Shanghai Tigers
only one team has reached the playoffs
thus far but we'll get to that shortly
at 10 A.M Pacific immediately after the
conclusion of that match we will have a
good modder's team the Croatia Bulldogs
facing MBL splits it's an action-packed
day as usual the one plenty of super GMS
to go around
Yeah a hundred percent Danny I mean we
have two different type of matchups
today one of them we find out who is
going to move on and join the Indian
yogis in the playoffs three and oh we're
gonna have a 3-0 team today which is
always very exciting to find out but on
the other hand these one-on-one teams
this is a really important match there's
a huge difference between two and one
and playing for your playoff hopes and
one and two and potentially being
eliminated Daniel
oh absolutely and you will be placed
accordingly in the standings and the
standings are jam-packed at the top like
I said only one team has made the
playoffs that happened yesterday in a
stunning Victory by the Indian yogis
over the levitov chess Wizards who
themselves have victimized a couple of
other teams you can see the Tigers and
the Gotham Knights the only other
perfect score teams and well that field
is going to be thinned even further down
Amman but some of those teams like the
Canada bras I have to say through
clenched teeth as well as the California
unicorns just because they've lost one
match it doesn't mean that you can fall
asleep on their hopes and aspirations to
win the entire thing 100 and I think one
of the most important things for fans
and viewers to remember is that these
teams are they have much deeper rosters
than just the four people that you might
see playing in a given week certain
lineups might work better than others so
a team could get blown out of the water
one week come back shake things up
different lineup and be dominant the
next this week we've seen that a number
of times the levitov chess Wizards
Daniel I thought they couldn't lose a
single match and then all of a sudden
you know they they go up against an even
stronger team so absolutely you said it
anything can happen
yeah I mean speaking of losing some
matches a couple of teams have lost more
than one match in fact one team uh their
aspirations and hopes of winning the PCL
title have vanished having a hard time
reading the name of the city that
assembled that team Charlotte Carolina
exactly yeah it Rhymes unfortunately
we've flamed and burned out and lost all
three matches but we'll be back next
year but what I wanted to say amount is
that the St Louis archbishops I'm
shockingly they're owing to they've won
the PCL in previous Seasons which just
tells you how ridiculously strong and
unpredictable the PCL season is but I
have a feeling that one of those 0-2
teams has a pretty good chance to make a
comeback how amazing of a storyline
would that be if like the archbishops
made the playoffs I I know imagine I I
definitely think that they are the most
capable team of doing that so you might
have just spoken into existence Daniel
we'll see
oh man now the PCL is cursed well let's
review The rosters for today's match of
course everybody knows who the MVP is on
the Gotham Knights it's that smiling
face of Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura who
will be putting in an appearance today
but he is not the only Grandmaster and
player capable of carrying a team
they've also get La Quang Lim former
World Blitz champion and by the way
Vladimir FedEx and one player Amman that
I think a lot of people and fans are
looking forward to seeing in a slightly
longer time control format is of course
I am Nicola boardnick who's throwing it
down in countless longchess.com Blitz
matches I'm from Nikola to test his
medal in a more serious event absolutely
I mean he's one of those players that
always has the rating that seems to back
up you know his his incredible
performances but he doesn't get to show
them on the biggest stages so I'm
absolutely excited to to see what he can
bring to this Gotham Knights team to the
PCL obviously Hikaru Nakamura is sort of
leading by example he had that one
really shaky game right at the start of
his PCL uh you know season but since
then he's been remarkable for the team
and uh you know there's a reason that
this team is 2-0
there absolutely is and Hikaru is a big
part of that reason he's also had a 4-0
run in a previous week as has the sort
of MVP member of the Shanghai Tigers way
not to be outdone Shanghai tigers have
assembled a Powerhouse team it is
composed of some players among that
don't necessarily have eye-popping
ratings but have already shown
themselves capable of throwing it down
with the best of them I'm looking of
course at Zhu and June the reigning
women's world champion and players like
Wei nihua Zhang Zhang they are
unbelievably solid and that's ultimately
what you need from a PCL team and from a
player I'm on you need players who can
consistently perform two and a half out
of four three out of four and who rarely
have flame out type performances
yeah that's a that's a great point and
you know what strikes me as uh you know
maybe one of the biggest reasons why
this team might be doing well Dania is
you know they have all their players
from China so there's a lot of Team
camaraderie a lot of chemistry and you
can really see it in the players they're
joking in between the rounds you see two
engine there on camera I just think that
this team is having fun with it and
they're all so talented you know they're
interested in Sharing lines uh sharing
uh you know ideas in the openings with
one another and you don't always see
that with you know different chess
colleagues from countries around the
world so I think that might be one of
the reasons why this team is currently
you know 2-0 and looks like one of the
absolute favorites
great point and that also stands behind
the success of a lot of lit chess
Olympia teams throughout history team
chemistry really is important in chess
team events as uh is your participation
in our weekly Community questions uh
voting does close on Tuesday so it's too
late to vote on this one but uh just to
tell you what you've been missing out on
if you haven't used the X Glam predict
feature in chat the question for this
week how many Bishops will the Shanghai
Tigers fee in quiero today I over under
is five and a half I'm on it's too late
too late to vote now but I'll give you
as the commentator the privilege of
making that prediction thank you Dania I
appreciate that and the great privilege
I will absolutely be locking in a over
5.5 but I'll even do you one better
because you gave me permission Dania
I'll say over but I'll specifically say
eight
you know let's have the chat keep track
uh and uh and we'll see how I do
we'll alert our scribes encounters and
our statisticians and they will keep a
very close eye on this one but we will
keep a close eye on the match-ups and
the lineups because they are indeed
quite scintillating starting with the
board assignments in caracamura and Wei
both have had perfect runs they are our
board ones and of course June June shuyi
and Liu ping among this is the lineup
that has won I think both of the matches
for the Shanghai tigers with minimal
changes for the Gotham Knight I think
this is Nikola portnick's first
appearance Alina kashlinska don't fall
asleep on her I mean she's basically a
grand master what I mean two Powerhouse
teams that we have here yeah I think if
I'm looking at uh you know the two
lineups that we have in front of us here
the most interesting thing to start off
is that you mentioned it two previous uh
4-0 weeks are actually going head to
head so I'm sorry but only one of those
and potentially none of them have a
chance to survive based on you know this
this incoming matchup when they do meet
on board one so that's already uh pretty
exciting and as we go down that list I'm
also drawn to the name uh International
Master Alina keshlinskaya who I know I
certainly remember from the I am not a
GM tournament I think she definitely
belongs in the GM not an I Am tournament
because she always puts in a good
performance I think she's going to be
Rock Solid on board three exciting to
see her in action and you just go over
that Shanghai tiger side and it's like
you don't seem to have to change that
much if it ain't broke no don't fix it I
mean this team has been doing well with
very similar lineups and you know most
of the players Daniel remain unchanged
yeah
and I think you called it earlier team
camaraderie right when you've got the
same lineup week in and week out you
almost feel a sense of responsibility uh
to your team into your teammates to keep
performing well uh like you said if it
ain't broke don't fix it we've seen
different match and a team assembly
strategies and I really am partial to
teams that essentially keep the lineup
weekend and week out so there are the
board assignments ladies and gentlemen
Everybody Plays everybody if you don't
remember uh the format for the PCL well
where have you been now before we recap
the format let's actually look at the
round one matchups because Hikaru is not
going to play wayi in round one that
happens folks in round four uh when
board one plays board one conversely in
round one board one plays board four so
Hikaru almost immediately Amman thrust
into I use this term sparingly must win
situation obviously Hikaru he lost a
heinemann in his first ever PCL game and
the Gotham Knights were just totally
okay okay but he really wants to set the
tone early doesn't he yeah I I think
whenever you see that board one versus
board for matchup you absolutely you
know you want to lean on your your high
rated players your poor once they're
there for a reason they're obviously
expected to score the most points in a
match Dania but one thing about these
two lineups is they're actually fairly
even you know you're not seeing a 2200
in there and then a bunch of 2700s you
actually do see a lot of 24 25 2600 so I
mean you know it best Daniel these 2400s
are not going to be a you know free
point or anything like that oh they're
here to win and they can absolutely give
uh Hikaru Nakamura and Wei Yi on board
one a good run for their money
absolutely and I think it's going to be
a really interesting PCL match we will
try to hit on all of the entertaining
games as usual and once again if you
don't know the format all right we will
we will recap the format really quickly
the time control the time control for
the PCL is 10 minutes with a two second
increment it's a nice cross between
Blitz it's not too blitzy and not too
rapidly Everybody Plays everybody in a
four round match on the first team to
reach a cumulative score of eight and a
half wins the match so this can happen
technically in three rounds but it's
only happened that way in a handful of
matches and something tells me that this
match is not going to be a blowout in
the event of an 8-8 tie uh we reached
High brakes which will feature the same
uh lineups as in round four uh with
colors reversed but as I always say
we'll cross that bridge if we get there
we have had Ty breaks them on a couple
of times and if we are to have a batch
with high bricks likely I think this one
is definitely up there yeah it seems
like you know obviously two 2-0 teams
you're certainly expecting that 88 is a
very real possibility I know from
watching the you know very tense and
heart-wrenching Canada chess boss
matches we've won so many matches Daniel
eight and a half seven and a half like
it really does get that close in the PCL
so it is not out of the question that we
see tie breaks and every time that's
happened in the PCL so far it has been
so exciting to watch
it has and it almost happened yesterday
with a garden state passers that match
came down absolutely to the wire I mean
Sam sebian you lost his last two games
of the match and he had a game
apparently I found out after the Mets
against Evan Sarge where he resigned in
a drawn position I still need to
investigate that but that's the kind of
craziness that we see in the PC all
weekend and weekend that's really why
you should tune in because you just
never know what kind of Epic stuff
you'll see on any given day yeah
absolutely like you have no idea how
professional and talented these players
are and yet how capable they all are of
making blunders that just looked so
insane but that's why the PCL is so fun
because you get to see the highest level
and sometimes you get to see just
outrageous blunders that don't belong
speaking of highest level Hikaru
Nakamura his game has begun he has the
black pieces against the Tigers board
for yipping Lou and Hikaru gonna
casually make his way over to his laptop
or contemplate his first move which I
think is going to be Knight F6 but you
never know it could be F5
wake up wake up Susie I feel like I'm at
a wax museum like I'm not sure if that's
the real like is that the real Hikaru or
yeah he's not changing his facial
expression at all nor is he changing the
state of the boredom on that's the
slightly more concerning thing yeah yeah
I've had uh you know a few few
situations where players on the the
chess brought team you just you're not
there like right at the start of the
round so yeah you know a little bit of
odds here and there but we'll wait and
see if uh Hikaru gets his first move in
I see D4 Dania and I'm already thinking
you know Gotta Give me a Catalan here
for my fan keto otherwise it's not
looking good
yeah D4 pre-move G3 and then Hitler
would play E5 for the eye for the
England is very good against 2g3 that's
right uh but you know the scary thing of
mine and this happened in the world
let's Championship where Magnus Carlson
had 30 seconds before the start of one
of the games and he didn't just win that
game he won it easily it was like it was
just another day in the office so the
terrifying thing about playing Hikaru is
that he probably could spot you six or
seven minutes and still be completely
fine yeah I mean the funny thing about
that game and I do want to give some
credit to kovalev his opponent actually
did sort of give back some of that time
uh in the game that they played to sort
of even it up I'm not sure with PCL and
everything that's on the line that you'd
be so uh generous that if I was playing
I'm saying take the time Advantage oh
see what I can do
every second that you can get you need
and while we're figuring out hikaru's
game we've got some more entertaining
action on some of the other boards shui
and Vladimir fedes are throwing it down
we have E4 C5 what about an icefe and
keto uh G3 The Accelerated closed
Sicilian what do you think about that
Iman it's funny because uh I've actually
seen that a few times in in the PCL I
will say like sometimes you're more
likely to see these weird Sidelines in
protest league matches where the players
aren't necessarily trying to play top
Theory but I mean we're gonna sit here
and always expect D4 you know the
mainline open Sicilians but hey bishop
B5 check kind of a mix between a
sideline and a main line
yeah this I believe is called the Moscow
variation or the canal attack I've heard
it referred to several different ways I
play this with white and white plays
Bishop takes D7 check here a major
crossroads for black queen 67 is the
more popular move but taking back with
an item on is the way to sort of
unbalance the position if you want to
preserve winning Chances with black and
it's still a very very solid system from
the white side right and you know when
you when you see uh the current
structure you're actually not looking to
play D4 as white uh like those normal
Sicilians open Sicilians that we all
might be used to but rather maybe like a
c3d4 so I could actually retain a pawn
in the center after the eventual capture
as opposed to just having a knight there
so white kind of gets this nice Center
but the other hand you know black guys
easy uh development shouldn't be uh any
any opening issues to start things off
yeah and black intern has a bunch of
setups that he can counter with I think
fedasev is doing the standard stuff he
goes E6 you can also feed and get out of
the bishop but the most common response
is to meet C3 and D4 with a well-timed
D5 counter-striking in the center and
then if white plays E5 you get that sort
of French Advanced type structure but
with the with the absence of light
squared Bishops the Black Knight which
lands on e4 is actually going to be very
safe and the only way to kick it away is
either to trade it off for one of
White's Knights or to kick it away with
the F1 but a different kind of setup or
should you playing maximally
positionally B3 and I do think of one
that he's likely to go D4 eventually but
only if he's assured that he can set up
the sort of marozzi bind with C4 to
follow yep that that seems entirely like
what he's trying to go for and I think
with B3 he's opening up other ideas of
you know just playing more solid he
could even start with C4 before the move
d4
um Bishop B2 looks like it's happening
and uh Daniel yeah
now he might play Bishop A3
incoming for the Shanghai Tigers uh
statisticians count that one
there's number one well let's go to the
bird's eye view and see if we have any
other fianchettos we actually might
there's good news on one of the other
boards because all of the games ladies
and gentlemen have in fact begun
including ikara Nakamura who might have
been setting up his stream that might
have been the solution to our mystery
and that's on the top left of your
screen folks I'm having a hard time
making out but the last move there was
by hikarnak where I think it might have
been B6 that's right B6 it's looking uh
looking great for all the potential uh
fan categories but remember Dania it
only counts for the Shanghai Tigers this
is a very yeah very specific very
specific Eddie Cara doesn't play for the
Shanghai Tigers oh man man I've got my
teams all mixed up let's go to that game
and see how Hikaru is trying to
guarantee winning Chances with block he
has in fact completed the fiancaro and
he's just kicked away White's Bishop
from the center with F5 early
Impressions I'm on I like hikaru's
position and I'll like it even more if
he castles Queen side here what are the
odds of that do you think
yeah and you know you could really
castle queenside and go I'm gonna call
it crazy but it might not be that crazy
move like G5 like long Castle G5 G4 if
you take my Pawn on G5 I mean we don't
even have enough we don't even have
enough ink to print the arrows from B7
to G2 C7 to H2 like I mean this looks
really scary especially if you add an
open G file to the mix
and the Hikaru you can see him talking I
can bet a silver dollar that he's
deciding live between castle and King
side and castle in Queensland it might
be too early in the match to make a move
as Brazen as Queen side castles because
you don't have enough ink to print blast
attacking ideas but don't fall asleep on
White's Pawn storm either and Hikaru
just sort of delays the decision with
Bishop to d6amon taking the sting out of
the move before against which I think
he's planning this very devilish idea
95. yeah that's Bishop D6 is really
crafty because if you let's say take
care of things and play like H3 then I
think we really will get a long Castle
plus G5 idea that makes a lot more sense
there and you just pointed out before
not so simple because Knight E5 if you
take on E5 you know I'll show this we're
capturing back and yeah we can show
everybody that The Rook on A1 is
attacked and don't forget about the pawn
on H2 loose over there yeah we get our
pancetto
steep cost and it's not just the H2 Pawn
the king is driven into the diagonal of
the other Bishop you could follow up
with H5 right clearly this is not the
sort of thing yuping Lu would want out
of the opening against icaro so as we
reload the live board instead white has
counter-struck in the center with E4 and
we've actually really really like yeah
trying to get rid of the F Pawn but more
importantly I'm on trying to contest
this incredibly nasty Bishop on the long
diagonal with a bishop of White's own
which would land on e4 in the event of
the trade yeah that that position looks
very good so if we see F takes E4 Bishop
takes E4 I like White's chances the you
know you have easy moves to make next
Bishop E3 Rook E1 Rook D1 such simple
gameplay for Lu yiping I'm wondering how
Hikaru is going to react to this because
I'm looking at Pawn takes and that
doesn't look so nice but on the other
hand you know you just have highlighted
move like G6 if you play that Dania are
you committing to Queen side castling
because G6 you're not castling kingside
after that no no you're not touching
that with a 10-foot pole and steady car
removes his Knight back to E7 and
craftsy I think uh is a word you use to
describe Bishop C5 to D6 I would use it
to describe hikaru's play as a whole
sort of kg he's trying to keep as many
options open as possible he's trying to
keep the situation in the center
undefined and that's how you generate
winning chances against a solid player
the issue is that it could backfire and
I wouldn't say that it's backfiring I
think that would be jumping the gun but
white is meeting Hikaru at the top
preparing E5 and suddenly the bishop on
D6 could be encountering some
difficulties Bishop C5 B4 right you
could probably save the minor piece by
taking on F3 but that would hand wipe
the bishop pair and that's again not
what hikar wants out of the opening yeah
it does look like with rather logical
move E4 rookie one he's already putting
the question to Black's pieces and we
might see that you know exact lines show
up on the board I mean it's actually
quite possible now that E5 is a real
consideration Daniel
yeah and white is going to spend some
time deciding how to resolve the
situation in the center that I think
affords us a good opportunity to travel
back to the bird's eye view because
there is a game that I am so so looking
forward to seeing in Amman I'll give you
the final say as to where we go next but
I'm looking at mikola board next board
and I'm seeing that he's got 9 minutes
and 51 seconds Wei has five minutes and
that is such a Deja Vu situation for me
I can't tell you in how many Blitz Games
we make 10 15 moves sporting still has
all of the time he started with and I'm
thinking there's no way that this is
preparation poor thing is some of the
most dangerous opening ideas that you
will find probably among any
quote-unquote International master I
hate referring to mikola Bortnick as an
international Master given what he's
capable of that's what he is exactly
yeah I agree let's jump into that game
because it does seem like with that time
advantage and everything going through
your head is this is prep you know what
what does he have uh in store for me
Knight B5 hitting the queen was the last
move the bishop pair for Wei Yi but it
looks like one of these situations where
you have to work you still have a lot of
work ahead of you to actually make that
Bishop pair relevant like you're not
even fully developed yet let alone
looking forward to utilizing the bishop
pair so sort of a long term uh Advantage
if you can uh arrange the pieces but for
now dealing with short-term threats
wait he doesn't seem too concerned about
his clock remember what he's doing is
that a water bottle he's fiddling with
something off camera there his Queen is
hanging so I hope he doesn't get
distracted to the point where he's like
oh let's complete my development with
Bishop to D7 he is presumably going to
move his queen and the biggest secondary
priority I'm on is I would assume to
keep the E5 Pawn protected although you
could make a move like Queen B6 and try
to engineer some tactics like Queen
takes E5 Bishop F6 but that has to be
calculated and as we're talking he's now
under four minutes this is a six minute
time Advantage here for a great tactical
player in Nicola boarding not someone
that you want to mess around with in a
Time scramble
it look almost looks like he's sort of
tweeting out like a don't love my
position hashtag ecl you know
um I think and obviously obviously the
players have uh multiple cameras set up
so I think he was actually fixing his
secondary camera is sort of what it
looked like
um but you know he's looks like he's all
good to uh good to go there but as you
mentioned perfect time to put on the
pressure you guys uh got the camera
Gambit so you know put the uh put the
heat on here he still has not moved
no this is getting ridiculous this
actually might be in the biggest time
deficit of the PCL type territory yeah
three minutes now on the clock for Wei
and I think the most obvious move is
Queen D6 to F6 so maybe there's actually
something he's worried about on top of
uh him being worried that his camera
isn't properly positioned yeah it might
just be that white goes let's say Rook
F1 to E1 and when you're the top rated
player by 500 points like way he is or
300 points you're playing you're
fighting a secondary enemy I'm on which
is the need to win the game Nikola has
the luxury of essentially playing solid
Chess By the way the evil part just shut
up I like the look of Bishop F4 here
because the bishop on E7 is undefended
but he continues to play instantly and
he's trying to shove that pawn down to
D6 I mean can't blame him D6 even comes
with a package threat of Knight C7 and
less gosh Bishop d8 would be the only
response and yeah
D6 D7 I mean there's already significant
threats on on the board Bishop D6 comes
to mind as just a you know way to
blockade that pawn but you know you're
already at the very least giving up
um you know your Bishop parent you're
certainly not better
yeah I mean if white wants to guarantee
half a point then I would take the
bishop on D6 and maybe play Bishop D2
which may seem like the most passive
developing move but you're really aiming
for B4 and once you dislodge that Queen
you're playing D6 you know essentially
automatically so right now it's decision
time for mikola boarding he starts with
Bishop D2 typical Piccola right there
I'm on a classic bukola board Nick move
so easy to miss this trick in a Blitz
game yeah and I'm getting really
concerned now for Waze clock and for his
position by the way definitely this is
not simple
um you know in fact sometimes the
positions where the eval bar hovers
around you know the middle of the board
the most those are the toughest
positions to play especially when you're
down on the clock rookie 8 sort of an
innocuous looking move getting out of
that exact threat Knight D6 and Bishop
B4 but the eval bar is just saying nope
like that's a mistake already
yeah not going to fly I think Rook a to
C1 that looks good to me you could
follow it up with Knight takes D6 and
Bishop before and the problem again
isn't just that black was losing the
exchange it's that you're dislodging the
queen that's why the queen one is the
worst blockader because it's such an
easy piece to attack once you attack it
and get this Pawn down at E6 I hesitate
to use the word unusable but that's as
close as it gets to like a risk-free
position against way a pretty dream
scenario here for uh Gotham Knight to
support four yeah I mean you know that
this is match up where a board four
scoring any points against the board one
doesn't matter what roster you're coming
with that's always a good result for the
team so Gotham Knights will surely be be
happy with uh with the performance thus
far
yeah it's a pretty cushy roll I think
board four but it's an incredibly
crucial role right as you said one out
of four it really feels so much
different from losing all four of your
games where kc1 has been played and as
the way he tries to get his pieces out
and muster up some resistance to Nicola
boardnick's initiative let's go back to
the bird's eye view because some of the
other games have also reached a climaxy
car in akamura is playing in the upper
left hand side of your screen
he is locked in a pretty wild tactical
struggle he has in fact castled kingside
and he's managed to damage White's Pawn
structure but a couple of the other
games come on that we haven't looked at
uh also are locked in a very interesting
battle I'll give you the say I'm
experiencing decision anxiety as usual
they all look tempting I was really
fascinated by the imbalances in the cash
linskaya and Jew and Jun game
um it looked like it may have come from
some sort of nimzo so I'd love to dive
into that one that one looks uh like
it's it's got a lot of imbalances
structurally and uh with the the pieces
the minor pieces on the board
let's take a look so ashlinska has the
white pieces this came from a I think A
samish variation of The nimzo Indian in
which white accepts the damage on the
queen side but in turn tries to get
tries to get stuff going on the other
side of the board I don't really think
that Alina has been able to get anything
going on the king side instead with her
move out for him on he's created a
massive hole on e4 which black is ready
to occupy black is ready to get control
of the e-file as well as the C4 Square
positionally white looks totally busted
here what am I missing yeah uh looks
like a dream position for juvenile it
does appear to me that at some point in
this game which is always interesting to
think how we got here white probably had
pawns on C4 D4 E4 and F4
um I wouldn't be surprised and then
black has sort of chipped away this move
F5 was probably well timed that just
looks like such a rock solid Pawn uh you
mentioned the light squares the dark
Square Bishop on C1 is just crying for
attention in here can't develop to A3
the F4 Pawn also blocks that Bishop on
the other diagonal
um huge issues here or Kesh linskaya and
I think if Joo engine is not taking a
full point from this game that's a you
know big big disservice
especially given uh the trouble that Wei
is in but yeah that's like paying taxes
he had pawns on C4 D4 E4 F4 you know
beautiful everything's good by the time
you're finished paying off uh the state
and the country you've got like one
measly pawn and it's blockaded yeah
bigger weakness on e4 so Alina basically
just has to sit around and wait but yeah
she's trying she's bringing her Knight
back to G1 King H1 was a crafty
defensive move perhaps one day she can
get her Knight over to E5 but I mean
there's no question that June June is
winning positionally she can play Queen
to E4 here and try to get the ladies off
the board so that she can more easily
attack the queen side Pawns I think
she's got things under control
absolutely yeah this looks like a great
start for the Shanghai Tigers you can
see that the eval bar reflects uh sort
of what we're saying as well super
comfortable position and you know the
clock is also indicative of you know the
strength of the position right because
but White's clock is ticking down it's
tough to play you know bad positions
quickly
it most certainly is and queen E4 has
just been played Jun executing Her Moves
confidently although it's pretty easy to
play good moves in a position where
virtually every move is good whether
it's Queen E4 Knight C4 you really can't
go too wrong here I think that we can
trust June June to finish this one off
let's go back to the bird's eye view a
couple of the other games are reaching
the time scramble phase top right is a
game we haven't looked at yet it was
it's been very kind of quiet and
positional all the way through but
Vladimir for to save with the black
pieces has developed a significant end
game Advantage with that pass Pawn on F5
Amman and Hikaru Nakamura he is up upon
it as well that's top left we can look
at Hikaru as he tries to win that often
Nikola Bortnick I think
he probably is going to draw his game if
he trades Queens in that position on the
bottom right yeah everything looks like
it's uh I mean we can jump to Federal
saves game because definitely looks like
it's progressing quickly and an
advantage for him as well hikaranakamura
appears to be basically completely
winning
um the car is going to win that yeah
very typical style as well
um but yeah fedo sales game definitely
looks like uh the one to tune into
because we have a rook end game these
are two grand Masters facing off in the
very first uh Round Here Dania but
despite the pawns being equal and it
being a rook end game oh would you say
that this is borderline completely lost
it is and the eval bar was showing
something like plus six that sounds like
a wild exaggeration material is equal
for goodness sake but the reason is just
that white has no counter play Black's
pawns are deep freezing their
counterparts I can never play C3 white
can never play D4 his Queen Side Pawn
structure is utterly Frozen it's
paralyzed and blacks disparity in peace
activity is the secondary factor that
makes this borderline hopeless or white
look at the state of White's King and
White's Rook they're pushed to the back
row okay shui is trying to get active
desperately he's trying to go after the
a pawn and create a pass on of his own
but I think Vladimir can go directly for
C2 and once he wins that pawn them on
whites other pawns just collapse like a
house of cards exactly and uh at this
point in The Rook end game it's it's
essentially like who can get a mobile
pass Pawn First and I think upon on B4
so much closer to cleaning than any of
white spawns and despite the fact that
shuyi is you know keeping material
leaving he's taking tons of puns
ironically it's just not good enough the
B Pawn will decide
yeah congratulations you now have an a
pawn but this Pawn can be stopped like
50 different ways you can even wait for
it to reach A7 and calmly drop your Rook
back to G8 right in this case
supervising a pass Pawn with the king is
so much more valuable than doing so with
a rook it shows you why people get so
obsessed over King activity in the end
game but Vladimir has to be careful like
you can't just randomly take pawns he
has to decide whether he's going to push
his V Pawn when he wants to stop the a
pawn and you know where he wants to
bring his King so a couple of questions
left to be answered okay there's the
answer he takes D3 he might take the D3
and H3 puns upon or he might meet Rook
takes C5 with something like F4 I think
it's clean to you know you could
potentially take H3 and go Rook H1 Rook
A1 so you always have the a pawn covered
but I like his Rook takes D3 because it
actually forced white to take the C Pawn
you could not allow C4 to happen two
connected pass bonds
um D6 so he's stopping the pawn in his
tracks and that appears to be the
cleanest way to uh to win this thing now
you escort the pawn right
yeah King A2 King A3 thing wins here and
White's King is cut off so fedesev is
going to carry this one home I think we
should go back to our bird's eye view
because Wei we've had that game on our
Raider for a while and now he has mere
seconds on his clock the Queens have
been traded and his position has
improved quite a bit but Nikola boarding
is one of the trickiest players in the
opposing side's time pressure reporting
might have played too fast there though
I'm on uh in the early middle game and
end game he's dug himself into a bit of
a hole let's see if we can handle his
time pressure waste I think he's
handling it amazingly so far
yeah just the the bishop rook and pawn
you know both sides are working with the
same instruments here but blacks look
far more dangerous the pawn on e4 is
actually mobile and White's King is in a
little bit of trouble imagine black gets
a pawn to E3 Rook D1 will be mate so
there are real issues for the white king
here as well and the bishop on B8 Pawn
on D6 so clumsy and easy to blockade
that pawn
and this is just what great players do
we thought that White's position was
essentially risk-free but now it turns
out that white is totally paralyzed yeah
that Bishop on B8 it's tied down to the
pawn boarding might just have to sit
around and wait but you can't wait
forever because black is going to get
his King up I think eventually or not
I'm on because now uh he's cut off the
connection between his bishop and the D7
Pawn that was a losing move apparently
one thing you want I'm not not even
exactly sure why might have had
something to do with Rook E2 check and
E3 getting that pawn pushed up the board
um because it basically if the pawn gets
to E3 you feel that things are crumbling
for white
and then you could have actually gone
after White's King side pawns uh
particularly the G3 Pawn if you had cut
off the connection between white truck
and opponent he can essentially do that
again he can play rookie two and E3 and
I think he might be going for it no not
yet he's got five seconds though
I want to make that decision that ruins
everything right where you you play E3
and it's like oops Bishop B6 and you
lose your Pawn
oh you could absolutely lose this right
you lose the pawn and with two seconds
you just might not have enough time to
react uh to the change in environment so
given the match situation where you
might want to play this conservatively
and just holds the drakikaru has one by
the way that a save has one as we
expected and uh June is going to win as
well so no surprising results there but
with the Tigers now down a point it
might be time for some risks here by way
yep he's I think he's not really exactly
making progress because we've kind of
had this position before
oh
what a mistake oh we did just do that
with three minutes on his clock I was
just about to say it's insane Rook B5
was very sneaky to play Rook B2 check
but he was forgetting that his own
Bishop was on B8 he had so much time
Dania
oh my goodness this is gonna be a
heartbreaker for the Gotham Knights and
I actually think I'm on that if he had
moved his Bishop calmly he does have
good drawing chances especially Rooks go
off the board that was insane but we've
got one game still remaining it's been
winning for Jew and June for a while but
kashlinsky is holding on for dear life
she is down yes a full night this is
completely winning but you and Juno
struggled a little bit here and she's
down to 30 seconds I'm on you can win
this in so many different ways even
Knight G2 and Knight takes F4
transitioning into a winning pawn and
game where you've got the opposition is
totally winning
that's the one I like you know just keep
it nice and clean
um don't have to worry about anything
but I don't think uh I don't think there
needs to be any lessons in technique
here it's more of a you know Choose Your
Own Adventure is so many ways to win the
only way not to win is to allow the
trade of all the pawns but you win June
H5 there was a really easy win and get
your king over to G4 she's down to 17
seconds I don't know where she's going
okay eventually it's time to you know
get on the pot so to speak
yep I I think taking the F4 Pawn is the
the easiest it's the one I like the most
I don't I think maybe if King E5 King E7
wants to be nice okay Elena's made it a
little bit easier there uh now she's
going to resign because she simply drops
the F4 Pawn it's hard to play these end
games down down a full night yeah
yeah in the women's world champion
strikes with an important win for the
Tigers that means that we are all tied
up Hikaru of course has won his game
that Bortnick awesome one that was kind
of a heartbreaker in the early going for
the Gotham Knights because that at least
should have been a draw given the time
situation
yeah definitely well given earlier on
when you know Wei Yi was having some
camera issues and he was way down on
time uh position looked great for it way
down on time you really did that I mean
that is the lowest of the low hanging
fruit I'm on at least you should reach
up and grab some of the apples I thought
that uh you know it was that kind of
show I might was I misinformed
I mean you'll have to Alina on me uh as
we okay I I need to stop this right now
nip this in the bud because we've got
three more rounds ladies and gentlemen
to cover in this fascinating PC all
match the score is two to two it is all
tied up first team to in the half wins
we'll have more car Nakamura way and
Gotham Knights against the Shanghai
Tigers coming up in just a couple of
minutes
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this
chapters
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
that's in this position from this
position white is winning about 60 70 of
the time and I think if you learn these
lines that very easily could be 75 or 80
for you
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
women's world champion Juan Jun she is
laughing I mean to this she finds a
commentary totally of glorious as is
everybody of course June June is such a
huge addition to any team uh the
Shanghai tigers are lucky to have her
and she is an integral part of their
lineup we can see there that June June
is part of the super six six women who
have surpassed the 2600 feet a classical
rating Judith poger doing it I think at
the age of 14 and 15 and June doing it
for the first time in March of 2017 a
month
yeah only a handful of uh these women
have played in the PCL right so it's
it's exciting to not only recognize the
uh the accolades of these these strong
chess players but also we have them uh
here playing in the PCL
it most certainly is we're lucky uh and
and just it's such an honor to be
commentating on all of these amazing
players not just super GMS in 2700s but
such a nice medley uh and mix of really
really interesting players that
hopefully the fans are finding all about
where we're finding we're finding all
about how close this match is likely to
be because the score after one round is
two points a piece we had no no in the
first round with Nakamura winning his
game and Vladimir fetise of winning a
very nice positional game with the black
pieces but on the Shanghai tiger side
their top two boards Wei and ju and June
delivering as well so really no upsets
among in the first round but in the
round two matchups we see uh slightly
less lopsided matchups at the top Essie
Cara Nakamura faces shuyi Vladimir
fedesev is White against Louis ping it
looks like another must-win situation
for Nakamura and fed to say if we could
get another 2-2 round them on if we
don't see any upsets but something tells
me that we might see at least one draw
exactly I mean the the way the match has
gone so far it's it's as if you were you
know only taking the expected results
right the of course the top two players
on each team they won their matches
that's what they're here to do
um really close on bortnick's board so
definitely that's the only standout
result that you're sort of eyeballing as
both teams as you know a missed chance
if you're the Gotham Knights but also
very fortunate uh to be tied to too if
you're the Shanghai Tigers so you're
looking at the the round by round
lineups right here and and yeah it's
gonna be a tough round ahead every
single game is where points can be
scored there's not there's not like you
play against that camera and you think
you have no chance these are 24 2500s
you don't walk into a game against
Hikaru and just think that all hope is
lost no you're you're there to give them
a good game and there's shuyi on on
camera looks like he's playing from like
a tournament Hall yeah I mean this is
like a serious serious flying venue
right there uh putting himself in the
mood but Lu you ping he did it give
Hikaru Nakamura a close game it wasn't
easy and there is really no such thing
as an easy PCL game because these top
guys they've got an x on their back
right you you always want to be that guy
uh to defeat Hikaru Nakamura even if you
lose the overall match that's something
that you can really hang your hat on and
so Hikaru knows that all of the Shanghai
tigers are going to be trying extra hard
to deliver at least a draw let's see if
Hikaru delivers a first move here within
a normal within less than two minutes
there we go he plays one E4 and let's
see what should he will put in front of
Mr Nakamura
yeah the um so Nakamura won uh with the
black pieces last round so as the as the
board one it's always a nice feeling
start off with a win with the black
pieces now you're coming in and you know
interesting experience as a board one is
that every single match you play every
single game you play gets harder and
harder that's just how it works your
opponents get tougher and tougher so uh
Nakamura definitely playing a bit of an
offbeat line here Dania when it comes to
the Petrov Knight takes E5 but then
Knight back to D3 what do you make of
this and now forward it goes to F4
creating the obvious threat of Knight D5
so don't fall asleep and play Knight C6
if you're playing with the black pieces
I'm pretty sure black typically drops
the Knight back to F6 leading to a
forced Queen trade white can't avoid the
queen trade so Hikaru kind of making his
bets that he will be able to outplay
Black in a kind of a long drawn out end
game but I would even hesitate to call
the ensuing position and end game I'm on
because we still have all of the other
pieces on the board so definitely still
plenty of room for tactics and a lot of
the middle game rules do apply uh even
with a pair of queens off the board
yeah absolutely C6 is the chosen move to
stop Knight D5 I'm more familiar with
your move Knight back to F6 but it looks
like shui wanted to I guess leave a
little bit more uh of something in the
position right keep some pieces on the
board night in the middle but I mean
Knack is not having any of that he says
okay F3 you're not gonna play Knight F6
I'm gonna force you get off me get out
of E4 and the other the other important
thing is that after Knight F6 that
Knight is going to be fully restricted
by the F Pawn so maybe it's worth for
sure you know to bring the Knight back
to D6 in order potentially to be able to
reroute it to F5 no he does go Knight F6
but these subtle considerations among
are what these types of positions are
all about you're not going to get a
check mating attack actually scratch all
of that because Hikaru said you had your
chance to trade Queens you didn't
exploit it and now I'm gonna make you
pay for it yeah he wants the Queen's on
the board all of a sudden and Bishop on
F1 I mean eventually both sides Bishop
Ford and Bishop they're gonna either you
know have to move the queens or we're
gonna see some strange fan ketos uh
coming out from both sides this is just
such an atypical opening when you think
about like five okay how do you develop
where your pieces go what pawns do you
push early on this is the worst game to
show beginners oh absolutely I mean we
don't even understand why these moves
are being played okay that I do
understand and Hikaru without any
hesitation he castles Queen side I think
he's going to go after Black's King as
quickly as he can him on another thing
that should be pointed out black might
and very I think probably will Castle
Queen side himself but that pawn on C6
the king becomes a bit of a liability
there's no question that if both sides
Castle Queen side I would rate White's
attacking chances as somewhat Superior I
like hikaru's position here Bishop D3
rookie one he's just faster to the
center
definitely yeah and blacks pieces I mean
if you're playing Bishop D3 Bishop takes
on D3 the Knight can come back and
capture Knight on D3 is a great piece
hitting the C5 E5 squares and you're
drawing the arrows uh just as fast as
the pieces are actually going to show up
there Rook H1 and E1 is super
frustrating to deal with because if you
want to get your king out of the way
then it has to be Queen side I can't see
you having enough time to move your
queen move your bishop and get your king
kingside castle before you know
Devastation hits with Rook H1 and E1
that's the drawback of fiancato and it
just takes so long and Bishop D3 is on
the board Hikaru I think already smells
blood in the early going and that Queen
on E7 could end up bleeding after white
truck gets over to E1 you don't have the
D6 Square because if Bishop F4 I think
sure you already has major problems to
solve right out of the opening H5 I
think was a little bit too Cavalier it
was a cool looking move and an
interesting opening but When the Smoke
Clears there's no question that Hikaru
has a clear Advantage this could be a
quick knockout win if Shoji is an ultra
precise in the next couple of moves well
as he contemplates how to solve his
opening problems Let's Travel back to
the bird's eye view because all four
games are underway we do have a Berlin
in the top right between fedesaf and
Louis ping now let's say I'm actually
playing a very fashionable line with
that early A4 and a benoni structure
between Wei and olena kashlinska how
that's right Adam for size
yeah I mean if I'm looking at the most
exciting uh positions I'm definitely
drawn to the Berlin of course
um riveting up there in the top right
but you know by popular demand uh Dania
do you know for the chat of course I
think we're gonna maybe choose another
another one um I'm I'm looking over at
Wei Yi's position
um against Kesh linskaya he uh I think
the opening in general the benoni just
always gets super imbalanced positions
uh middle game struggle so I'm looking
at that game as an interesting one to
drop in on and I'm looking at Jew and
June's board as well so let's look at e
against kashlinska and then go to that
chaos which is occurring in Jew and
June's game against mikola Bortnick but
first I do think we should do a quick
overview of this benoni structure
because really understanding structures
that you don't play can be one really
good way to sort of increase your
general level of Chess knowledge and
ideas can be borrowed among from one
opening to the other I think a lot of
players and fans uh they kind of get
disappointed when there's an opening
they don't play with either color but
that doesn't mean that some common ideas
can't exist this actually started as a
Kings Indian so question didn't intend
to play the manoni but C5 was a response
to the rare line that way he played the
bishop was on G5 it got kicked away with
H6 and then coachlinska struck at the
center with C5 what do you make of this
yeah the interesting thing about this
position
um maybe compared to more traditional
benoni's that people might be used to
seeing is that night on C7 often that
night spends its time on D7 Knight on B8
developing to D7 is more natural from C7
you know it doesn't have as much control
over E5 but black has ideas like maybe
bishop D7 Rook B8 and pawn to B5 so
that's a big plan all of a sudden for
Alina but you know I mentioned the E5
Square not under as much control and
neither is the B6 Square white has ideas
like A5 Knight C4 to B6 so it's really
about black at B5 or can white stop that
So to that end I also like the way the
weight that was unintentional I promise
I like the way I mean I mean it's early
in the morning when my mind's sharp so
wait he's put his Bishop on D3 and in
the main line of the modern benoni you
often see the white Bishop on E2 the
reason I think this is an improved
version has to do with the fact that
after Knight C4 white C4 Pawn is well
protected so if we pull up an analysis
board here really quickly if Alina plays
Bishop D7
and white stops B5 with A5 then actually
black can use that square for the Knight
you can see the eval bar dropping that's
not what's going to happen White's gonna
play Knight to C4 and if the D6 Pawn
falls in the benoni or if you have to
play this incredibly ugly move I can by
the way just follow up with Bishop F4
you can see how quickly Black's position
simply falls apart I mean you have to go
here and things are not getting any
better after an ip6 so let's not talk
about this line Alina has in dead
instead put her Knight on D7 among
rather than her Bishop which I think is
a reasonable Choice given how crammed
she is she wants to meet Knight C4 I
assume with Knight D7 to E5
yep you're you're calling it exactly and
I think it's a good point for people to
remember just look at where the pawns
are located of course white has that
d-pawn pawn on D5 way more space more
real estate for pieces to move around
which means the more pieces on the board
don't generally be beneficial for white
to have uh you know more pieces on if
black is trying to you know fit all
these pieces it's like a puzzle there's
just just not enough space for where
every every piece wants to go so Knight
C4 95 trade those nights off then we
have the D7 Square available for the
bishop and it's a little bit harder for
white to attack D6 we've got total
Magnus Madness and we call a board next
game against you and June so let's do
two things we have somebody named Levy
Rosman who is waiting in the wings to
help us make sense of his team's game so
that's first order of business Levy
welcome to the show glad to have you
hi guys what's up thanks for having me
hey hey Levy welcome we were uh Danielle
were we gonna check in on the absolute
chaos that's streaming on one of these
boards because uh this this might be an
exciting one to get Levy's take on as
well yeah and I wanted to get Levi's
take on sort of Nicola portnick I think
who's making his first PCL appearance
first game didn't go his way but Levy
how excited are you to have someone this
underrated capable of basically beating
everybody
yeah we were just talking about this on
my stream with uh our esteemed manager
manager of the Year 2023 already decided
uh International Master Alex ostrovsky
and um yeah we were just saying how this
guy mccola has a rating of three
thousand Blitz you know I I'm sure both
of you guys have played him I've Had The
Misfortune of playing him I know Dania
you've probably played him like 500
times uh and last game he really he had
a great position against Wei but he got
2 700 did uh and I yeah I saw this game
his his position is uh
kind of insane and I I mean the engine
isn't giving it the full blessing so I
don't know exactly what's going on but
the craziest thing is as good as he is
he is technically I think the underdog
in every single matchup and it just goes
to show you how absurdly stacked not
just the Shanghai team is but just all
of the protest League
yeah yeah you guys actually have a
similar roster whereas you know some
teams come in with a 2200 on board four
but it seems like the Shanghai tigers
and the Gotham Knights this week at
least coming in with a lineup of people
that you know can pretty much win every
single game was that a bit of strategy
uh Levy maybe on on your part or the
manager to bring in a lineup where
everyone can beat everyone
well yeah so we didn't know exactly what
to do going into the season so we
thought we would get a two twenty seven
hundreds and be balanced so today we
have 2400 2400 and we looked at some of
the best women in the world but it's
hard because there's a lot of women's
candidates events there's a lot of uh
European championship for example but
actually uh Amman uh you guys inspired
us to
have two lineups because when we saw
that you guys had Magnus and we were
like oh like they could feel Magnus
uh sarich and like a 2600 maybe in like
a 2200 we're like uh oh yeah so we dude
we were looking ahead man we were like
if if it's bras and Gotham in the finals
like we need uh we we've been calling it
The Giga lineup yes and uh you know
you're well I'm not you're bored for it
could be like a 2200 but yeah dude I
mean I don't know Shanghai crushed uh
the Blitz and the blitz had a monster
lineup last week so yeah I don't know
man I mean I think It ultimately comes
down to the the players and the games
hmm I'm not making any bones about who
I'm rooting for I'm on in a bras versus
Gotham matchup because I'm rooting for
the team that didn't send our Charlotte
cobras into a Tails then I'm gonna let
the chat figure out which team that is
by the way I was kind of transfixed on
this position and I hate to be that guys
get a series and look at the game uh but
Nicola boarding has just covered White's
attack on the queen with Knight bd7
instead there was a ridiculous line Levy
I think you'll be entertained by this as
well if we could pull up an analysis
board here Bishop takes E4 was a
possibility for black trying to deflect
the knight from its protection over the
bishop and after Queen takes E4 the best
move is Queen takes H3 how did your guy
not find the smooth Levy come on I think
you need to recruit some new players
yeah I don't know what the hell is going
on in this game I mean this is the best
the Catalan is supposed to be like a
subdued opening that takes like 40 moves
to convert some plus point two meanwhile
like both of these players are hanging
on a knife's edge by the way my stream
doesn't see it because you guys have
like the live board but uh yeah there's
like some completely insane fireworks in
this game and oh I I yeah it just
happened on my stream there's a line
here that mikola was like minus one and
a half or something but yeah I don't
know what is happening here this is like
uh
this is terrifying is what it is but
it's also not bad because if you win
with black as the board four of a team
you can't really complain
that's the board four I was gonna he
says
report yeah even say that
um but as a board four aren't you happy
to just have an insane position like in
general kind of like increases the uh
you know the fluctuation of the uh the
eval bar like I think here the eval bar
has been sure in Jew engine's favorite
but at the same time I think it could
flip with just a single move
yeah I think against the 32500 rated
players on China's team for sure I think
against Wei Yi it was the total opposite
for mikola because there was a moment in
that opening that he could have seized a
really nice Advantage I think and he he
sort of was just like I'm not going to
lose this game and he wasn't losing it
for a while but then you hang a bishop
in one move and it's like you just feel
what have I done I spent the whole game
trying not to lose instead of trying to
play the best moves I always like to say
in those situations like if mikola was
playing me he would have won that game
it's just you you adjust your strategy
sometimes based on your opponent yeah
this game is insane total knife's Edge
no clue I should also point out that
Hikaru will I be more good news for your
team
I don't know where to start in his game
whether it's the fact that he's got
seven minutes and 20 seconds against one
second but if we go back to the birds I
do I'm not even worried about jinxing it
with Hikaru because you just know that
the game is in such safe hands let's
watch Hikaru deliver the last couple of
moves he's playing this like a hyper
bullet game and I think he's got good
reason to do that Levy I assume it just
must feel so reassuring to know that
you've got a car on your team and he
when he's got a winning position you can
breathe easier with Hikaru having the
winning position than just about anybody
else
yeah literally I mean just like Hikaru
Magnus obviously on the team is uh is is
uh is a super super nice thing uh
actually there's there's something and
yeah we do see the final move there and
a resignation my my chat doesn't see it
just yet but uh the really I think the
one of the most impressive things that
we've done thus far you guys might not
know this but we had to do a lot of
study on these players I had no idea who
zhui was and he's just like an Uber
solid 25 like 40 like fide guy last week
he had no problem holding grishook no
problem holding mvl he like doesn't lose
and it's really reassuring that our big
dogs just gave him two losses because
that's like a mad strategy I mean the
guy was taking half points off everybody
last week and here we have Hikaru and
phariseev like super dominant display
this guy played the Petrov he car said
you want to play the Petrov welcome to
the 2700 club and gave him you know the
super GM treatment and that's what you
need to win these matches yeah I mean
it's ridiculous he cars spent like two
and a half minutes and he beat a guy
that I would probably not beat 10 of the
time so it's unbelievably impressive he
dealt on his first loss since like 2003.
yeah has just been a complete Buzz side
as he always is well Levy uh we know
that you're streaming on your own
channel so we will let you get back and
uh chill watch your games In Peace So
Levy always a pleasure to have you on
good luck to the Gotham Knights
especially if they face the Canada chess
bras
yeah uh we will definitely need it
that's definitely the matchup that
people want to see thanks guys uh have a
good rest of your commentary all right
see ya
okay
that we could bring him on for some some
wins you you don't always bring the
guest on and get to share like a nice
moment sometimes they join the broadcast
and it's like oh yeah uh all your guys
just lost by the way
that's the worst because you just know
how disappointed they are and yet
they're trying to keep it all buttoned
up and and nice but you can just sense
it uh this is looking really good for
the Gotham Knights they already have a
point in this round Vladimir fed is
saved is clearly in control in the top
right but I'm still looking I'm
transfixed on the bottom right because
I'm watching Jew and June's clock
continue to dwindle as is Alina's game
by the way I think Alina might be flat
out better in that benoni line against
Wei this is getting crazy
yeah I'm starting to see what could be I
mean it's a flip on that final board
between portnick and Juan Jun but we
could honestly see the knights like here
I see like potentially sweep this round
listen Hikaru one that I save should win
his game barring some sort of turnaround
in the time scramble and these other two
games are complete toss-ups so I
absolutely could see this go for oh I
could also see this go to too if we can
pull out this position in Alina's time
pressure and if ju and June keeps her
composure in that utterly chaotic uh
struggle against mikola portnick so
what's going on here Kalina Kalina Alina
has just taken on D5 the eval bar was
not a huge fan of that move and I think
the reason why I'm on is that lets the
queen get active and if you can if you
move the bishop out of D7 you're
potentially walking into an incredibly
nasty floor
yeah and I'm I'm trying to see what you
know the the move is That's So Special
here I mean sure we can just push Pawns
in the center onto E4 upon to F4 but
specifically pulling to F4 I was
concerned about because I'm thinking
okay white moves the bishop what is the
the next move for for black because you
have to be careful that white doesn't
start controlling those light squares
and just blockading the Pawns in the
middle
yeah and we shouldn't forget that B7 is
also hanging if you take that pawn you
hit the bishop so it's a total 50 50
position but that was an excellent move
by Alina that was the whole point Queen
takes B7 runs into Bishop C6 with a
double attack against the queen and the
main thread on G2 but you're right way
he drops his Queen back and he is
preparing to drive the bishop into D5 to
keep the queen as stable as possible
I was even I was even considering Rook
takes C4 here to try to play people C6
after that I'm not sure if it actually
is good or not because white can yeah
throw that Rook up to D5 but man it
might get really spicy here all of a
sudden
Elena's playing some incredible chess
right now B5 keeps her foot on the gas
pedal and forces this bishop out of C4
it might seem like white wants to go to
D5 anyway Amon but if you play Bishop D5
too early I'm looking at Bishop F5
followed by E4 and when black center
pawns are set in motion there will be
hell to pay
100 and Bishop D5 blocks the
communication from The Rook on D1 and
the pawn on D6 so all of a sudden on D7
just isn't a move after black moves the
bishop
now this is this is getting crazy way he
is now down to two minutes he survived
the first game when olena kashlinsky
just seems so confident and she's got
nothing to lose right you lose the game
okay you're the board four that's the
luxury of being one of the lower rated
players all you really need is one point
here half a point there speaking of full
points it looks like mikola boardnick is
gaining the upper hand against you and
June Who's down to 10 seconds I think we
should go back to our bird's eye view
and see if Nikola portnick can finish
this game off he's up a piece still Jew
and June are their last seconds trying
to keep harassing the king of mon I feel
like White's initiative is fizzling out
at a Breakneck Pace it definitely is
ortnick all of a sudden on top and I'm
looking at the the clock being the
deciding factor I mean Bortnick cannot
let this chance go amiss right after
that uh game one where things just went
South for him uh from a great position
you cannot afford to pass up and this
opportunity
and part of not letting that happen is
managing your time well you don't want
to get into a Time scramble here you've
got four minutes on your clock take five
ten seconds per move at least get your
Rook into the game and get your king
over to B7 don't try to win uh you know
the game in three moves here and I think
Bortnick is handling this exceedingly
well if Jew and June pulls this one off
I literally won't have anything to say
yeah no I don't see that happening at
all I I think that Bortnick has got this
I also think that what I mentioned
earlier is kind of coming true where
it's a good feeling to have like a
absolutely insane toss-up position where
your board four is is uh is in the game
like you want to have these tumultuous
evaluation swings that's what it's all
about because uh it's paid off here
this was phenomenal decision making by
mikola in the opening not getting
discouraged after that first round loss
knowing his worth and I hate to say We
Told You So as The Rook comes into E2
that will signal the end of June June's
resistance what a win for me Cola
portnick but I'm on it was pretty clear
that working was not about to go 0-4 no
absolutely not uh this is just the
reassurance that that is indeed the case
but no we we saw how capable he was uh
he was not going to go 0 and 4 he gets a
win here which is huge for the knights
but I see Federal sale because we're
looking at a bird's eye view what is
going on in that game Daniel looks like
a queen it's a draw I actually think
that might end in a forced Perpetual
check because even if white promotes to
a second queen queen takes F3 keeps
White's King at Bay so black is gonna go
King hunting and Vladimir frederasev is
going to try to escape the checks with a
series of zigzag Maneuvers with his King
I'm also partial to the way you
kashlinski game which is now officially
reaching the time scramble is
kashlinskaya is now up in exchange so
come on if you don't mind could we maybe
watch the end of that game because this
would be a Monumental upset if even
Alina could pull out the drum but feta
save is now winning again well Dania I
officially mind oh my gosh okay let's go
to feta save and watch him Dodge the
checks here because blacks let the king
get out of the cage yeah it seems like
this was a really crafty idea Queen
takes F7 earlier played by fedosea and
he was he could have made a queen Daniel
he could have cleaned his Pawn on the
board he said no uh don't play King D5
here I think wait we need two oh C4 oh
oh my gosh
the entire game right there and then he
would be losing because he'd make
another queen but you would lose the F3
Pawn now the key I'm on is to chart a
course to the right area of the board
which area affords you the best
opportunities to dodge the checks I'm
not sure and he's kind of zigzagging and
Meandering for now the nice thing is you
don't go on the right direction answer
to that question as white but you do
have to have an answer to that question
as black
there's a lot of pressure on breathing
to pick the right checks versus when
default save to pick the right defense
exactly because you can see that even
blundering the queen doesn't even really
blunder the queen because he's still
have C4 I think Vladimir is doing all of
the right stuff that's it no more checks
look at his Queen on D5 dominating its
vis-a-vis nothing left to play for what
a win for the Gotham Knights oh my life
to potentially see a 4-0
Helena kashlinsky is completely winning
but she's down to 40 seconds if she
forces a queen trade in this position
the Gotham Knights are going to go 4-0
this is unbelievable look at her
position insane I was hinting at this
earlier but I didn't even believe myself
when I said 4-0 was possible here
yeah I mean I was surprised when they
told me I'd be compensating with Lamont
Hamilton I'm like maybe hypothetically
possible but is that really gonna happen
but let's be real I'm on the game is not
over look at Black's King Black's King
could just as easily get checkmated it's
easy to blunder your queen here and
Alina must be alive right about seven
yeah only move on the board I think
there King H6
maybe even H4 to cover the G3 square
like E2 Bishop D2 right it's weird you
might almost get mated oh my gosh Bishop
D2 is a devastating move and queen B2 to
follow up that's the last thing you want
Bishop E4 by the way is a ridiculous
defense Queen takes E4 Queen takes G8
dude
he's freaking 2700s man you just cannot
bring them down five seconds now for Wei
who's had a spotty connection so you
gotta make sure you're not flagging
Jesus
Bishop's coming to C3 Maybe
uh oh but not immediately because G3
hangs oh my gosh that's a main threat
that's a maid threat Rogue G8 don't
blunder mate
time is ticking H4 might be a nice move
for black
H4 I think was winning on the spot I
mean back to G5 and then go H4
Jesus C3
oh
no he didn't he's gonna win
thank you
it's mate it's mate queen h8 queen F6 oh
yes oh my God what man Swindle he pulls
it out Daniel and way he is the sole
reason it is not a 4-0 round
and a forward round would be this is
such a Monumental result for Wei Alina
goes for the win she was one move away
Amman I think if she went H4 in that
position a couple of moves ago it wasn't
just oh you need some more precise moves
that was game over White's king would
get massacred by Black's heavy pieces
there instead of Lena blunders the E3
pawn and White's Bishops decide the game
a huge result indeed but come on let's
not miss the forest for the trees still
a huge round all things considered for
mikola Bortnick and the Gotham Knights
yeah that that we can't forget just
because you know way you pulled magic
out of a hat there absolutely but it's
still a three to one round obviously
Levy will be super happy to see that his
top boards continue to perform and
whenever you get a point a full point
from your board four and yeah it's
always a really really good sign going
forward
it most certainly is and we see their
the individual score sicaro we've gotten
used to Excellence he is displaying
Excellence once again he's got two out
of two well I don't refer to save
likewise and Alina kushlinsky will hold
her head up high because if you're that
close to beating uh your opposing teams
board one with the black pieces I think
that Mode's really really well for her
chances in the final two rounds well
folks we'll have the final two rounds
for you coming up soon but I'm on I
think there might be something else
coming up pretty shortly isn't there I I
think there is Daniel we want to make
sure to remind everyone while the PCL is
super exciting of course the women's
candidates finally comes to a head
that's Tuesday March 28th after taking
down six of the strongest women in the
game including ecl's very own Katarina
lacno and Alexander kostenia lateing G
and tanjong Yi are now vying for a seat
across from reigning women's world
champion who just saw her in action Jew
engine we're bringing you the live
camera feeds and the exciting commentary
course of that match and you'll be right
here twitch.tv chess use exclamation
mark candidates in the chat right now
for all of the details Dania that is
going to be super exciting I think this
match is shaping up to be super exciting
we had a 3-1 round there's work to do
for the Shanghai Tigers but we are going
to be right back everybody stay where
you are because it's five to three for
the Gotham Knights you won't want to
miss the next round
thank you
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary
Cloud analysis opening Explorer and
table bases find all the key event
information including schedules prizes
results news reports player bios tie
breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
thank you
[Music]
foreign
well Hikaru Nakamura might be traveling
but he's not letting him stop uh he's
not letting that stop him from being the
silent engine of this incredible Gotham
Knights team Hikaru is two out of two
but the supporting cast from Master him
on Hamilton has definitely arrived for
the ride
yeah you can't uh you know say enough
about Hikaru Nakamura Anya you can see
his overall PCL record there nine oh and
one and we should point out for people
watching that that one loss came way at
the beginning of this entire PCL Journey
so he's been undefeated since it's hard
to imagine your team not doing well when
you've got a guy on board one that is
basically winning every single game look
at his overall PCL record Dania I mean
76 wins this is insane
all the good all he does is when you're
telling me he won nine games in a row
that's that's out of this world he won
the three remaining games in the match
that in which he lost against heinemann
then he went 4-0 and now he's going to
oh and these games aren't even close
it's not like he's in these time
scrambles he just crushed a grand master
with eight minutes left on his clock
when he delivered Checkmate but this
time hikaranakamura's opposition gets
even stronger let's review the lineups
for round three the score ladies and
gentlemen is 5'3 in favor of the Gotham
Knight so they could hypothetically
finish this match in this round with a
three and a half or 4-0 performance but
way he is going to try
to uh stop your car knock more but they
are not playing in this round they are
playing in the next round right now
Hikaru faces a different difficult trial
in the women's world champion Jew and
June
yeah and I should point out as well that
uh Hikaru nakura and Wei both still have
those undefeated streaks alive if you
will uh 4-0 weeks still possible for
both of them it would be really exciting
to see if they were both 3-0 going in to
the final round Wiggy barely kept that
streak alive with that last round
Swindle uh I'm excited for these uh the
pairings this this round Hikaru against
Juan Jen is going to be an incredibly
exciting matchup when Jun has the white
pieces in that one and you see
hikaranakamura there I mean I feel like
the the guy doesn't need his
professional setup his lights camera
action no just you know a lamp will do
uh the skills the skills are there
regardless give him a lamp a three Mbps
internet connection and he is good to go
of course ikaro is streaming uh so he is
making sure his setup is optimized and I
think another X Factor game is going to
be Vladimir Freda saves game against Wei
because Wei has not inspired confidence
the first two games among he was one
move away from suffering a shock defeat
at the hands of Alina kushlin sky but
that's what great players do even when
their form is not ideal they make it
happen but hikaru's form has been ideal
thus far in the first two games what
strategy is he going to adopt in the
opening is he going to go all out I'm on
or is he going to play something a
little bit more tame
I I think the the thing about when
you're at that level you're so strong in
chess is that even when you're playing
in a way that's kind of boring or not
taking much risk there's still so much
that the other player has to to put in
to just neutralizing or not getting a
worse position so I feel like even when
Hikaru is just kind of chilling or not
trying to work too hard maybe he's okay
with the draw
the guy just accidentally gets a good
position and that's one of the
collective factors that we uh
collectively refer to as the Hikaru
effect right it's part of it is that
feeling that you're always worse even
when
rationally objectively you know that
you're not in Hikaru he's assayed a BOGO
Indian with his last move e 6 E5 he
wants to carve out that juicy C5 square
and his Knight is ready to jump into
that square at a moment's notice of
course if you take twice and you're
going to potentially lose a piece uh
along the D file after the trade black
can put a rook on d8 that seems out of
the question is Jew and June likelier to
just keep the tension yes she actually
adds to the tension on the queen side
yeah and actually a plan that
um that I've seen white do a lot in
these positions is something along the
lines of like you know a knight going to
F1 and to E3 so maybe rookie one Knight
F1 knight from F3 to D2 and then the
knight from F1 to E3 white eyeballs that
D5 square but also wants to leave that
d-pawn on D4 because the Knight on A6
you can already see if you ever push
that pawn or capture an E5 C5 squares is
right for the taking
that night is going to be on C5 faster
than a teenager you know eats a free
donut
um and that brings back some memories of
yes uh College donuts donuts in the dorm
lounge and by the time you come there
two seconds later the night's already on
C5 and there are no Donuts remaining
okay I need to stop talking about Donuts
because now I want one I'd have to do a
little Dunkin Donuts trip during the
commentary month I think you'll be able
to handle it but let's see if it's June
June I'm fine we'll be able to handle
the tension in the center how about that
transition
hey that was uh that was pretty uh
smooth I see no holes in that transition
unlike Donuts
um and unlike the C5 Square
I like milking this hat to the extreme
Rook D1 okay same idea I I guess the
Rook going to uh D1 also means though
that the e-pawn is not supported and you
know these these nights aren't so easy
to uh to move another way I was just
thinking you could bring the Knight
there tonight each four to F5 to E3
hmm
and I guess the benefit of that is that
you're simultaneously protecting the E4
upon which has just become a lot more
important than see Carlos put his Rook
on E8 I love positions like these
because they're not about King safety
both sides they have no problems with
their King but their centers are not
safe the tension has reached a peak Aman
and it's a battle of who flinches first
because if white plays D5 does that lose
the game immediately are you much worse
no but you've conceded the C5 square and
that's exactly what Jew and June has
done she waited for Hikaru to play
rookie eight now The Rook on E8 kind of
looks a little bit dumb so she's gained
the tempo in a way and Knight T5 really
isn't the end of the world let's not
overstate the case
yeah I I have to say the way that my you
know brain sort of functions is that oh
white played D5 game over black black
wins yeah exactly that's C5 Square you
you couldn't have given up that square
um obviously as you pointed out it's not
the be-all end-all but it does mean that
strategically Hikaru has achieved
essentially the maximum what his
position could hope for the Knight on A6
defending the B Pawn on B4 if you ever
capture it the knight's just gonna take
back I think the way that you engine has
approached this game is just it's too
compliant
um in her play
and her last move was even more
compliant because what she does is
closes down the queen side eliminates a
source of tension that I think is
favorable for white because it was
keeping the A6 knighted Bay I was going
to point out Bishop C8 is automatic in
this position why well you might be
rerouting your Bishop to G4 but more
importantly you're preparing the sort of
typical King's Indian type plan F7 F5
white is completely devoid of play on
either side of the board I'm on and as
crazy as it sounds um Hikaru is close to
being positionally winning here as much
of an exaggeration as that may seem I
really don't think it is I think Jim and
June has misplayed this considerably
yep I think Hikaru has a tremendous
position this is what I was talking
about he might have played this opening
thinking to himself I've started out uh
fantastically in uh the match so far won
two games I have black pieces right now
I don't mind making a draw play in a
solid opening maybe play for a win with
white in the last round instead he's
just accidentally winning like he just
has a great position for no reason
and easy play which is so valuable in a
rapid game Bishop G4 F5 the cost of a
move here is not high even if black
makes an inaccuracy he's so so solid
that it really is hard to ruin your
advantage car doesn't really make
inaccuracies though and I think things
are getting worse and worse here for the
Women's World Champion we'll see if
she'll be able to wheel her way out of
this highly unpleasant position in the
meantime all four games are underweight
ladies and gentlemen so we're going to
look at our bird's eye view and some of
them have already reached a wild
position I'm looking at the top right
way against better save exactly the kind
of position you don't want against
Vladimir fedes typically and the
grunfels game on the bottom left is just
as crazy among
yeah the the bottom left definitely has
caught my attention with that sort of
wean on H5 like what the heck is going
on there that'll save against Wei is
just such a star studded matchup
um probably one of the closest games in
the round but how do you not take a look
at this position like we know an H5 hey
first things that are coming to my mind
F3 and G4 or Knight to F4 and guess
what's coming H5 and The Rook on H1
would like to join the party
I'm just captivated by Alina
kashlinska's change to appearance in the
last couple of hours I mean
you can never really pin her down you
never know who's going to take your
place we're gonna go back to the bird's
eye view for a second
um Alina is in the kind of position in
which the Evo bar might be showing an
advantage for white but that's the great
thing about the grunfels I think similar
to The King's Indian Iman even if black
is objectively much worse than the
grundfold the game is never over because
White Center can really collapse at any
moment yep that's a great point and
probably one of the reasons why you know
at the very highest level you know you
maybe you don't see these openings as
much but completely I mean they just
make for such exciting games uh in the
meantime Rook d8 D4 clearly a Target
here it is defended adequately but you
know it does tie every single piece
Bishop Knight and queen to that defense
interestingly Black's Queen is almost
trapped if it didn't have the A5 Square
Knight G3 would win the game on the spot
you can imagine a black Pawn on A5
Knight G3 would simply trap the queen so
black has to keep an eye out for that
there could be ideas like D5 and then
Knight G3 of course in that case the E5
Square opens up That's a classic
scenario right where you take away one
square some doors closed but you
inadvertently open other doors what
catches your eye here from Alina sajuchi
play Rook B1 something more positional
or should she go full pedal to the metal
D5 Knight F4 Etc
I I think there's a sort of a phenomenon
that happens when you're in a position
uh like this with Alina clearly having
an edge
one thing that happens is sometimes you
fixate on that Queen on H5 and you go
all out you're like okay I gotta get uh
the queen traps so let me defend the A5
Square you know Rook B1 Rook B5 Bishop
D2 and you're fixated only on trapping
the queen Alina has to realize and I
think she does so credit to her her
position is fantastic because of the
queen on H5 just play the game right
just develop your pieces bring the
pieces to good squares there's no need
to rush if you can trap that Queen in
stride go for it but I like her choice
King F2 just says okay back to you what
the heck are you doing with the position
she's not gonna compromise her structure
and make too many concessions trying to
win that Queen and win the game out
right instead he just passes the move
back and says oh yeah you figure it out
I think that's a great explanation and I
think as menacing as the pressure on D4
might seem this is the worst of the
enemies that white is going to face
black literally has no other pieces that
can be recruited to the cause of
attacking the D4 pawn and God forbid the
movie E5 is not only terrible because it
blunders the queen but even if Knight G3
didn't exist white could meet that with
D5 so yeah attacking the pawn of the
pawn isn't always uh a Panacea black
could try some tactics with Knight takes
D4 I think this might be something uh
it's worth calculating for yipping Lou
but I'm on I'm so pessimistic about any
of that working because again anytime
black plays E5 white not only can
respond with Knight G3 white also has
the simple move G4 and at the very least
that's going to win a piece so yipping
Lou takes a fundamentally different
approach he tries to trade off the dark
squared Bishops and soften up the D4
Pawn even further I'll tell you one
person that didn't like that move Mr Eva
more
that uh that eval bar is man he's tough
to please I tell you it is yes Jesus try
everything never works is uh I mean it
really is logical when you think of like
okay after we maybe trade these Bishops
Black's Queen might have an Avenue to
safety Queen H6 Queen G7 so I'm
immediately fixated on Queen C1 to just
if you take me up take right back with
the Queen the status quo is not changed
Queen is still in trouble from H5 uh
Pawn is still defending on D4 so Queen
C1 looks like a nice option there might
even be better I'm not sure
I think Queen B3 is a move that achieves
the same exact thing the the primary
point is that you're reinforcing the
bishop on E3 but you're simultaneously
attacking F7 I like your move to Oman
because it forces Black's hand it hits
the bishop on H6 and provided that you
don't lose the D4 Pawn white is dominant
on all three sides of the board that's
ultimately why Black's position is so
unappetizing but Alina takes a more
concrete approach I don't know about
that she takes on H6 and she's going for
checkmate down the H file but black
could keep things relatively closed down
and you mentioned Avenue to safety Iman
Alina better have something in mind
against this move because D4 is now
officially hanging
yeah and uh I mean I I just think that's
uh gotta call spade a spade I think
Bishop takes H6 was a blunder like a big
time mistake yeah uh Queen B3 and queen
C1 just maintaining control of that
diagonal
um leaving that Queen stuck on H5 I
think that was the way to go now you're
looking at that d-pawn and you don't
really want to play D5 it Blocks Your
Bishop gives up the E5 square but at the
same time it's like are we really
surviving and basing this whole line on
King E3
yeah I mean King E3 Knight takes D4
becomes uh a much higher likelihood now
that black doesn't have problems with
his queen that was the main issue that
black was facing and Alina she solved
that issue for him Bishop takes H6 is
one of those impulsive moves you make
and two moves later you're like what was
I thinking maybe she overestimated the
impact of the H file but the queen on G7
is just such a phenomenal defensive
piece Bishop D5 though I think is a
level-headed response by Alina and you
know let's not overstate the case I
still think that white has the advantage
but Alina's work is going to be cut out
for her as black Ponders the way to keep
his initiative his newly minted
initiative going let's go back to the
bird's eye view because we've got some
crazy developments on a couple of the
other boards one board that hasn't had
any crazy developments Amman
unsurprisingly I think Hikaru continues
to display surgical technique against
Jew and June that's completely in the
bag
it is yeah that that doesn't look like
there's any chance uh for jewinja in
there I mean Hikaru has been so dominant
and his position looks remarkably easy
to play
um I trust that that he's going to be
winning that game I'm looking at now the
rest of the games because if I'm looking
at this from you know the Shanghai
Tigers perspective we need points on the
board here right uh where are we gonna
get them I see Wei and fedesev in a you
know a tight battle there but uh Daniel
where are these points coming from is it
way Yi is it chewyi
I think at this point in the match for
Wei it's essentially a must-win game
because you think about it Alina
kushlinska might very well win her game
even though she's let a lot of the
advantage slip if she does that's
already two points right there you're in
the territory where you can go down you
know eight four at the end of this match
and let's be real you're not coming back
against a Gotham night scene when you do
when you need to go 4-0 so let's see how
way is doing he does have the kind of
unbalanced position that you would want
in a must-win situation there's a small
problem I'm on in that I think he's got
the worst end of the stick here yeah
it's like uh there are a few things that
go into the checklist of what kind of
position you want in a must-win game and
it's like imbalance check better side of
the imbalance can't quite check that
um
I like the idea of either balance that's
that's something right
and it's an imbalance not in terms of
the pieces right when we say imbalance I
think players often think well where's
the Knight versus Bishop where's the
queen versus two Rooks that's not the
only type of imbalance when the kings
are Castle to opposite sides of the
board that's just as much of an
imbalance which creates oftentimes just
as much Intrigue as you would get when
the players have differing pieces on the
board now first of all I'm going to make
a very controversial observation so I'm
on you might have to save me from you
know raising my rotting crowds yeah I
think black is up a pawn here which
might not seem like a problem right now
but as the Rooks get traded I think Wei
might be borderline lost his last couple
of moves were very sloppy he gave up the
E file and the e-file is the main
conduit that blacken used to get more
pieces off the board
yep no that's uh well said Rook E7 is
also a really really good move I think
it takes the e-file by force here so
you're up a pawn protected pass Pawn I
think fed of save is in control
completely oh my gosh this is a this is
a disaster in the works right now for
the Shanghai Tigers see karodakamura has
officially won his game they have now
reached six points all they need is two
and a half more points they could
conceivably get it this round if
Vladimir fedes finishes this game off
let's go back one more time to the
bird's eye view because those two other
games now they officially become
must-win games for the Shanghai Tigers
if they want to have it's not only if
they want to make it to the force round
them on if they want to have any
realistic chance of staging a comeback
yeah I mean we talk about how strong
teams are you you see the Shanghai
Tigers week after week they look
unassailable oh now look at this
position
my lands how did that happen it feels
like she's made five moves and black has
made zero yipping Liu has gotten nothing
going against the D4 Pawn nothing and
ultimately I'm on Alina's strategy to go
down the H file it's been a dashing
success she's gonna go Rook H1 Queen F6
and Checkmate black on the on a chain
there's nothing that he can do this
looks so simple I'm wondering how you
even form a defensive idea like you're
just pointing out the obvious oh my gosh
Queen F6 not Rook h8 first but Queen F6
even the queen trade is fine white
calmly takes back and says okay Rook h8
is waiting for you that's mate in one
the queen trade actually makes matters
worse but it doesn't matter okay it
comes even without the queen trade I
think what says it all is the top
computer recommendation which is Rook d8
takes D4 and you might say oh that's a
brilliant rucksack black gets counter
playing no after Knight takes D4 black
is supposed to offer a queen trade with
Queen takes C5 so that's the only way to
Stave off Checkmate this game is over
and yeah this is not even Mike this is
crazy
pulls out a drawn this match is over oh
my God I can't believe I'm even saying
that when you have these two Powerhouse
teams matched up against each other
again it's also official oh my God has
won his game
oh it wasn't even close wait you just
resigned he blundered a second pawn and
there was nothing left to play for he is
disappointed and discouraged as is
yipping Lou I think his facial
expression says it all it's basically
down to Nicola Bortnick if he pulls out
a draw this matches over in this round
even if he doesn't that will still be a
crazy blowout the Gotham Knights at
least will be up eight to four it's hard
to say that I mean it's crazy you know
like imagine going into the last round
it's like all right uh fortnite
[Music]
Nakamura I'm gonna need half a point in
total and we win it's like great I think
we can manage that
I'd like to go to the mikola boarding
game because I think the results of this
game is not in question yipping Lou
might very well resign In This Very
position yeah there's nothing left to
play for more good news for the Gotham
Knights I think Bortnick is handling
himself very well I think he's got to
draw in the back yeah you can oh my gosh
you can almost force a draw with a
Perpetual of some sort so I mean
Bortnick has done all he needs to do
he has indeed and he scored that crucial
Point against Jew and June that gave
them the Boost that they needed this is
a dead Drive I would just take the
bishop I'm on I wouldn't even play
around with these checks Knight takes D6
C takes D6 and maybe just Queen C8 and
queen takes B7 and Black's actually on
the defending side there I'm even yeah
if I want to make a draw I'm looking at
Queen C8 Queen F5 and like how is that
ending I don't know
when said and queen C2 is a four-straw
literally a four straw let's see if Levy
might type in the chat in the group chat
that all we need is a draw Queen C8 and
queen F5 is probably a drawn Pawn end
game but there's no need to calculate
here yeah but I mean he can also just
sit there right play H4 there's
absolutely no need to do anything insane
I think he's located Queen C2 and
barring absolute Insanity on Cashland
Skyes board this should be the match
Daniel I can't believe that's even
coming out of my mouth right now
he takes B7 McCollum boarding might say
hey I'm now playing exactly just to make
a you know a cowardly draw here but it
says you make sure you don't have any
problems you checked me that's the meta
game because we might meet again Queen
E5 check
yeah Borden explained for a win here I
mean King G2 was a draw I don't really
know why he's doing that yeah and I
think he's got to be a little bit
careful among because he is kind of
playing with fire and you don't just
want to like give this game away yeah
you're gonna win even with an 8-4 score
but you don't want to give even the
slightest inkling of a chance for a
miracle yeah and I think but you can
Reign it in at any point because he has
this Queenie for Queen E8
um you know draw mechanism so I truly
think he isn't risking a lot but you're
right if if he has that mentality that
oh I have to play for a win at every
moment here you might mess it up
I said this yesterday I'll say it again
today for the purposes of the team match
you're not an individual player and
ultimately you have to sacrifice your
individual intentions for what the team
needs and we saw players agreeing to
withdraw with an extra piece which is
what you're supposed to do if that
guarantees victory for your team I agree
I'm on I was overstating it a little bit
white is not risking here at all
and I think a true offer might actually
just be forthcoming
indeed and oh my gosh Alina's up a queen
oh oh she's gonna win her Queen eh yeah
look at that position where is Black's
Queen Nation
time to repeat moves like the good team
player that you are yeah we need four
we'll seal the match it's unclear if he
knows that at the moment however it's
also probably the objective you know
best decision overall so
he continues to play on for by seemingly
no reason
this must be driving Levy crazy he's
just like I just feel the deal make the
draw
but I can hear he's got all of his pawns
protected yeah I would be the same way
if I'm watching the a game and it is a
draw and all we need is a draw and
they're not making the draw it's like uh
excuse me oh God I mean the pawn end
game might even be winning for white at
least White's not risking in that
pawning game that's for sure
but I've seen ways I mean you can lose
every single Pawn doesn't matter how
much better your king position is it's
always possible to mess it up but I
think Levy still has a little bit of a
little bit of anxiety here oh and
apparently the pawn game is now winning
yeah I'm I'm kind of wondering so it
does make sense that if you take with
the d-pawn that it may indeed be uh be
winning I'm wondering what happens if
the F Pawn captures oh I think you just
make your way to the queen side I kind
of forgot Amman that there was a pair of
Pawns lying in weight on the queen side
white king is just a lot closer to B5
I mean look we've been talking about
being a team player but what about being
an absolute stud and just winning out
the last round just like on demand
getting a w and your team winning nine
to three in round three against the
Shanghai Tigers I mean that's a
statement
we call a boarding by the way is an
incredible end game player I've lost so
many pawn and games to him and I was
totally convinced or unusable so he's
gonna invest some time and calculate
this I have no doubt in my mind that
he's gonna calculate it accurately I'm
on being a stud that works too that's
going to win you some matches are we
actually seeing a potential 4-0 in the
final round in a match where both teams
were 2-0
um I also want to mention first of all
yes second of all it almost happened
last round let's not forget it's almost
like back to back 4-0 performances from
this Gotham Knights team I mean Daniel
are they cementing themselves as one of
the scariest teams in the PCL right now
listen we've had a couple of teams look
Unstoppable you pointed out the Levits
off chess boosters well they were
stopped yesterday in this match the
level of unstoppableness had reached
entirely different proportions among
this was the kind of scary level where
you're like if our team pulls out half a
point in any of the rounds that's
already a miracle this is insane yeah
it's over well boarding's gonna win he's
gonna play H5 the pawn on G7 and he's
just gonna walk his King over to G7 and
use this Pawn as a decoy it's a 4-0
final round
that's just incredible
um I'm I'm you know just languishing
here because we don't get to see a final
round Dania but yeah I mean you can't
complain when people are putting
performances like this on the board you
have to just tip your hat this Gotham
Knights Team game to play today and this
Bortnick Edition to board four I mean
what a sign
that is an incredible signing they've
got such a well-assembled team basically
every one of their players from Hikaru
Nakamura obviously to Nicola boardnig
are capable of getting a plus score and
when you've got a board four that gives
you this kind of push you're already one
of the top teams in the league they're
gonna make the playoffs after Bortnick
wins this game they will be the second
3-0 team after the Indian yogis I don't
think anybody is even remotely looking
forward to the task of facing the Gotham
knights in the playoffs oh my gosh man
yeah G6 so the idea is H5 and if it gets
captured you take back on H5 the king
gets to F5 and I mean the win is so
trivial
yeah the pawn race is kind of like a
Ford Racing against a Ferrari Black's
gonna go after the uh the B Pawn but
he's about seven Tempe short
yeah I think he's gonna resign right
here you know the the issue that I'm
having with this score line Dania is
we're not seeing a round four which
doesn't give me as many games to see
fiancaros and I'm just I'm I'm
distressed what can I say
that's actually that must be a
conspiracy man they heard your
prediction you were doing well in the
first round by the way h8 equals Queen
check
and it's official it's official round
three ends in a 4-0 victory for the
Gotham Knights unbelievable final score
of this match I don't even want to say
what it is as we look at Nicola portnick
there
he's got a little bit of that half smile
on his face he's checking the match
might not know the smile is going to
grow
his smile is about to grow to a full-on
grin yeah
like oh dang you guys did what I just
did as well nice oh there's no final
game nice
safety in numbers and there's no numbers
on the board for the Shanghai Tigers
well there is it's zero it's zero
everybody loses
this was the craziest blowout that we've
seen in the PCL thus far and there's no
debating that
and something interesting that I I just
saw in our uh chat here Greg shahadi
saying that the playoff seating depends
on the margin of Victory so potentially
this is like very impactful here for
like first seed versus second seed
Daniel so everything seems to be going
in the Gotham Knight's favorite with a
nine to three final score you don't even
need to play the last four games
that's I'm I'm totally speechless I
don't know what to say I think the
scores really say it all the final score
ladies and gentlemen is nine and three
two separate players had perfect scores
try that on for size three points for
Hikaru three points out of three four
Vladimir feta seven Hikaru has now won
his last 10 PCO games you've got crazy
performances all around and to help us
unpack these performances will be the
team captain for the Gotham Knights Levy
Rosman we're gonna set Levy up and hear
his thoughts on this absolute blowout
but first we're gonna take a short break
you're watching the pro chess League
don't go anywhere folks because we'll
have Levy Roslyn for you and then our
second match of the day in just a couple
of minutes
foreign
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level most
importantly all of our courses are
powered by chessable's exclusive move
Trader technology which uses the science
of space repetition to make sure it all
sticks
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
my inspirational reading about great
players from the past great great
performers from the past Arthur Ashe
reading his life his legacy
Jackie Robinson who was even earlier
after reading about people like that
Malcolm X and Dr King their Journey
James Baldwin
those are people who made me feel as I
was pursuing this this history-making
moment if you will that
I wasn't really going through stuff that
was that hard I mean I know we were
still and still are in the middle of a
deeply divided Society in this way where
the struggle is still real for African
Americans where equality of treatment is
is something you thought should have
happened a century ago but or at least
in the last century but it's still
happening today
but it's not like it was
and I understood that I'm standing on
the shoulder of the Giants and they were
absolutely my inspiration in dark
moments difficult times
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the pro chess League we
just witnessed perhaps the craziest
match the craziest blowout that's for
sure of the protest League thus far the
Gotham Knights have blown open the gates
against the Shanghai Tigers 9-3 the
final score and Levy Rosman the one and
only is joining us to share his thoughts
Levy congratulations that was ridiculous
it was ridiculous and uh listen I I will
uh I will thank you for having me on
because I I am like the uh the
cheerleader and the Creator behind this
team but uh all credit to the players
and the manager of the team because the
Strategic lineup that we put in this
week was absurd and the performance of
all the players was completely
unbelievable but I will happily be our
glorified cheerleader on camera because
just on just unreal honestly uh what a
performance absolutely not what we
expected
yeah I mean Levy you you're you're the
captain that's what you got to do take
the credit man you uh you put the lineup
forward now I wanted to ask you about
that lineup because obviously it worked
wonders today you just kind of came out
ahead on all the 50 50s but what do you
think about some of the lower board
performances like Alina and Bortnick
getting in there and scoring crucial
points for your team Bortnick was wild
he like I when you guys had me on in the
second round I it's kind of everything
we wanted he's it's sort of what went
into planning a lot of our lineups so we
we looked for young talented players we
also look for guys like Bortnick who is
criminally underrated In classical chess
in my opinion uh and in the manager's
opinion as well and uh we just didn't
know if bullet and Blitz would translate
to Rapid and man it did like his nerves
got in the way in that first game right
he hung the bishop but second game was
absurd and that could have gone either
way and that's just how it goes
sometimes today a lot of a lot of things
went our way but he was he was great and
Alina's playing style was also
super super aggressive fun to watch and
she almost deserved that second game but
way Yi did what 2700s do uh but it paid
off in that third game so uh yeah I mean
you can't ask for much more it's like
everything went right that could have
gone right today
yeah Lena played amazing against Wei I
mean she was basically one move away
which is crazy I mean it's the end time
your board four gets a chance to beat
the opposing sides board one at what
point Levy in the in the final round I I
guess technically it's round three uh at
what point did you start suspecting that
a 4-0 victory might be possible
uh I I didn't I mean I I thought it was
gonna happen in the second round because
everybody was doing so well right like
it literally almost did happen in the
second round I mean Hikaru just it
really helps when five minutes into the
round shikaru already got you a point
right like I don't know if the players
know that but let me just tell you as
the commentator uh I don't I haven't
followed the chronological order of the
chess bra matches but like I'm sure it's
the same you know Magnus won all right
we got a one point lead great uh good
feeling yeah I mean it's it's a really
nice feeling and he was taking care of
business like as if he had like
somewhere to go like he had a business
meeting to attend uh and uh
uh the rest of the games in the last
round the way you lost just came out of
nowhere because it looked like he had a
nice position from the opening and um
uh I was confident that Lena was going
to get it done but
it was so wild man like there was
literally almost a chance that we won
two games back to back two matches 4-0 I
mean it's
I've I did not expect that going in I
was super nervous uh to play Shanghai
and
yeah team pulled through
I think that's the the thing Levy with
like uh you know teams that are 2-0 you
look at them and like okay these guys
are never losing a match like these
teams look insane and then uh you know
based on the lineup that you put forward
in a certain week it could just work
wonders as as it did for for you guys in
this round like uh you know going into
this and now seeing the result levia put
you on the spot here do you think you're
one of the absolute favorites in the in
the protest League
so that was still CBD
uh I was gonna say that was still TBD uh
I think before this match today but uh
yeah I mean after seeing today it's kind
of hard to argue I mean we fielded a
lineup today that just so like my
manager was explaining this to our
stream you have to have a lineup that's
25.50 after all of the rating
adjustments and our lineup is 25 49.75
literally like if if any player was one
or two ELO above their current rating it
would not work and unofficially it's
over 2 600. so I think on paper we've
had like two if like the top three best
lineups but that doesn't always
translate to points because it you have
to be a good rapid player you have to be
good Under Pressure you have to be good
against people higher rated than you so
uh if it works it works you know but
there's other teams that are perfect and
um you know if the bras field
the three stack again and you know Eric
doesn't have a rough day you guys might
get 10 points in a match so I anything
can happen that's like I'm happy we win
3-0 but they're still really really good
teams uh in this league so I'm I just
want to keep you know
keep doing it the way we've been doing
it
well I mean it's going in the right
direction Levy we've got a couple of
featured chat questions you mentioned
that it's not only about ratings it's
also about experience level and how good
these players are in Rapid time controls
and Under Pressure BJ h13 asks Levy can
you talk a bit about having a woman as
strong as Alina kashlinska on your team
how much of a boost uh has that giving
you and how much of a boost will it give
you as you get into the playoffs
we actually have I don't know if it's on
our official roster if we made any
adjustments but we have like four women
on the team all of whom are really good
we might have had to remove one because
she wasn't available but we we were
gonna have nurgul salimava who's like
winning every tournament in Bulgaria
she's like 20 21 and she's probably
gonna be a gym within a year or two but
unfortunately she had a lot of classical
tournaments committed to
um buxa Natalia books are super strong
and we have like a young player in
Kazakhstan who's 2200 and 2700 Blitz and
fits in with a three stack right so she
would fit in with like a Hikaru fatasev
and then like Shield which is what we
ran last week and she had a you know she
had a rough outing but she was playing a
lot of really good players so uh it it
really helps I had no idea what was
going to happen today in in Alina's
games I I didn't even know that she was
so aggressive like did you know that
because I did she she went after
everyone's head every game and
she was winning against Wei and you know
that It ultimately uh paid off in that
in that third game so uh
I I really like this lineup this week we
didn't know what to expect when boarding
you know uh Nicola was like play the
youngster I don't know if I'm in As Good
As formism and I would say he's in
pretty great form I don't know what you
guys think but yeah he seemed to do
pretty well so uh yeah I don't know I
mean it got a good team good team of
four and we got Liam now who's played
only one match so uh but I don't want to
jinx anything you know we're in the
playoffs but that doesn't mean we want
anything
yeah definitely it's a really impressive
lineup uh Levy I got another chat
question for you and I'm a big fan of
this question would love to hear your
take uh screws02 ask question for Levy
were you upset that Bortnick was not
immediately making a draw in the final
game now obviously it was going so well
for you that even if somehow you know
disaster strikes he loses pretty much a
favorite to win the match but still as a
captain you know onlooking there were
you were you uh thinking hey man where's
my draw
no so there was something really funny
you can't contact the players during the
match like they don't know the score but
they have access to a spreadsheet I'm
not explaining this to you guys just to
the audience uh they have a spreadsheet
they can check to have the scores and my
ma and my manager was like oh I forgot
to send it to them this week
so we were just cracking up like you
know Nicole is probably out here
grinding a result has no clue what's
going on in the match oh man like maybe
if I lose this half a point we're gonna
like lose the match or something and
meanwhile just three you know 3-0 and uh
maybe uh the Chinese player uh Zhou was
like looking at man I gotta play for a
win you know and obviously backfire it
so uh no I wasn't too upset I mean it's
hard to be upset when you're up eight
three like you secured a playoff already
you know so uh but no
um you know I I don't think I think
hikara was a little a little rattled by
the Elena way ye game people you know
Chad was relaying like he was like
watching it and uh but it's hard to be
mad when you have a five point lead I
think in this format
yeah that's okay unbelievable Levy final
question and we'll let you continue
chilling on your stream if you're the
manager of the Shanghai Tigers how would
you handle a loss like the one that they
just suffered what would you be telling
them and would you be making any serious
line of changes if you're trying to get
them into the playoffs
um
well they have a very balanced lineup
now right I think they just need
I I'm actually surprised they feel the
two the same lineup three weeks in a row
because it had so much success which
obviously can't blame them but I would
figure against the Hikaru in another
2700 like they would have you know they
would try to find a way to field uh Wei
and like you Yang Yi or Wei and uh but I
don't even think you Yankee is on their
roster I think it's like nihua and I
think maybe they have another player but
um I don't know I mean it I think it's
really hard to win the protest League
without two 2700s but 2700 rapid like
fedes is underrated he's 26-68 I think
classical but over the board rapid he's
27.50 so
you need these short time control
Specialists that won't tank and that
have like good openings that can kind of
be more flexible in this 10 minute
format
um that's all I would I would say but I
listen I thought their lineup was
ridiculously scary like I thought Jew
and June could easily get two and a half
or three and
like I'm saying it you you have like
some small moments in every single match
and this match literally every moment
went our way so sometimes that happens
and sometimes it you know it happens the
other way and momentum is everything so
uh but very tough to win I think without
two players that are
top 15 top 20. so but I'm not the
manager I'm the glorified cheerleader so
I just come here and talk about the team
and Mr ostrovsky makes all the decisions
well Mr glorified cheerleader we
appreciate all of the Insight this was
such a fun match to watch
congratulations on making the playoffs
we'll let you take your rest that was an
amazing wire to wire Victory Levy
congrats once again thanks guys cheers
that was fun Dania that was oh I've
never seen that I've never been witness
to a three-round match before
yeah I knew it was possible
hypothetically I mean the cobras I think
might have lost in three rounds in that
third round but to see it unfold and to
see and unfold them on with a team as
strong as the Shanghai tags we're not
just saying it I mean they were 2-0 for
goodness sake they have the numbers to
back it up and you know you're a monster
team when you make other monster teams
look like the victim right the yogis did
that to the Levitz off chess Wizards
yesterday but this was on a whole nother
level
yeah oh this was on a whole other level
Dania um I mean we saw the overall score
there speaking of those other matchups
let's look at the overall standings here
you see the week three standings they
are now updated with the clinched
playoff spot where not only the Indian
yogis but the Gotham Knights joining
them as the the two teams that have
qualified and the only teams that will
qualify from week three day
and you just have to be realistic I
think if you're the manager or the
captain for other teams and you just got
to say listen if the Gotham Knights Play
the way that they play today if they
display this level I don't think there's
any team in the league that's capable of
stopping them at the end of the day you
just have to hope that one or more of
the players shows at least some signs of
being a human particularly Hikaru
Nakamura but the yogis are definitely a
force to be reckoned with and if you're
the chest Wizards or the Norway gnomes
or you know Canada chess bras not
telling you kind of what to do or what
to tell your team but you can get too
discouraged I mean you're still two in
one you've got every shot of making the
playoffs you're gonna have at least two
more shots of making the playoffs and
just because a team has suffered a loss
doesn't mean that it can't Avenge the
team that defeated it potentially in the
playoffs that's right
um you know while there are people at
the top of the standings as well there's
also people that have fallen to the
bottom of the standings and without
naming any names myself Daniel without
telling you what to tell your team
I wonder who will be joining them St
Louis archbishops and the Berlin Bears I
can't even believe that one of these two
teams is going to be eliminated but
that's uh gonna be an incredibly tense
matchup to uh to look forward to as well
listen you just see how this could have
gone another way this just shows you how
evenly matched the teams in the PCR and
I think how well formatted the
tournament is right that's what creates
the entry the idea that a pre-tournament
favorite could be sitting on zero two
and steering down the barrel of
elimination but like I said at the start
of this match I think we're still going
to hear from the archbishops I think
they're going to hunker down and we
might very well see three victories
rattled off in a row obviously
realistically that's an incredibly
difficult task to achieve but the
passers uh and of course the teams that
we have playing each other in the next
match the Blitz and the Croatia Bulldogs
any one team can defeat any other team
in any particular match so we do have
ladies and Gentlemen The Blitz featuring
agad Mater's team the Croatia Bulldogs
they've got some incredibly strong
rosterism on so if anybody had work
plans I asked to meet their boss for
brunch just forget all of that you won't
want to miss our second match of the day
will you no I mean this is a different
uh type of matchup it's not two 2-0
teams but I think it might be closer for
that very reason the 2-0 teams it's like
even if you lose you're two and one you
really don't want to be one and two and
as you said staring down the barrel of
elimination with two losses going on
three that really puts your team in a
tough spot so these teams at one and one
right now Dania have everything to play
for
yeah it's a total toss-up it's a wild
card listen if this match isn't closer
than the previous match then we're in a
lot of trouble if we see more of a
blowout than 9-3 well I won't know what
to say so you can count on this match at
least reaching round four I think it's
going to be a really entertaining one
and we will delve into the rosters into
the round by round lineups uh and into
the sort of nature of this match but
first we're going to refill our coffee
cup soap ladies and gentlemen you're
watching the pro chess League one match
down one match to go and before we
refill our coffee cups you Oman I have
another announcement to make oh my gosh
fine go ahead Dania I just want to
remind it give me a break I want to
remind people we're in a new month it's
March and this month we are celebrating
women who have changed the world with
the March bots on chess.com challenge
Mary Jackson NASA's first black female
engineer test your skills against Ada
Lovelace often recognized as the first
ever or computer programmer what lines
will the Visionary and activist Malala
yousafzai bring to the chessboard you
don't want to miss your chance to find
out you can get these new Bots uh over
there at chess.com play slash computer
they will disappear once once March ends
so head over there quickly and use
exclamation mark
whm in the chat to play now
Daniel we have some new Bots we are uh
not going to be uh going to a break
without a tear in our eye that we didn't
get around for but I will say I'm
excited for round four potentially in
this upcoming match the teams have a lot
more to play for so everybody stay where
you are we are right back with another
match and this Pro chess League action
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
in competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
oh those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
what a beautiful tactic the Indian yogis
are the first team to make it to the
playoffs
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights spraws and
Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
what a stunning move this is just
unbelievable what he does entering its
fifth season
teams will reboot the PCL Legacy with a
new format and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion
it was a huge pottery
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
and the bee Pawn comes oh my goodness
Miley way to go girl that's huge
that is huge for us
well ladies and gentlemen we just had
some of the most ridiculous two hours of
the pro chess League thus far and it's
been a great pleasure commentating I'm
GM Daniel nariditski alongside Grand
Master Amana Hamilton and we just
witnessed Amman without question the
craziest blowout of the protest league
is the Gotham Knights beat down the
Shanghai tigers with a score of nine to
three
incredible incredible I mean it's one
thing to just say that was the craziest
or most impressive or widest margin of
defeat uh just you know on a on a whim
but it actually was dead it truly was
the most one-sided result the Gotham
Knights punched their ticket into the
playoffs of course we'll still hear a
lot more from the Shanghai Tigers but
what a match earlier today that was and
Dania the upcoming match will surely not
disappoint either I think it's going to
be even closer
hey well you know the bar is set pretty
low I think the most impressive thing to
me uh about the Gotham Knight's win I
forgot about this until like two seconds
before we went live which is that the
score after one round I think was two to
two I mean this was tied and this went
off the rails in only two rounds both of
which could have easily ended with a 4-0
score and the fact that Nikola borknick
didn't even go for the draw to secure
the match no he actually won to hammer
home the total sweep that might have
been the Osman Alpha move that just
encapsulates how much of a blowout this
was
yeah I I think I'm looking at the
Shanghai Tigers right now they haven't
changed anything right from their uh
from their lineups and I think it might
be time we look at the week three
standings and Shanghai Tigers they're
fine they're two in one right there
there's still a win away from qualifying
to the playoffs but it might finally be
time Daniel to shake things up in their
lineup they've used the same lineup for
all three weeks if it ain't broke don't
fix it well it just broke
well and some of the other teams are
broke as well the manager and the
captain roles they might sound very
cushy and Monica you just kind of sit
back and once you initially assemble the
roster you just kind of watch them play
no you're actually making a lot of
decisions about the roster and those
decisions are very impactful and of
course the chess bras the California
unicorn some of the one and one teams
for those teams I mean the manager and
the captain must be feeling nervous
because in the next match a lot of their
decisions uh will either prove very wise
or they will dig themselves further into
the hole because three strikes and
you're out of the pro chess league but
there's only one team uh that's out of
the protest League thus Farm
yeah I've only won there's hopefully one
team and I would like to say that that
uh result has actually freed up a
certain someone for commentary today
great to have you with us uh an
unrelated news Dania but indeed the
Charlotte cobras uh bottom of the table
there the first team eliminated but not
the only team there's gonna be either
the St Louis archbishops or the Berlin
Bears they're going to be joining them
they will face off against one another
but the match that we have for you guys
right at the top of that standings list
you can see the Blitz and the Croatia
Bulldogs one and one there's such a big
difference from going two in one and one
and two it doesn't it doesn't just feel
like you know this is just one random
match no this this puts you on the brink
of elimination or almost punching your
ticket in to the playoffs yeah you've
been saying it from the start the
difference between two and one and one
and two one in which you feel like okay
just one win away out of the next two
matches and we're in the other one more
loss and you're out two Polar Opposites
so these two teams are going to be in
completely opposite places at the end of
this match but teams like the Garden
State passers and the Brazil copy baras
I mean we got blown out the Charlotte
Cobra has got totally blown out by the
Brazil copy bar as I'm on and when you
lose a match like that you start asking
man how does this team lose to anybody
that's what we were wondering about the
levitov chest Wizards yesterday until
they got blown out by the Indian yogis
so it's a hierarchy in the protest
League one team looks like a monster one
day they look like the victim uh in the
next and we'll see which team is the
monster and which team is the victim in
today's match between the Blitz and the
Croatia Bulldogs their rosters are
pretty mouth-watering them on yeah no
we're we're jumping into the rosters and
there's a lot of things to talk about
here the Croatia Bulldogs they're 1-1
they're LED at the top by Bogdan Daniel
dayak super strong player at 2700 but
the thing is it doesn't just drop off
from there Daniel there's a there's a
star-studded list of cohorts here
Alexander indich from Serbia Grand
Master is uh is also going to be uh
showing up for the Bulldogs he is such a
strong player he's actually played for
the chess bras in previous Edition
before so I know uh firsthand just how
strong of a player he is and how much
he's worth at 26 30.
yeah that's a great pickup and in
general the Bulldogs have a lot of GMS
in the rating range 2500 to 2630 that's
a rating range in which a lot of Chess
fans I think aren't as familiar with
some of the GMS who occupy that vast
space but I actually think they've got
quite a few good pickups I'm looking at
Leon levage was a very exciting young
player he recently became a GM he had a
very bad run in the Bulldogs loss uh
last week so he is itching at the
opportunity for Redemption and some of
their female players as well Eline
rubers had a standout performance in the
Tata steel Challengers where she
dispatched a couple of players over 2600
and Paulina shivalova who's playing
today again is basically for all intents
and purposes of GM that's right I mean
the this lineup here is such a strong
one I also am drawn to bardia danshavar
which is another
um uh I think it's another player that
is worth way more than just 2500 we talk
about you know essentially you know for
all intents and purposes a GM I think
bardia is very much in that category uh
standout performance recently by by him
so I'm looking at this team and I
basically I think my summary is that I'm
looking at a lot of players that are
likely worth way more than their rating
would indicate
you're absolutely right by the way
dineshwar we got word a couple of weeks
ago did complete his final Grandmaster
norm and his rating unofficially is over
2500 so oh there we go rightful title
you called it uh even without knowing it
will be confirmed pretty soon at the
next few day Congress let's confirm the
roster for the Bulldogs opponent today
the blitz are one of the most
fascinating teams in the league you
called them a family team because there
are a couple of couples and Father and
Son relationships in the blitz you got
the two back rows you got the two
cornets and you got Katarina lagno and
her husband Alexander grishek I love
that Amman yeah I I think I spoke about
this earlier with the Shanghai Tigers
how you know everyone on their roster
was from China you could see the
camaraderie in between the rounds
everyone's laughing have a good time
likely sharing analysis and you know
truly wants the best for one another I
get the same feeling about the blitz
right it's it's captain of course
blitzstream Kevin bordee as put together
roster of mainly French players but also
free shook like no you know they have a
connection literally like no other and
this team has been fun to watch so far
that was really smooth now I'm on let me
ask you this when you've got let's say a
couple like we're Shook and lag now or
even Father and Son Etienne and
Alexander do you think there's a little
bit of healthy competition that might
happen which might drive the players to
do better like hey I did better than my
I mean I'm sure that Alexander Grisha
Katrina lagno didn't let Alexander
grishra forget his rather mediocre
performance last week so do you think
that actually contributes to uh the
motivation that some of these players
feel
I I would actually say yes but only
because they're on the same team so it's
like you're competing against one
another for fun and it kind of motivates
you you want to do better you know you
definitely want to do better than your
son I mean that that's a clear rule of
the house but also if you were playing
against one another that's I think when
it gets dicey you know husband against
wife I mean look I I like my ELO but I
also like sleeping in a bed so yeah you
gotta you gotta make some decisions
um
well you also have to make some roster
decisions because you can't just play
all of your top players there are some
rules and requirements in particular
each team must include at least one
woman every week uh the total cap uh
average rating is 25.50 but there's some
good value to playing players over 2700
uh who count as 2700 and women over
23.50 such as June June they count as
23.50 so once again the captain and the
manager don't just have kind of a cushy
role they actually are really involved
in the decision making and these
requirements are in order for the teams
to be as evenly matched and as
intriguing as possible I think we can
safely say I'm on uh that these
requirements have produced one of the
most fascinating PCL seasons ever maybe
the most interesting ever so I'm a big
fan I'm a big fan of these requirements
yeah I think they I think they bring a
lot I mean they allow people to be
flexible with the rosters but also
you're able to have those you know 2700
plus players on your team without
feeling you know constrained as we look
at the board assignments of 2700 flowers
yeah
just a few of them over there on the
blitz
oh geez yeah they're they're household
names shall we say but obviously the
Bulldogs have uh 27 of their own and
Bogdan Daniel dick if I'm looking at
these boards top to bottom here Dania I
definitely think that the you know
obviously we're not going to get these
board versus Board matchups until the
final round but on board three I'm
looking at bardia for the Croatia
Bulldogs that have a big performance and
over there on the blitz I'm actually
looking right to the top Alexander
Grisha you hinted at it earlier did not
have the most you know scintillating
performance last time he needs to step
up as board one and score more points
than he did last time
he most certainly does and I've been
saying this from the start I think there
are two large-scale strategies the teams
can adopt when choosing their rosters
you can have the sort of evenly balanced
team like the Chinese uh like the
Shanghai Tigers uh had or you can have
the sort of top heavy team where you
have two super GMS uh but then you have
a slightly weaker board three and four
and if you're adopting that strategy
among I think you want to have the kinds
of players like mahel Boyer who I
pointed out uh last week when I was uh a
guest commentator for about five seconds
uh with Hess and Danny handling the
duties that Boyer's one of those players
that a lot of people don't know but I've
played him in a bunch of title Tuesdays
and I know that he's capable of
delivering a couple of upsets so if
you're Boyer and if you're cornet you're
not necessarily aiming for a four out of
four performance you're offloading the
heavy lifting two or two super GMS but
you need to get them on you need to get
half a point here a full point there
that might be the difference in this
match
yeah that's a great point and yeah we
see these are the board assignments but
these aren't how they're going to be
matched up initially right uh obviously
things start off with Ward one against
board four so we see the round by round
lineups here this is round one grishook
is starting with the black pieces
against Paulina
mvl on board 2 also starts with the
black pieces I'm immediately drawn to
the uh board two and board three
matchups because I think you have two
very hungry very talented IMS on both
sides Mahal Boyer and bardia and ashfar
both of these players are going to be
looking with the white pieces mind you
looking for a big uh result to start off
round one uh Daniel I'm looking at both
of those boards as potential upset
situation
oh completely I I agree and even though
on paper round one is the most lopsided
matchup because board one faces Port
four first of all we've seen board four
defeat board one on several occasions so
we're not just saying this uh to keep
people in their seats I mean we saw
Alexander castenoke defeat solemn solid
that's just the first thing that comes
to mind in like 20 moves uh so for
Paulina shivalova I mean she's got the
white pieces she's an incredibly solid
player this is not just a walk over win
or Alexander grishock and I really think
I'm on that my Hellboy era is not
thinking of this game as one in which he
just has to hunk her down and try to eke
out a draw I think he's just flat out
playing for a win and probably not even
looking at himself as that much of an
underdog given how good he is in in
Rapid time controls yeah given how good
he is and there's another sort of X
Factor there given how young he is I
think in general the the younger players
are just so confident right they're
always ready to play for a win there's
never a position in front of them where
there like yeah you know whatever I'm
fine making it draw I think that's the
uh that's my mentality That's the older
Generations mentality Daniel they're
like I'm willing to take a draw here and
go home no I think the PCL is all about
uh you know the hunger the determination
to win and knowing that a half Point
versus a full point for your team is a
huge difference in in the value that you
bring so I think that he's absolutely
gonna be hungry here he's going to be
looking for results and what better way
to start than an upset in round one to
really give the blitz some uh some
confidence going forward
yeah and of course bugged on Daniel Dash
also has to step it up he had that
incredibly incredibly disappointing game
against Darius virch in the Croatia
Bulldogs loss that actually was one of
the big reasons that they are not to no
so definitely a shot at Redemption for
the young Romanian Grand Master and
well the PCL is a fascinating tournament
and part of the reason why is the format
so if you're not aware of what the
format is well again where have you been
we hope you're here now because the time
control is 10 minutes with a two second
increment uh the teams play a match
consisting of up to four rounds the
first team to reach eight and a half
points cumulatively wins the match that
can happen in three rounds and now I see
that that actually might happen in three
rounds and the event of an eight a tie
we reached tie breaks where uh the
players maintain their round four
match-ups board one plays board one Etc
but if the time control shrinks to three
plus two so Amon if we get another three
round match I think I might just quit
PCL commentary for the rest of the
season yeah if we get another three
round uh well rushing I I think that's
just even more unexpected than the first
because like I mentioned in our previous
match
two teams that are uh you know two and
oh I can theoretically see a more
lob-sided match there because they're
just two powerhouses that you know I can
definitely decimate the other one and
just depending on how players play and
match up it is pretty likely but teams
that are one and one they have so much
to play for so much is on the line here
they're not sitting cushy with two wins
already they could be going one and two
and be facing elimination next week so I
think everyone wants it I think everyone
is excited to get into their matches I
definitely think we're gonna see a close
match but it's important to uh take note
of those tie breaks which may indeed be
needed here I speak about tie breaks
Daniel because I'm not mistaken the
blitz are uh no stranger to Ty bricks
and have actually pulled off a super
impressive comeback victory that they
won in tie breaks so in case we do see
tie breaks again I might give the slight
Edge to the blitz just because they have
experience there before
yeah given how nerve-wracking these tie
breaks are as we look at the week three
standings you need all of the experience
that you can get but I'm really looking
at that kind of Peloton that group in
the middle that's one and one and two
and one those are the teams that really
want to try to stand out as we get
closer and closer to the playoffs and
it's really not like the NBA I'm on in
which we get basically two obvious
categories like not like the NBA don't I
see the Golden State oh the Garden State
I'm sorry sorry my fault I if I had a
nickel for every time I set the Golden
State passers I would be uh you know be
buying up some real estate here in Los
Angeles but essentially it's not like
you got the playoff teams then you got
the non-playoff teams I mean for
goodness sake you got the Archbishop
sitting at 0-2 so I think it can be
emphasized enough if you're a fan
choosing which team to root for don't
just hop on and off the bandwagon it can
actually be really interesting to root
for a team that comes back all the way
from Owen two or even from like an
unremarkable one and one to potentially
win the whole thing absolutely and you
know we have seen that a little bit the
uh Spanish Maniac shrimps you know they
they came in and won their match after
being 0-2 and suddenly it's like hey
don't forget about us we might have
started Owen two he counted us out you
know we're on our way to three losses
but instead like I like I keep reminding
people The rosters are deep for all
these teams only four players play at a
given time Dania but they're so much
more depth to these rosters and if you
find that that perfect roster that just
works for you all of a sudden you know
you kind of found the Holy Grail there
and you can run with that for a few
weeks
well as I told our team manager at the
start of the Cobra season I was
reviewing all of the rosters and it just
immediately occurred to me that the PCL
I think is largely going to be decided
by by Form uh not even really by The
rosters themselves although the Gotham
Knights beg to differ in that regard I
mean you got players or basically
guaranteed four out of four but unless
you're a team that has Magnus or Hikaru
a lot of it is going to depend on the
form that your players show and I think
in this match today we see that more so
than ever with grishok and mvl I mean
these are two complete X Factor players
I could see if Sasha let's say is in
very bad form I can see him go two and a
half out of four I'm on but if he's in
good form you could see two different
players go 4-0 much like we did uh with
fetisev and Hikaru right I mean if you
have your top two players going you know
3040 I mean you're already not losing
the match right there you know that's
eight points all of a sudden so I mean
while while we saw the bottom of the
standings there we also of course have
to think about the flip side the teams
that are celebrating a little bit at the
top of the standings 3-0 records and
already punched their ticket uh into the
playoffs Indian yogis and Gotham Knights
saw the Gotham Knights In Action really
making a statement that they are one of
the absolute favorites a reminder that
Daniel all you need are three wins so
those teams the chess bras gnomes
Wizards and tigers even though their
record is two in one they're still just
one win away from joining the Indian
yogis and Gotham knights in the playoffs
yeah nothing cataclysmic happened to the
levitov chest Wizards and I don't want
to say that losing a match in the
regular season is a good thing right I
don't want to be that guy who tries to
put a positive spin on everything but if
you're the team captain of the levitov
chest Wizards for example you get more
data right you get more data about which
rosters work and if a roster crashed and
burned and you were pinning all of her
hopes on it well listen you're getting
data about what changes you can make you
know which players are displaying better
form which players are struggling in the
team format and you can use that
additional data if you do make it into
the playoffs to really find the best
roster but all of this again needs to be
taken with a major grain of saltimon
because especially when you get to the
good teams it's really all about the
form that the top players display that's
right I mean there's there's one team
that in particular is all about data
collection the the Charlotte cobras
um
we're rebuilding we're in a rebuilding
phase really just trying to collect as
much data as possible I can actually see
the Indian yogis and they're quivering
at the top there
um just they just lack the data that I
believe Charlotte has to go through this
rebuilding stage so I agree agree
completely Dania uh we we see uh some
players that certainly don't need any
more data collected on them to uh slot
them easily into your starting lineups
Alexander grishook is playing with the
black pieces to start off against
Paulina shivalova and uh Daniel I mean
where's my featured chat question
I feel empty here where is my fianchetto
question come on
the fin Kettle question it's it's gone
well the voting has closed already Iman
it's too late for everybody to talk
about it but we're gonna get our
statisticians to count up yeah I want to
know if I wanted
how about the move B3 in this position I
think that's a pretty workable move
right I mean sacrifice them at night but
you at least get the bishop pair there
anything for the fiancados I've been
I've been trying to say that
um but honestly we we see a nimzo bishop
D3 early it is a little bit flexible you
can go Knight F3 or you can go for 92.
usually Knight ge2 is a move played
before the bishop gets to D3 and then
immediately you're ready to challenge
the bishop on D4 with A3 for the most
part in the nimzo you know it's not
usually too common to play A3 to chase
the bishop because the bishop will
probably take on C3 anyway yeah yeah so
you've seen actually some very modern
treatments of this line in recent years
this line itself it's called the
Rubinstein variation uh or the classical
botvinic system sometimes I read these
chess.com uh line labels and there's
like seven different players I could say
it's the makagana of kaspara of Defense
the alkyne sub variation how do you get
your name on one of those classical
traditional is still like okay if
everybody's not hopping on the train
yeah where's the sign up sheet now C6 by
Alexander grishook is a pretty unusual
way to handle this position because it's
not a semi-sluff and normally C5 is
pretty much automatic I'm on what do you
make of this I'm shocked I I have to say
uh C6 is shy it also shocks a little bit
by A3
um because I thought maybe we'd see
Knight F3 Castle or Knight ge2 but
instead A3 so forcing the issue but then
it just feels so weird to me to play A3
Force the bishop to take and then play
Knight E2 why not 92 first and then play
A3
yeah it doesn't seem like 92 had a
downside I get that you want the bishop
there but A3 was inflexible I'm with you
there now the one line where you see the
move C6 featured in the nimso Indian
happens in the same year so I do want to
show this just kind of generally for
context and some players in the chat uh
might find this familiar if
um white plays the move F3 which is I
think the clock variation there is a
lion it's not the most popular in the
world but after D5 A3 and the trade on
C3 a Lithuanian Grandmaster eduardus
rosenthalis uh who's a nimso expert
really likes the move C6 here and if
white plays E3 and black plays P6 and
Bishop A6 then you actually get a very
similar position to the one that we have
in the game actually we might have
transposed into the mock variation Let's
uh rewind to the current position I
literally think this is
indistinguishable you would have never
known that this came from a Rubenstein
true yeah this uh now it looks like
reshook is actually done exactly what
you set out to do in this opening which
is trade light Square Bishops he's done
so on A6 and the C4 Square hey it might
take a while Daniel but I'm really
looking at Knight B8 nice C6 yeah
exactly I like that one too yeah Knight
e896 I mean this is just great there's
so many ways to get to C4 and if you're
wondering how to kill like five or six
moves there you go okay that that'll
take some time off the clock
now white needs to kill some moves as
well and I think for Paulina really the
only plan that I'm familiar with in
these positions is to play E4 and that
doesn't end Humanity I mean black can
just ignore that pawn but then white can
drive the pawn over to E5 and send the F
Pawn in motion as well so I think we're
gonna get a very clearly defined battle
between Black's positional play on The
Queen side and potentially his Square
control and paulina's attacking chances
on the other side of the board so a
fascinating position Sasha is down on
the clock all things are normal the
world continues to spin and he protects
the Knight on A6 we will continue to
spin around the horn and look at the
other games I'm on because all four of
them are now underway
yeah we were just taking a look at the
game in the top left of your screen
grishook with the black pieces I see um
mvl is in a position that looks very
symmetrical thus far and it's actually
the the other games on you know boards
three and uh and four there that that
seem to have the most action going on
and I say action of course I'm drawn to
the benoni type position
okay let's start with the benoni game
between my hell Boyer and Becca 95
that's Alexander indich was a very sharp
player he always looks for unbalanced
positions with the black pieces and this
is indeed a modern benoni so image
making no bones about what he wants to
do with black to start this match no the
pawn count which I've been counting for
the last like three minutes is actually
even I thought that white was up a pawn
because normally you get this kind of
position in the benko and the b-pawn uh
has disappeared here yeah black hasn't
even sacrificed upon and he's still
gotten that Banco compensation
but on the flip side I'm on I'm looking
at Black's Queen side and I'm getting a
little bit concerned because if white
can grab control of the E file with
blackstrokes not coordinated you got to
be very very careful about not allowing
a rook infiltration to E7 or E8 yeah
exactly and you know it's funny that you
mentioned the positions are sometimes
from a Banco because I'm looking at that
eval bar and it really likes white I'm
starting to wonder if the pawn was not
on A7 would it be more equal or what's
going on here it's almost like the pawns
are equal and Black's position is worse
what the hell happened in this game I
love you that the uh the rookie one has
highlighted I think Queen D2 rookie one
are lethal moves black looks like he's
gonna be way too busy on the queen side
hitting Knights Bishops Rooks out and
hang on Queen D2 Bishop H6 and that
could be just like a lethal checkmating
attack before black can even bring any
pieces over to defend
yeah I mean conceptually right black is
doing great he's got the bishop air he's
got the benko pressure on the queen side
from a developmental standpoint though
he's in pretty big trouble and that's
why I have my eyes on the immediate
rookie one if we could pull up an
analysis board this obviously looks like
it blunters upon but the last thing that
black can do is send the queen over to
E1 and then not defend the E8 Square
this is the best way to get checkmated
in like two seconds and I had some fun
actually looking at this position I'm on
yeah I could not I don't know if I'd be
able to resist the move rookie one with
Queen takes f8 check as a threat yeah
but I actually think that Bishop H oh
look at this line Bishop H6 sacked The
Rook oh yeah
and then after 97 send the knight in and
black can't defend F7 and f8 that's
amazing at the same time so there's just
one indication of the price that you pay
for not developing your queen side
rookie one is on the board that's uh I
think just good instincts uh you you
can't teach moves like rookie one right
you don't study those in books you just
have to have that feeling that no this
is the time to strike I need to play
direct moves and guess what the the
Knight and Bishop are still on V8 and C8
respectively which means that those
Rooks are it's just one move short of
Defending one another you can't I mean
Rook f8 just doesn't make any sense so
you will have to surrender the E file by
the looks of it
yeah and the best way to surrender it
might be to simultaneously develop your
Bishop I think the top priority for
black forget the B2 Pawn get your Bishop
in your night out so that a queen
doesn't land on E8 he takes only one
though and maybe he wants to meet
Queenie one with Bishop D7 no Knight D7
oh man I'd be quivering in my boots here
Iman I mean Queenie a check looks scary
in and of itself I guess white wants
Knight f8 and then to smoke the queen
out by fee and Kettering the bishop
right there you go another fianchetto
yeah it's hopefully we're still keeping
track uh the amended scores
um Queenie it looks it looks dangerous
but the funny thing is the bishop on G5
is on the Square that the Knight would
need to jump into to make another threat
speaking of that I actually started
looking at Queen E8 bishop d8 and Knight
G5 oh my gosh like what the heck is
happening there
well what I love about Bishop d8 is that
it actually blocks the a file so the
development of Black's Bishop won't come
with Tempo anymore right which is a good
thing for white and you might end up
sacrificing you know the Rook on A1 and
the Knight on C3 because the only three
pieces that you really need are the
queen the bishop and the King side
Knight so yeah my old Boyer has a lot of
calculating to do the one piece of
silver lining for in-ditch is that
White's position in a weird kind of way
I'm on is harder to play than blacks
because White's the one who's doing the
calculating in ditch is the one who's
making the forced moves whether or not
he's going to get checkmated correct and
that's such a frustrating feeling as a
chess player male Boyer is going through
it right now because he feels my
position is so good what the heck is
this Queenie it must be working whereas
in Dish it's like uh I mean if it works
I made it there's nothing more I can do
I can't fight the evaluation but if not
I know exactly what my next moves are so
you're right he definitely has an easier
time with the black pieces here and
Hellboy he's got a lot to think about
yeah I hate that feeling it's that
feeling when your opponent plays
terribly but he's playing instantly like
this isn't fair you know it's like I'm
I'm playing better and yet somehow I'm
losing on time uh and Boyer has to keep
a uh certain amount of time in reserve
because you just know that this game is
going to stay Tactical for a while to
come so as Boyer is hard at work they're
leaning back and forth and stretching
his arms a little bit and enjoying the
moment we are going to enjoy a look at
the bird's eye view I see a Pawn on G4
on the top right
has his hands tied with mvl looks like a
pretty decent position for the Frenchman
with three names them on and of course
cornet against Dash in the bottom right
also looks like a pretty nice position
for the white pieces yeah I feel like
you know in this commentary Duo I've
been making uh far too many decisions
Daniel which one would you like to go to
nvl or Bogdan Daniel dare
okay let's go to bdd let's go to bogd
and Daniel Dash that's getting better
and better at saying that the Croatian
bulldog with three names
yeah exactly and that rolls right off
the tongue well bdd is facing a pawn
that has just landed on F4 this started
as an Owens defense E4 was met with a B6
so Dash much like Alexander indich is
not hiding his intentions he's I mean B6
just screams I want as unbalanced of a
position as possible but let's be real
one I once faced that move in a blitz
tournament from somebody
against me recently it's a pretty
dubious move objectively
and the move B6 screams that you're
either trying to imbalance the position
intentionally or you've been watching
him on Hamilton stream far too much for
your own good
um I I no such thing come on victim of
trying that opening myself perhaps a
little too often
um I can tell you that in my tenured you
know 15 plus year career playing the
opening I have never in my entire life
at the current position on the board
laughs
I'm still wrapping my head around the
fact that we have a Pawn on F4 and
Black's like hey why am I not invite I'm
going to invite myself to the party and
he stops the pawn in its tracks for that
five the big question I'm on I think is
who benefits from this highly
unconventional Pawn structure because on
the one hand black has this long-term
weakness on E6 and white can try to
attack it with like Queen D2 and queen
E3 but on the other hand Black's got
some positional assets of his own that
Bishop munchie 3 definitely has seen
better dates absolutely the bishop on G3
is stuck in defense right now uh as soon
as you said that we have something that
is kind of unorthodox if you've never
seen it before I immediately feel that
that favors black because he's the
higher rated player he wants the spicy
position that you know will seem
unorthodox unusual
um there's not many I guess patterns
that the players have to go off here and
I'm also looking at White's Knights it
would love to make their transition to
the E5 square but they're impossible the
worst positions on the chessboard to
reach that square it's really awkward to
get there
one night is restricted by black spawns
the other night is restricted by its
need to defend the F4 Pawn so you're
right the knights are very immobile I
think Dad should go full shebang here I
think you should go Knight D7 and Castle
Queen side you can't play one E4 B6 and
then you know castle and cowardly
Fashion To The King side no no no I
think he's counseling Queen side and
sending that h-pawn full down the board
but ditch one thing that has plagued him
among in Rapid time controls is his
predilection for time pressure he's
always in acute time pressure and this
is a case in point four minutes after 12
moves he's got to be very careful yeah I
I actually remember possibly I can't
even remember now if you were on the
commentary but it's possibly like the
funniest moment in the PCL thus far when
Bogdan Daniel dax's camera fell like it
fell off his monitor I can't remember
who's doing the commentary but it was
like the funniest thing I've ever seen
because he has to fix it right you can't
keep playing your game until it's fixed
it's like in you know tournament chess
when you can't actually keep playing
until you make sure your score sheet is
written down properly so I mean he's had
to deal with a lot this PCL let's put it
that way well we saw that with Wei e in
the first round he had like two minutes
and he was just casually adjusting his
camera it was Canty and Hess were on the
commentary team but I was watching that
and it was an amazing moment Bogdan also
had one of the most painful moments of
the PCL when he failed to promote a pawn
and win the game on the spot a game
without exaggerating that really could
have changed the course of the match in
the course of the Bulldogs entire season
so let me tell you he is not going to
forget that and he is determined more
than ever to prove his worth on the team
okay I think the position is some
King is on F7 so I'll give him a pass
right he hasn't castled King's side he's
done something a little bit more gutsy
than that that's right you know B6
living up to its expectations I think
both sides actually have a number of
pieces that need to be where they are
The Rook on h8 has to be there defending
the The h-man Rook on E8 also seems like
it needs to be there to defend E6
whereas White's Bishop on G3 Queen on E3
Knight on E2 are all Tethered to that F
Pawn Bishop's also Tethered to the h-bun
there's so many pieces stuck the bishop
on F3 can't move the Rook on F1 pretty
much can't move so even though the eval
bar is not a super fan of Knight to D1 I
have to admit Dania kind of struggling
to see what other pieces to move and I
kind of like it because I can see a nice
rewrite there
this is a huge threat Knight F2 Knight
H3 Knight G5 the evot bar is creeping
back up but I feel like the players are
making incredibly natural moves I'd be
giving all of this exclamation marks the
ELO bar is just laughing all of these
moves out of the building what's wrong
with Queen d8 I mean you are hitting
white where it hurts on the H4 Pawn Yeah
and if he he can force De Monte to go
Queen F2 well that takes away the
rightful Square from White Knight on the
other hand it gives the Knight a
different pathway but that pathway could
be easily blocked with a well-timed move
such as a P5 so it's just such a weird
cagey kind of position you called it him
on there are no patterns here to speak
of the players are entirely on their own
they they certainly are Dania
um and I see the bird's eye view if we
can take a look uh we have to probably
jump to the game that we haven't touched
on yet because I see mvl as potentially
well committed just a serious uh offense
here and I was hyping up the possibility
of an upset in round one it might happen
you call it even before we went live you
pointed out bertia Don eschvar he beat
Ray Robson with the black pieces in the
previous match oh my goodness nobody
didn't just take on G6 his king that's
the ultimate twist them on black was the
one going after whites King just a
couple of moves ago but mvl he was
overzealous now the white king is fully
safe and obviously F takes G6 is
Unthinkable because of Rook B7 it looks
like black has to stay alive with Rook
f8 but Rook B8 does that finish it oh
there's a trap there Rook B8 FG
Rook B7 there might be Queen takes F2
check might be Queen takes up two junk
unbelievable
I shinxed him yeah I think he just spot
like mvl by the way spotted that credit
to him like he saw that whole thing
coming now I'm wondering what what was
he supposed to do and I think it was
maybe the slow approach Bishop H5 or
something and you know bring the rook in
next I don't know Bishop E4 maybe but I
just that what a Miss like that that
tactic came out of nowhere from mvl well
I'm gonna show exactly what he missed I
think even Rook B7 I'm on because black
literally has no threats here this is
resign time you just take on F7 right
you're up a thousand pawns what he was
trying to do is force FG and now go Rook
B7 what is The Rook NFA doing here well
it's allowing the tactic which he missed
Queen takes F2 the bishop steps away
with a discovery but what's crazy about
this apparently is no the movie Seven I
apologize and black actually wins oh so
it's the same idea yeah but after Queen
takes C7 you actually do get mated after
Queen takes F2 check what a
and what a great decision I'm on to not
stubbornly play Rook B7 but accept the
inevitable or has he accepted the
inevitable no he's going for the win
Yeah so basically black was about to
play Bishop G7 if the checks kept coming
instead he's played D6 he's also low on
time he can actually lose this game
oh he absolutely can and I apologize mvl
was the one who went for the win by
tucking his King away on H7 I think he
is gonna lose this game definitely it's
insane yeah Knight F4 is in the picture
the king is actually remarkably safe
there on H7 and guess what A5 is it
can't move the pieces are covering d8
White's pawns even though there's three
of them for the piece he suddenly seems
so immobile
nothing about this match is normal thus
far another crazy thing has happened
Alexander indich has won his game
against my hell Boyer who did get into a
cute time Press Room on this is exactly
what we kind of predicted that's right
he didn't have the time to figure out
how to conduct his initiative and the
tables turned almost immediately so a
big win for the Bulldogs there in the
early going that evil bar is swinging
and Swinging
finish off the attack
yeah I'm looking at Knight D3 and it's
like how do you end Queen Seven Queen C2
Queen C7 Queen C2 oh wow
but then there's Bishop E5 and there
might be a fork on E1
oh my God yeah what the heck is going on
Queen A7 oh and now you want to move the
Knight
and defend from A7 I I've missed a lot
there I'll start by saying that so did I
and I think so did mvl who probably did
not spot Queen A7 the fact that he's
thinking right now
says a lot now where does the Knight go
does it go up to D5 which Amman
threatens checkmate with Knight F6 and
stops Queen is gonna get victimized in
the end yeah I love 95 that has to be
the decision here oh it's the wrong move
again
what unbelievable it looks like
everything that white is doing makes so
much sense but mvl is up to task King G2
Queen D5
that was the reason the Knight T5 is
wrong how could he have missed that with
10 seconds left come on
bardia step up your game and the King
doesn't have any other squares King F3
91 is Checkmate yeah four pattern yeah
that's incredible
okay Queenie one that's got to be the
move although that's oh King f395
that's a great tactic I'm wondering
where the win is after King H2
5 you missed it but he's got made
he missed it in favor of me
what is the winning Winnie the queen
amateur
that's a beautiful name I still was not
convinced after King Stu what the wind
was but mvl was seeing so much there he
missed the initial Bishop sacrifice and
then it felt like he saw literally
everything
but that just belies the earlier
craziness that happened Boyer uh
apologist Boyer lost he was winning as
well bargain on ashbar was winning in
one move but it's so pretty easy against
these 2700s I mean their ability to
weasel out of virtually any position
it's it's inhuman Amman it's spiritual
it's otherworldly speaking of
Otherworldly we have a crazy game
unfolding uh in Demonte dalite's Affair
against Bogdan Daniel Dash where I think
his decision to play the Owens defense
is now looking pretty darn good that's
the same position it's paying off and
this is a really important uh game
because we actually see that it's one
and a half to one and a half a draw
between uh grishook and Paulina that's
board one against board four this is the
other board one and board four matchup
and if Bogdan Daniel Daya can win this
game that's not a bad start for the
Bulldogs they would jump out to a two
and a half one and a half lead
something's in the air today all of
these games are wild shavalova by the
way really didn't give gristook too many
chances in that names of Indian I mean
she held a comfortable draw from a
position of strength in the end game
speaking of position of strength that
King on G6 is crazy it's it's crazy how
safe it is it's impossible for white to
even set up a check maybe it's worth
going 92 that's the only way that I see
to even deliver a sensible check to the
black king yeah and at some point this
King might find itself situated very
nicely on you know a dark square like H6
on on G6 and it's just so entrenched in
there I'm also looking at aggressive
ideas for black just down the line
something like Queen H4 Knight G4 and
strangely enough if you take the Knight
you kind of open up the H file so uh
maybe black can set up some uh check
meeting attacks as well
oh absolutely and 50 seconds now for
damance I mean Bogdan is very
experienced in time scrambles he gets
them literally every single game it
feels like Demonte is losing the threat
here I would still try 92 because
anything can happen when you've got a
knight and a king and a queen in such
close proximity
but she continues to hesitate here I
don't even see an alternative 92 is on
the board and look at Fox bringing his
Bishop back which is kind of passive and
it gives white I mean it hands over the
initiative
where's the king in a hideaway F7 maybe
yeah F7 guards the pawn my feeling is
that you know King H6 is just kind of
safe and I want to play G6 after that
but down to H7 it goes I that's probably
my third choice honestly
now I think the idea is that if the
bishop moves away from F3 then I could
have jumped into G4 they Manta takes the
other Pawn attacking the Queen Another
totally sensible move
we've got a trade on rookie 8 is going
to be tough to deal with I think
yeah there there's also you know some
ideas like Queen E3 check right once
let's say you play Queen takes
C63 chat comes and I can see some funny
lines like Knight G4 takes takes at like
a brook back to h8 oh yeah almost seven
don't forget about the age file
I I think this is a primitive remark it
may sound very primitive but having a
night these types of positions and in a
Time scramble is always preferable
because they're just so much more tricks
that can be generated when you've got
the Knight let alone the fact that black
is also Apple Pawn so that's right
barring a cataclysmic turn of events I
think Dad should be able to bag this
game and take home the point agreed
agreed this looks very good I mean you
can treat the Rooks with Queen H4 and
Rook E1 if you want
um you can also just sort of solidify
things with G6
this looks good I mean I think he's just
he's just gonna grind white down trade
the Rooks and exploit the three-on-one
pawn majority you have to be careful
though about how you do that because the
last thing you want to allow is either a
Perpetual or some sort of fork don't
fall asleep on white spawn majority
either
yep
yeah Queen C1 is a extremely good move
here yeah that'll just win on the spot
you can pick up every pawn and guess
what white is threatening a total sum of
zero with Queen B7
Bogdan though just going directly for
checkmate Queen C1 Queen C2 Queenie
Queen F2 was forced mate there which he
missed
95 even listen Queen C2 was literal
force me the game's still not over here
he's got eight seconds I would just take
the bishop and push my H1 yeah that
should do it
I mean I have to do this keeping the B6
Pawn defended but
H4 at some point has to be uh thrown in
you have to say
you would think I mean F4 also possible
with Queen G6 coming up it's just all
about King safety here in Black's King
is utterly unapproachable that's what
makes this such a one-sided position
yeah Queen G4 Queen H2 and queen G2 and
eventually White's Queen is going to get
smoked out of there but they want to
doing a great job of keeping some
chances alive yeah six King F6
oh oh
that's game
G5 was such a devilish move he was he
was actually threatening a lot like my
instinct was King E6 but I have to admit
I didn't realize it got out of Queen F4
I was just like neither did I I just
noticed that Queen 04 was the threat
okay this position was basically
indefensible for Demonte she put up a
tremendous fight but the board one of
the Bulldogs takes the game and they
take the first round among but only by a
point uh and I'm I'm looking at those uh
at these results on your screen are Dia
danishvar no points for that game and
position that he had nothing on the
board same for my hell Boyer so while
the upsets were possible at the end of
the day results are cleared that the
higher rated players pretty much got
things done with the exception of a
player that I highlighted earlier you
know a player that I have a ton of
respect for and I know he can be
performing better than he is free shook
only half a point continues to just I'm
off to those shaky starts Daniel
we always talk about it I'm on those
half points they accumulate and if
you're the board four you don't need an
outsized performance you don't need four
out of four would be nice and someone
like Michaela Bortnick probably is going
for four out of four but if your Ballina
every draw is incredibly valuable
because those draws they add up
incredibly fast so it's a good start for
the Croatia bulldogs and it's a good
start that could have been even better
bardia danishvar is going to have a
slightly more manageable matchup in the
next round and I'm really excited to
watch him try to score some upsets uh
with the black pieces them on this is a
fascinating match in the works so ladies
and gentlemen you go absolutely nowhere
because we will have round two of the
Croatia Bulldogs and the blitz coming up
in just a couple of short minutes
laughs
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream the and your stream will
be linked to your games on our play
server type command Community streamer
in chat and start growing your stream
today
[Music]
my name is Edward Dawson I'm from
Chicago I'm secret Blackman my name is
Roberto bezo Jr and what I want to share
is I love tacos tacos and chess
because I am
with the chess program really even chess
in general like on the deck you are you
kind of Lose Yourself you don't really
think about your case you learn to think
differently you know you strategize more
I sometimes come out uh 7 30 in the
morning I'll probably play until lock up
you know if it makes my day go by faster
it's competitive it's a lot of trash
talk it's it's crazy you know like the
chess players we got our own little
circle you know and all of us play each
other we talk trash about who be who who
garbage yeah I never played that dude
again he garbage I have a plan but yeah
it's real competitive
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
well he won't be an international Master
for very much longer bardia danishvar is
a key part of the Croatia Bulldogs even
though he lost his first game he was
also close to defeating mvl and Amman
just recently a couple of weeks ago he
finished his GM requirements scoring his
third and final Grand Master Norm he is
a player with a very bright future
indeed I think it's uh it was just a
basically a formality at at this point
um getting that title approved but still
a formality that needs to be under
undertaken
um obviously I think with him slotting
in at a board three position I mean he's
sitting at like six out of eight in the
PCL Dania that is such an incredible
score for someone that you know can be
like board two board three depending on
his position I mean six out of eight is
a good score for board one
it's crazy how many PCL teams managed to
fare it out you know these underrated
young players who are on board three or
board four but absolutely capable of
maintaining plus scores in most PCL
matches so dineshbar is a huge pickup
for the Bulldogs the Bulldogs they're a
Powerhouse team they're incredibly solid
they don't have any weaknesses on any of
the boards and they are currently
leading with a score of Two and a Half
one and a half on the strength of
Paulina shubalova's drop against
grishook I said Polina was gonna have a
slightly easier game
I'm sorry to say that I was wrong sorry
Paulina exactly it's like uh I'm pretty
sure what happens is that as the board
four you're supposed to have your
hardest game first and then you know it
gets like way way easier eventually you
play the board four
um your your day is not really supposed
to go from playing Alexander grishook uh
to playing Maxine vashilograph so as you
said good luck with that a similar
experience though over there for Demonte
cornet she started off with a tough
opponent in Bogdan Daniel dayak and well
hello Alexander indich is waiting for
you in round two so no rest for these
board fours
it's true that cornet lost but I think
she has to try to go for exactly the
same types of positions in all four of
her games because that was a 50 50
position they were in a Time scramble
both kings were weak and if Coronet can
get four of those positions she's going
to pull at least one of those games out
so again if you're the board four I
think the best strategy for scoring an
upset is not hunkering down and
groveling for a draw especially if
you're playing white but really to go
after your opponent and lean into the
fact that they are the ones with
something to lose same of course with
Paulina shuvalova who did play a very
solid end game and held mvl that's a
huge confidence boost I'm on I think
when you're the bottom board knowing
that you've held the top player that's a
total game changer for the next three
games
it is and it puts not only your team in
a good frame of mind but it helps your
confidence tremendously I always you
know have some sympathy for these board
fours because a lot of them come in and
they have their toughest matchups right
at the beginning and just sort of like
defeats your mentality before you even
get out of the gate so by the time you
get to you know round four and you're
playing which should be your easiest
pairing you may be suffering because
you're just like taking so many losses
by that point so they have to stay uh
mentally strong as we see pardea and we
shook their game has started and uh that
ashfar is is gone with the karaoke here
too to start off against Grisha
yeah the cargo con obviously super
popular nowadays at all levels and I was
in a Grisha uh as saying the line which
I think of all the lines in the advanced
Caro is probably the choice of most
super GMS who really play principal
chess this is the short variation where
the bishop modestly comes out to E2 but
don't be fooled by the sort of modest
appearance of White's kingside
development I'm on I think you'll
co-sign this point the short variation
is actually a very principled and
aggressive line that leads to some wild
tactical struggles particularly when
black Castle's Queen side which is
pretty often that's right
um you'll you'll definitely see that
grishook's play is based a lot of what
he gets in return from his opponent
right it depends which way the king
castles it depends how black develops
black sometimes has lines where they go
for G5 even F6 Knight E7 is definitely a
more modest approach I think G5 and
Bishop G7 is still on the table but a
lot of times you see you know even the
bishop move again like dropping back to
G6 Knight F5 Bishop E7 just slowly
getting developed like that but you
mentioned it most top players these days
are going for this Advanced line with
white because hey takes more space the
computer co-signs it and it's not easy
for black to find enough squares for his
pieces to develop
A4 is the ultimate typical Grand Master
move white grab space on the queen side
and this move will double as a pawn
storm type of move if black infect
castles Queen side there's no doubt that
this Pawn is either gonna land on A5 or
support the b-pawn in its quest to
shatter Black's Queen Side Pawn
structure so it's largely a game of cat
and mouse and you often see the players
try to be maximally flexible I think
that's easier to do for white because
White's already Castle White's already
committed in that regard black has to
figure out how to generate more real
estate for his minor pieces and that's
precisely what Dinesh warp does he
pushes C5 and among the idea isn't so
much to win the D4 Pawn which is very
well protected as to vacate the C6
Square for the Knight and then the
bishop can take the parking spot that
was cleared Away by the night absolutely
yeah Knight C6 is the intention and
blast pieces actually look quite good
honestly
um after that they've all found good
squares as grishook I'm definitely
looking at a move like A5 because I'm
I'm getting the impression that if black
plays Knight C6 and white plays A5
potentially A6 you could really loosen
up a lot of light squares and you're
highlighting it exactly Bishop B5 Queen
A4 that Knight on C6 is extremely hard
to defend and white is just getting more
and more space so I wouldn't mind seeing
A5 here from Grisha I'm also drawn to
other moves like you know just simple
developing moves but I mean he just
played A4 so A5 is is the first move on
my mind
having said a you have to say B but
probably grishek is going to take six
and a half minutes before saying B you
also see why taking on C5 in these Karo
Khan lines which is a very difficult
move to explain I think particularly to
newer players you know why would you
voluntarily shatter your own Pawn chain
and the reasons are complex they're very
tactical but one of the reasons is that
you can use the D4 Square as a very
powerful post for your knight and from
D4 the Knight is needling the bishop it
can also later move on to B5 and D6 as
is common in a lot of different French
variations so Sasha is going to settle
into another long think he's already
down two minutes on the clock by move
nine again the world continues to spin
Society isn't falling apart just yet
Sasha grishock is down uh more than two
minutes yep and we take a look at the
bird's eye view there
um grishook with the white pieces leave
him to think for now I'm also noticing
some of the other games and uh the
specifically the openings that we see
down in the bottom left Bogdan Daniel
dayek has this weird kind of double
fienketto position and you know he's
just trying to not commit anything he's
finally played D4 in the middle of the
board but you know he's been sitting
there kind of toying around with uh you
know fianchetto here attack the center
there and finally he's taking the center
with D4
well let's take a bit of a closer look
because I think we're going to get a lot
of committal moves by both players
um really before we reach move 10 this
is only move seven and the the line
along where white plays Knight F3 E3
fianchetto's the queen side bishop and
then play C4 that in and of itself is
very popular I actually haven't seen
that combined with a second fianchetto
very often exactly yeah the bishop well
it does well on D3 so that's why usually
you see all this combined with just
Bishop B2 or Bishop D3 but the extra G3
move as well I mean it definitely says
to Black if you want to play Pawn to C6
that's great against the bishop on G2
but it might not be great against the
rest of the position so you kind of have
black guessing you know how do you
handle the structure I'm looking at E5
or C5 I mean those are the breaks if we
can get those pawns pushed fantastic if
we don't see C5 here uh I'll be kind of
shocked
well in a bullet game I actually would
still consider the move E5 to meet de
with Bishop B4 check uh creating some
tactical Intrigue but it's not the best
thing to do against the super GM in a
rapid game Boyer actually withholds he
doesn't play C5 just yet instead he
prioritizes the development of his
Bishop he wants to meet Bishop G2 with
the classic Bishop B7 neutralizing the
Bishops kind of cancel each other out
and I have no doubt him on that he's
probably leaning toward playing C5
because logistically E5 is going to be
harder to achieve maybe not unachievable
though maybe he can go Knight bd7 and
then E5 but I feel like C5 is a little
bit more typical when you're facing the
kind of semi-hanging Pawn structure that
white has with the pawns on D4 and C4
yeah absolutely I think B6 is possibly a
little bit more flexible than just going
C5 initially so I kind of like his
decision there if C5 was played first
White would play Bishop to G2 and black
could not get his own Bishop to B7 so I
really like the move order he's making
sure as you point out he can challenge
the Bishops on that long diagonal and
now he has C5 if he wants to or Knight
bd7 and you're still withholding do you
ego C5 or jigo E5 making your opponent
guess could actually be more valuable
here whereas C5 might show your cards
too early
boy you're lost a frustrating game in
the first round and his clock management
was a big part of the reason why you
can't really blame him because as we
were discussing him on and this exact
scenario unfolded he had a position
which I'm sure he knew was
overwhelmingly better but in order to
figure out the right path he had to
invest almost all of his time in the
early middle game and these GMS are so
good at spinning up Intrigue and
complications the moment that you hit
time pressure so Boyer has to avoid that
scenario unfolding a second time and I'm
getting really worried because he's no
Sasha grishook with full due respect
when you're down five minutes in a PCL
game against someone like Dash
the game's not over but he's gotta put a
move on here he's got to make an
intuitive decision yeah it and I think
that he's overthinking it like there's
nothing here that I think he needs to be
concerned about so it's just him
choosing a plan and maybe unfortunately
for him they all look good sometimes so
many options in front of you are like
yeah that's good oh wait but that's good
too oh wait wait but that's also fine
whoa and then you don't know what to do
at all
we have to go to the mvl game let's go
back to the bird's eye view because
craziness is unfolding and mvl's game
against Paulina trivalova not only we
have to look at the current position in
which white is down in exchange which
mvl has of course sacrificed well let's
rewind a couple of moves and see how
that's got crazy five moves to go I'm on
this was a totally normal kind of
semi-toire structure whatever okay
Bishop D3 why it's just going to get his
King side on Castle no Paulina goes
Knight to B4 in this position it looks
like the Knight cannot be captured
because after the trade black plays
Queen C1 but that check isn't as scary
as it appears white walks with Queen D1
what black delivers another check is the
sephoric yeah but white defense and now
Queen C1 check is a move that mvl I
think might have overlooked because
Queen to A1 check runs into of course
Rook to B1 and white wins on the spot
mvl can repeat moves with Queen D1 but
without any hesitation he sacrifices The
Rook in the corner and chases the queen
with B1 the queen is not trapped it can
take on G2 and evacuate through H3 but
that open G file I'm on could spell Doom
not to the queen but perhaps to Black's
King
wow this is such a weird position and
Jesus I mean the idea is clearly Queen
G5 is a follow-up after G6 Rook G3 might
drop the queen there
and then I guess you can like
try to free your Queen by playing after
H6 or something but oh it's such a weird
position oh my gosh I mean the Evo bar
as usual tells none of the story here
exactly so yeah I really do
I think we should show this on the Eva
on the on the eval bar on the analysis
board once again so Queen H3 is forced I
don't know what paulina's thinking about
she has to go to this whether it's
losing or not and after Queen G5 G6 what
we're talking about is Rook G3 say no
problem Queen H5 but remember the Rook
pins the king white just takes back so
what you're saying them on is that black
has to counter-attack White's Queen and
try to open up some Escape Square
probably H5 because White's Queen
incidentally oddly enough cannot move on
to a square such that H5 is still
protected because Queen A5 actually runs
into B6 with Queen H5 on the next move
this is mind-boggling this is wild and
Polina is now seven minutes on the clock
now and so important to do it the way
that you just did with F6 if you go H6
first and queen E5 and you are guarding
H5 and F6 is way worse there because now
you can just take G6 and F6 and it's
just over
F6 has been played Paulina stays afloat
look at these two I mean this is
meticulous what is this line they're
both playing it like they've seen it
before
well Paulina definitely hasn't she's got
two and a half minutes although she's
accelerating her pace of play you would
think that she would be taking longer
but no I mean the more the further
Advance they get in this game the more
familiar Polina seems with the position
and the L is finally thinking no never
mind he's still not thinking well I was
gonna say you know his opponent only has
like two minutes and that eval bar is
saying equal now I think it might be
related to a potential like you know hey
Rook G5 you know Queen H3 Rook G3 it's a
draw but but like the mvl is not taking
a draw in that way like not even close
yeah he could have taken a draw earlier
with Queen D1 and avoided this entire
brouhaha but he feels that with seven
extra minutes and a long-term attack on
Black's King he's got every winning
chance here in the world and I agree
completely if the bishop moves away the
queen takes on E6 I will point out him
on that I think players sometimes fall
into the Trap of assuming that if you
don't deliver Checkmate that you're
automatically going to lose that's
totally not true white is only down in
exchange yeah that's a lot of material
but if you win the pawn on E6 you're
basically not down any material you can
even potentially transition into some
sort of end game and exploit your
connected passers that's not out of the
question
yeah Rook C7 was just played I'm I'm
looking at a potential Bishop B5 but now
you're I mean kind of walking is such a
strange position here I have no idea
what's going on but I've said this
before as a board four you're happy to
be in a chaotic position against someone
as strong as mvl I'll just say that
oh absolutely we were talking about this
right this is what Demonte Cornett did
in the previous round it didn't go her
way but if your board fours constantly
get these types of positions they're
gonna pull a couple of points out Rook
G5 by mvl disliked by the Evo bar I
think this might be sending the queen to
a square that it wants to go to anyway
Iman and is MBL just playing too quickly
here and banking entirely on Black's
clock
I will say that I I don't think mvl can
mess this position up like I know the
eval bar is kind of creeping
um but I I don't actually think that it
can be messed up to a point of no return
for mvl
um and I do think that the time will
tell the story a minute on the clock for
black it will be difficult for Paulina
to keep up in in this position with the
eval bar although I say that and look at
her doing that so I'm so impressed that
cheese is finding moves here she has to
find some way to clarify this position
and I'm just as impressed as you are
this could go either way and I think I
know one man that must be watching this
on the edge of his seat and that would
be the Croatia Bulldogs manager of
yokoslav Nimitz yokoslav welcome to the
show we're glad to have you what are you
feeling right now as you look at this
game
hi guys nice to meet you both uh very
very good pronunciation a bit Russian
but very good of my name
um yeah
because he adopted me two times and I
promised my chat I would say that live
so yeah
anyways pleasure to meet on even terms
here yeah right on the PCL broadcast
yeah yeah exactly
yeah and how even I don't know I think I
understand these positions much worse
than you but okay we'll see
the eval bar in this position
um we were looking at this this game
here between Paulina shivaliva against
mvl and the eval bar is just like just
an embarrassment to chess right now it's
saying 0.00 but the position looks
completely insane I mean obviously I was
pointing out right before you joined us
I think it's a good place for your board
four to be in just a wild position where
there are winning chances what what do
you think about Black's chances in this
wild position
yeah definitely are like something we
want although yeah the clock situation
is a little bit concerning and if I'm
not mistaken this is also kind of imvl's
type of position right we have seen that
also in the previous game to a certain
extent against bardia although he was
probably quite lost at some point but
yeah he'd manage to navigate his way and
even win in the end so yeah we'll see
what happens although I am a little bit
concerned with the time situation
16 seconds now for Paulino this is what
mvl does right he always has seven
minutes at the end of each game and this
is just the problem is you make one tiny
mistake and Maxima has five minutes to
refute it Queen dhek is a huge threat
here I don't see a move here for Paulina
maybe 25 to protect the Rook she's not
finding it though oh Queen d8 and it's
over
but that's only one game and queen E5
check is forcing the queen trade
okay so that's game
but a couple of the other boards are
looking promising Vega slav in
particular I wanted to ask you about
bardia danishvar uh whom you referenced
let's click onto his time scramble
against Sasha Grisha are you as excited
as we are about bardia and what he can
bring to the team
yeah definitely I I think he's like sort
of a discovery of the season right like
I thought before the season that he
might be like a good pickup like some
sort of a Dark Horse but so far what he
has been doing beating Robson with black
uh beating Matthias bluebonn with black
scoring three and a half out of four in
the previous match I think he shows that
he's very very much underrated like I
don't know do you have any experience
playing him in online I I saw it he's
like very high on chess.com I presume
there might be some matches right so
recently but I don't think I've ever
played him before played him in like a
title Tuesday recently that might be it
and I recognized his name because of the
PCL I was like wait a minute this is the
guy that's uh tearing up the PCL right
now so it kind of kind of intimidating
but a really good pickup for you guys
yeah it was a Pity that today he started
on a fighter over note because he had a
very very good chances I thought in the
first game but and this second game also
doesn't look too good for now but okay I
mean MVM and Greece Chuck I mean that's
crazy crazy first two boards very strong
so yeah it's
it's hard tough to stay alive there
right
I mean Polina and bardia get envio
grishock uh in different orders and the
silver lining for them is that they do
have two significantly easier games
Paulina pulled out a draw against Chris
shock and I'm sure the berdia uh is not
exactly going to be you know mourning
the losses too much he's got two
winnable games in the next two rounds
and this game is not over it's far from
Over the evil bar has just dropped but
it's gonna be really hard to defend this
with only a minute left on the clock
that's that's surprising yeah
no that's that's always going to be
tough it's not just how strong the top
players are but like when you're low on
the clock as well it factors into it
um I offhand I look at this and I'm kind
of thinking that if he survives a couple
moves here the light squares for
grishook are insanely weak they know
that Bishop shows up on e4 I start to
get concerned but it's the immediate
issues in the position like A7 hanging
C4 hanging that that are the the cause
for concern but I feel Daniel like we've
we've done a disservice we keep showing
him the games against grishook and mvl I
mean what about his guys like Baghdad
Daniel dick that guy's got a nice
position let's let's go to that game
maybe
he does have a nice position he's up a
pawn and it does appear that Sasha is
going to take that one but baghdan is up
a full Pawn he's got a big advantage
and vehicles unless we're missing
something looks like your guy is up two
minutes on the clock and the coast is
pretty much clear
yeah it looks good especially since I've
been very much impressed because by his
ability by his technical abilities to
convert all kinds of positions even in
very severe time travel I think we have
kind of seen it to a certain extent in
the previous round uh but yeah this here
this looks even better but okay you know
it's not over until it's over and and
yeah the level of resistance in this
process week and and I think also the
level of nerves that that's something I
have noticed when when in this title
Tuesdays in these process weeks there
are always some sort of crazy upsets and
some you know mistakes and I think this
happens more often than in let's say
non-official events online and the thing
here with the team also at the line
there's an even extra component so it's
exciting to watch but I hope this will
not be the game where we will feature
yet another instance has has happened
for example in his game against Spirits
I don't know if you guys saw that but he
yeah
you remember that yeah I was I was yeah
that was a crazy moment but you know the
piece only about the individual results
but also how you're coming back from
match to match so Bogdan has acquitted
himself particularly in this match thus
far but obviously the two biggest games
are still remaining so vacus love we
will let you watch the rest of the games
in peace uh we really appreciate you
coming on the manager of the Croatia
Bulldogs
thanks for uh putting in an appearance
and sharing your insights yeah yeah well
in this is a strong word because I'm
watching them with my girlfriend but
okay thanks
I'll try
she'll kill me if she hears this
yeah
meeting you and thanks for having me
thanks so much our pleasure
nothing but brutal honesty there from
the the manager Dania and we wouldn't
have it any other way here on the PCL
it's okay we're not live I'm on nobody's
hearing us it's okay viewers we're just
testing our stream I think that the chat
Dania wouldn't mind uh keeping a little
secret uh you guys can keep a secret
right come on guys we're all we're we're
bros we're good this is off the Record
come on you know
um Queen E7 has just been played I I'm
only seeing you know Green Pastures
ahead here because if you put pressure
enough pressure on that E6 pawn and you
get E5 to happen the game just ends
right there
no it feels like the combination of
White's time Advantage 30 seconds is a
lot of time in a position like this
coupled with the extra Pawn coupled with
the weakness of Black's King makes this
virtually indefensible also I'm on a
move like Queen C7 accomplishes exactly
nothing that Knight on F3 is such a
strong defensive piece and if I'm bogged
on I'm considering Queen takes C6 but
after the trade black plays King F7 and
that's exactly how you let your opponent
back into the game there's nothing that
black would rather have than an end game
that's like paradise compared to what he
had in the middle game okay
Paradise is not so bad
I'm
actually drawn to a potential move like
uh Knight D4 and Bishop D5 after
kind of like sacrificial in nature but
94 Bishop D5 uh rookie one looks just
fine
um no need to uh to stress but that
Bishop on uh G2 I think it wants to get
on a different diagonal Knight needs to
move to like I don't know H4 or
something like that Bishop D5 is gonna
be great I think I got slightly over
excited about Black's chances in this
end game Paradise it might be
overstating the case just a little bit
I've seen better positions than this one
by the way more good news for the
Croatia Bulldogs uh Alexander indich has
won a very smooth positional game
against Demonte the position was
defensible but Coronet was just too low
on time so a good effort there and it's
all down to this game this is a huge
game if Dash can win it then they tie
the match 2-2 if Boyer can pull out a
draw then the blitz will be able to tie
the match
and this seems counter-intuitive I have
to say King G7 rather than King f8 to
keep control of some of the e-file
squares like in the future Rook E7 is is
on top and the bishop on B8 that's the
problem piece put that on B6 hitting F2
and everything changes but Bishop on B8
is so bad
that Bishop on B6 and black might be
declining a draw Boyer is going after
the bishop on D5 but I think he will
have to play King f8 the problem is that
if you play it at the right wrong moment
the Knight D4 is going to be utterly
devastating because 96 will be
unstoppable three seconds I don't see
him defending this now he's gonna flag
no I mean he makes moves and you know
he's got the right idea trying to stop
Knight D4 but there's too many things to
keep track of where's the mate where's
the maid Bishop F7 looks interesting
even Bishop G8 you can just go after the
pawns just Bogdan has to keep an eye on
the clock right I'm always worried about
that
and Bishop takes H7 trade the Rooks is a
simple way to win it's not the most
efficient yeah but as long as he keeps
A2 protected him on I think you should
pull this one through
gets the job done we see him sort of
perking up in his chairs should be six
wait a second black might be able to win
the F2 Pawn
191 C1 oh 94 though
oh that was so close and he has F5
coming up this is not over just yet
yeah okay now it is now it's and now
it's getting to over territory
still though five seconds anything can
happen it's easy to blunder a pawn here
blunder at peace go King G2 and walk
into Knight F4 that's right
oh okay
and this looks like pretty clean
conversion but presence of opposite
Bishop means Daniel if you take those
Knights trade them off the board draw
yeah
just like Square
I mean if the knights are traded on G5
and Black Lands a Pawn on that square
white will not be able to make any
progress that's right
oh God Bogdan struggling to get his Pawn
to F4 he gets it to F3 but Bishop E3
oh I wouldn't have done that
okay
he's maintaining control the dark
squares here though you have to say like
metal Blair has fought so well I mean
you can't do much better than this dude
he had five seconds for the last three
hours and he's somehow able I mean
Knight C2 that's such a tricky Bishop
c750
she got five with me
oh he was gonna get mated
oh my God
it was that might be the most
unbelievable thing I've ever seen and
wait a second black could still lose
this that's the craziest thing King F5
and white is still playing for a win
what a Twist that would be Knight C6
gotta get your night in the game oh my
goodness taken 96. King H7 and now black
might win after Knight D4 the Pawn's the
right color this is remarkable yeah the
a pawn is the right color for both
Bishops but okay white should not lose
this because black can't make any
progress in fact black could lose this
after Knight G6 Bishop D3
sat the bishop for G5 do 's thing
probably a good move
he takes it yeah my God playing it safe
holy smokes what the hell just happened
dude Bogdan has honestly had the most
frustrating PCL run of anybody with
literally two games
what the heck was that how did he manage
this bishop he is beside himself he
can't believe this is ridiculous
ridiculous this is a mate yeah so that
was set up on the previous turn what was
the move nice
I saw that when he played Knight C2 he
must have seen that mating net and it's
a miracle that Bogdan has
94.96 otherwise he loses otherwise it's
over
holy smokes yeah and and by the way
after this I know that it kind of is
leaning in Black's favor the eval bar I
have to say it's like not entirely
obvious at all how black is supposed to
win this so I think draw might be a fair
result oh I don't think it is winnable I
think point eight is the evolver getting
a little too emotional maybe you can
somehow go King H6 and Bishop E7 but no
with just one Pawn remaining on the
queen side I don't think this is
winnable even remotely in fact I think
Boyer deserves credit for drawing this
with the pawns running up the board like
that yeah he maintained the presence of
mine didn't get nervous and he holds a
huge draw that allows the blitz to tie
the match at four a piece I'm on this
was insane yeah and you you highlighted
it it just feels like uh Bogdan Daniel
Daya keeps finding himself on the wrong
end of highlight Clips I mean for all
the wrong reasons uh the poor guy he put
together an amazing amazing game I mean
we we had uh vehicles on and he was
talking about the great conversion
technique and he was right yeah that was
like literally Flawless just a kind of a
freak accident there and what a setup by
Boyer to even find that Checkmate idea
two and a half to one and a half round
two score which knocks us up at four
points this is so close Daniel
this has been a wild match we've had
some games that have gone completely off
the rails really from the very first
round grishek managed to win a big game
against bordia dineshwar never an easy
opponent and mvl he is the engine of the
blitz match uh right now he's got two
points out of two games but he's gone
through some very dubious positions he
had a crazy game in round one which he
could have lost to dineshvar and this
time mvl winning a significantly
smoother game although no less crazy
game against Paulina shuvala but they
need more of the same if the blitz are
to have a good chance to reach eight and
a half points first a month that's right
we've seen a lot of mismatches so far uh
it seems like the higher rated players
are getting it done as they should a
very similar situation on both sides for
where the teams are getting their points
from and uh we want to remind people
Dania before we go into our break for
round three of course we have to remind
not just the chat but the title people
in chat are you a title player you want
to compete in the 2023 Champions chess
tour this is your chance don't miss it
you can qualify for the tour's second
event we host the qualifiers every
Monday excluding the days when other
Champions chess tour events are underway
this is your next chance to join the
action Monday March 6th for details use
exclamation mark qualifiers in the chat
I think there's no doubt Daniel will see
a lot of exclamation mark qualifiers a
lot of titled players in the chat a lot
of chat Grand Masters that are certainly
looking to qualify for this uh Champions
chess tour Dania that was a uh exciting
round I am pleased to say we're tied up
4-4 which means I can say with certainty
we are gonna get all four rounds today
but round three is coming up next so
don't go anywhere PCL returns after this
I don't think about during the games but
I certainly like do think about
how like
a few African-Americans there are like
the top level so I try to do my best to
to motivate more people like us to
give it a try and hopefully succeed
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck
quack quack
how to play duck chess the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the doctor
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow though
there's no stalemates but still wait
there is still me but the still made the
player wins ooh if only that was real
chess I think I'm getting the hang of
this game I think I think I actually am
getting the hang of it
I think this works
oh that's a horrible blunder oh my God I
just blundered I have to move something
else first then dark and Knight will
take my king this is the best way to
lose the dark chest
there's some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time winning
duck chess That's so exciting
I won
duck chess champion give me those points
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
what a beautiful tactic the Indian yogis
are the first team to make it to the
playoffs
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights
bras and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives
what a stunning move this is just
unbelievable
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule only one team can be
crowned the next PCL Champion
it was a huge bonus
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
and the bee Pawn comes oh my goodness
Miley way to go girl that's huge
that is huge for us
welcome back to an approaches ligander
we have a guest commentator in garage
sport uh in all reality it's GM Daniel
aritzki sadly no Gary for us today but
we have a different world champion Grand
Mastermind Hamilton we hope you've been
enjoying our coverage of PCL Thursday we
are in the midst of a much closer match
Aman than we saw in the morning the
score
the bar isn't very it's not very hard to
have a closer match it's as close of a
match as it gets though all tied up at
four yeah uh truly I think this has
lived up to the expectations neither
team uh wants to give any ground here we
have four to four and look at the
results the top two uh boards for each
team are bringing home the majority of
the points but you're getting a half
Point here and there from your board
three and four that's exactly what
you're looking for it seems like both
teams managers have drafted some very
close lineups and they're matching up
neck and neck Dania well we heard from
the Bulldogs manager he is very proud to
have drafted bardia dineshvar and on
that note as we look at uh the round
three lineups I really like the role
reversal that happens uh with players
like mahel Boyer and on the other side
Guardian ashvar who just played mvl and
grishok these are not games he is
expected to win but the last two games
of the round he turns from the hunted to
the Hunter and he needs to do some
hunting if the Bulldogs are to succeed
in the final two rounds and yes we are
guaranteed a round four what a relief
I'm on I know we're we're here for uh
all the action today uh Baghdad and
Daniel dayak against mvl I think that
right there is uh an extremely high
profile match because Ogden Daniel deck
he just has not had his match he hasn't
had his PCL season I want to say uh
things just keep happening in him for
the wrong reasons and uh you know this
is exactly
I know it's just it's so criminal
because he puts in like all the legwork
and then right at the Finish Line it's
almost like he trips over his own feet
you know uh quitting a pawn like
something as simple as that when I
couldn't even begin to put in all the
legwork that he does beforehand no he
honestly slaying such high quality chess
and two of the best games that he's
played in his entire PCL season thus far
one of them was against Darius schmirtz
what will not be talked about against
the context of him not promoting the
pawn is that that was actually an
incredible positional game that I'd be
proud to play in a classical game same
with his game against my Hellboy so he
has to find some way to maintain his
composure and time pressure ultimately
among I think that is what's driving
these freak results is the fact that he
is finding himself you know grishek
style in a lot of time pressure right
out of the opening so maybe trusting his
intuition a little bit more leaving
himself with that extra 10-15 seconds
that he can use to avoid those freak
checkmates and you know lack of
promotions and whatever has been
affecting him so he's got to push all
that behind him because he's got a major
trial coming up right now against Mr
Maxim
that's right the uh the teams decided to
match up everyone with three names
against everyone with three names yeah
the uh oh this is actually similar but
you know finally we see the bishop on a
more natural diagonal I think
um bdd had G3 and Bishop G2 previously
um not to be confused I'm on with BD
that would be part Dia de neshvar so we
got two players those initials are BD on
the same team what are the odds of that
anyways sorry it's a distract us from
this enlightening Illuminating analysis
of this fascinating
asymmetrical position yeah no there's a
lots going on here and as I say that it
kind of is a lot going on here
I mean this move needs explanation
because the moot B5 it almost looks like
an error it's like wait a minute did you
think you were getting your Bishop to uh
B7 you're gonna have to play Rook A7 and
strangely enough Rook might even slide
over all the way to D7 in front of the
queen we can see the bishop go to B7 and
you know Black's getting his pieces
developed and Orthodox way here and I
think newer players they hesitate to
make awkward looking moves because they
look at a move like Rick A7 and
something about it just seems very
discordant something about it just seems
like you're admitting defeat in the
opening but in reality The Rook is very
well placed on A7 it's essentially as
good as it would be on A8 and what a
move by mvl very committal decision to
play E5 very importantly the Knight
cannot jump out to out five that's one
of the benefits of keeping the bishop on
C8 for now is that it forces the Knight
probably back to C2 you could go Knight
E2 but then you'd have to reckon with a
very nasty idea of E4 that might lose a
piece I think mvl is doing oh there's
also Knight C6 sorry I forgot about that
Knight C6 is a bit of a funny looking
move because you're entering your
opponent's territory there now there's
two pawns hanging mvl has B5 and E5
hanging however uh because it's his turn
I think there are a few different ways
to sort of gain time attacking a a piece
for example I don't know Queen takes
Queen can be played Queen C7
um it hits the bishop as well as
defending the pawn and trying to think
what what move I prefer here it's not
that easy to uh to decide if I'm honest
I'm having a hard time making heads or
tails of this B takes A4 can reflect in
to kind of eliminate the headache of one
of the hanging pawns but then you have a
different headache to deal with which is
that Bishop takes E5 in response trades
a corner Pawn for a center pawn and then
there are some crazy ideas connected
with trapping The Rook in the corner
with Bishop B8 so now is decision time
for bdd
maybe bishop takes E5 maybe that's a
move to play Bishop B8 I thought I might
say that as a joke but now I'm serious
well I think the the less exotic
alternative is is obviously to take on
A4 but there's another decision
associated with that which piece are you
taking with and oddly enough Amman I
actually think Bishop takes A4 might be
worthwhile the bishop has sort of
overstayed its welcome on C6 and can
actually be used by black as fodder for
getting his Rook to d8 quickly I'm
predicting Bishop takes A4 I think Dash
especially after the last round wants to
play with an abundance of caution in the
early going of this game
yeah you're not you're not wrong there I
think that would be a wise decision at
least early on I mean these players are
going to be playing for a while uh there
will certainly be chances for one if not
both of them uh later later stages of
this game so I mean looking at the
bird's eye view of all the games right
now
um we see in the top right that's the
game that we just started by taking a
look at I'm looking at what we have on
the board here and find myself you know
immediately drawn to some of the other
positions like bottom left Mahal Boyer
there's like a bishop that appears to be
hanging uh you know temporarily using a
pin there and if I'm not mistaken that
we've seen this opening before it almost
seems reminiscent of that mvl wild game
that he played against Polina
yeah white is I'd say definitely finding
himself more in my heaven than in my
hell I mean the bishop on C4 is hanging
we're just going to pretend I was
watching you on the camera as I was
saying and it was just sort of an
experiment
I was just watching your face you know
react in this contortion kind of way
that tells us all we need to know the
bishop on C4 is not technically hanging
well it is but it can't be captured
obviously because of Queen takes d8 and
I'm on that is the price that black pays
for not coordinating her Rooks soon
enough so presumably Paulina is going to
get her night out to D7 and the big
question for Boyer is going to be how
does he want to recapture on D5 I would
be leaning toward doing it with a piece
in order to preserve maximum activity so
I would like Bishop takes D5 here but
Pawn takes D5 does come with Tempo what
where do you stand on that topic I think
um in these kind of first of all in this
opening you very often see ethics D5
um and just pushing that pawn like Tigs
try to play D6 for the moment if you
take with the pawn it definitely looks
like Black's intending Knight A5
attacking that light Square bishop and
then perhaps Queen D6 so a lot of times
if white can take on D5 and then play D6
and maybe D7 I know it looks funny but
getting that pawn all the way to D7
really early on and completely
restricted tie down your opponent's
pieces but I think black is going to get
Queen D6 to blockade that that pawn
before that's even possible so because
of that I think I'm leaning Bishop takes
D5
agreed and that's actually a total Game
Changer the presence of the possibility
of Knight A5 to buy yourself that Tempo
that you can use to blockade the pawn
and then the D5 Pawn goes from being
White's biggest strength to White's
biggest liability because it could be
further attacked by a move like Rook a
to d8 so if I'm border this is where I'm
trying to save time he's experienced
pressure on the clock the first two
games right here these types of
decisions are the ones among that I
think you should try to make a little
bit more intuitively than he's been
making them in the first two games for
sure it looks like he's trying to
calculate when you know Bishop takes D5
can be played by white here with almost
no calculation you you know that that
move cannot be a mistake Pawn takes on
D5 admittedly does need a bit more uh
calculation behind it but still Knight
A5 Queen D6 is kind of a two move
thought you just have to pick which
position you like more I do think that
if you're unsure you find yourself just
going over variations in your head
Bishop takes D5
keeps the structure a bit more intact
and definitely has less risk So
eventually makes the decision which I
would consider to be just the solid
option
agreed completely Polina gets her Queen
off of the default there were ideas like
Bishop takes F7 with the queen moving
away and exposing a discovery against
black screen so I think it's a wise
decision by Paulina the position has
more or less stabilized and I think it's
a good time for us to travel back to the
bird's eye view or the Bev as you know
the industry Specialists tend to refer
to it I'm looking at the bottom right
where we have a sicilian I think it
might be our first Sicilian of the day
in cornet's game against uh BD not to be
confused again with bdd uh bardia
dineshwar has played a sicilian and is
embracing his new role among which is
that he really needs to try to go 2-0 in
the last two games that's right
um yeah let's jump to that game it it
does look a little bit strange to see a
Pawn on F6 in Black's position but the
bishop on F4 means it's a it's going to
be a while before that Knight gets
booted out of the E5 square and guess
what if it does there's great pastors
awaiting on C4 Knight C4 is a move that
black might play anyway so I am liking
the way that bardia has set up his
pieces feels like a very strong position
and well uh Cornett kind of has all her
pieces developed
I'm not really convinced that they're on
great squares it's sort of weird it's
like almost like a little artificial
every piece is developed Bishop on G2
Knight C3 Bishop F4 you know you almost
want to play Rook to D1 and just say
okay I've got all my pieces where they
should be but something about White's
position for me just feels a little
incomplete Daniel I'm not sure how to
describe it
I think part of it is the lack of
targets and relaxed position I mean D7
is a bit of a weakness but right now
it's defended three different ways and
it can't really be effectively attacked
and combine that with the excellent
placement of blacks pieces especially if
that dark squared Bishop comes out to C5
so Cornett is trying to spark some sort
of fire on the queen side with a very
typical move A4 but black could meet
that pretty straightforwardly with B4 I
wanted to show an instructive line I
think a lot of newer players in
particular would be very tempted with
the possibility of Bishop take C5 so
let's say for example that after B4
black takes on E5 and then drops the
Knight back to e so why is this so bad
for white aren't the you know the pawns
doubled isn't the pawn structure damaged
well all of it has to do with the dark
squares and with the newly opened app f
file which black piles up on so so
quickly after something like Rick 81
Castle short I'm on I think you'll
co-sign this the pressure on F2 becomes
virtually unbearable in the span of like
two move so definitely cornet wants to
keep her dark squared Bishop alive
and we see a couple of moves here Knight
C4 and queen back to C1 is on the board
yeah Knight C4 was it looks like
definitely the way to go now you can
throw in the move before I find it hard
to imagine that won't get played the
only other move that I might be
considering is I was even going to say
Bishop B4 we see Bishop C5 it is similar
in nature but interesting he's kind of
baiting the move you know Pawn takes B5
Knight takes B5 hoping to uh get Queen
B6 hitting F2 and that loose Knight on
B5 so Bishop C5 does come with a little
bit of poison to it uh and as you
pointed out in the previous line makes
way for black to kingside Castle
Yen let's see what Cornett decides here
I'm thinking about the move B3 here as
nerve-wracking as it could be to leave
the C3 Knight without a Defender
particularly with that Rook on C8
staring right at it I think getting rid
of the Knight on C4 might be the first
step toward achieving at least some
breathing room for your pieces if you're
Demonte Garnett right now she's driven
all of her heavy pieces are really
driven back to the first rank the Knight
on C3 doesn't have any prospects her
Bishops may look nice but they're also
not really controlling any important
squares if you allow Queen B6 I'm on you
know black Titans the screws a little
bit further and you could find yourself
you know driven so far back that you
just don't have the activity to keep all
your weak points defended
yeah exactly they're I think you said it
best early on when you pointed out
there's just not many targets for
Cornett to attack in this position and
it makes finding a plan very difficult
and honestly you know you give this
advice to to beginner players as they're
starting out it's better to have
probably a bad plan than no plan at all
because at least all your pieces are
moving in some sort of cohesion you have
an overall goal in mind and uh you know
your pieces are working together so
that's the impression I get with
bardia's position the pieces are coming
out F2 is a target everything seems to
be working but you know cornet just
doesn't have anything to get going and
B3 just looks like hey I've got to do
something let's kick out one of Black's
best pieces tactically does this work
Dania
I think it might 95 is I wouldn't say
forced I mean the Knight could have
dropped back to B6 but this is the most
reasonable Square because you want to
leave the B6 Square for blacks Queen and
once again Knight takes B5 Queen B6 is a
straightforward Fork on the Knight and
the F2 Pawn so that's Unthinkable I'm
also looking at Demonte cornet's clock I
could totally see her take two or three
minutes on the next couple of moves I
think bardia has this not just under
control but I really think the black
might be winning in just a couple of
moves here if cornet is not Ultra
precise
agreed agreed yeah we can let the
players think about this position and
maybe return and and take a look at all
the games overall but this looks like a
good spot for the Croatia Bulldogs to be
in on this board and yet looking at some
of the other games that uh are ongoing I
mean we haven't checked in with you know
the heavyweight matchup there between
grishook and inditch should we go to
that
yeah especially because a lot is
happening there the Queens are off the
board someone in chat said the most
obvious statement of all time which is
the grishok is down five minutes I mean
tell me something I don't know but I
think this is exactly that before and a
half with two minutes exactly I mean
yeah it's true like 99 of the time
six so down five minutes but I mean you
have to say of all of grisha's five
minute down positions this has to be one
of the most manageable
yeah this looks like it might fizzle out
into a draw like in the span of a couple
moves in fact I think white is the one
who has to be cautious at least for the
next couple of moves because if you're
just nonchalantly grab B7 maybe you can
get away with that but I would not be
allowing black stroke to infiltrate down
the second rank because we know I'm on
it in the end game it's really all about
piece activity material count is often
subservient to how active your pieces
are especially if you can get two of
your Rooks on the second rank
yeah I mean if you want to pull up an
analysis board just to show how bad it
could get just with Tempe Bishop takes
B7 let's say I don't know Rook B8 Bishop
A6 Rook E6 and I'm just imagining like
chasing the bishop to E2 and then
something like Rook B2 and you're just
saying okay you can't Castle I'm
attacking your Bishop okay Bishop F3 all
of a sudden black might play Bishop C4
and suddenly you know it maybe it's not
that bad according to the the eval bar
but I think most players Daniel look at
this and just see the inability to
Castle and value that way more than a
pawn yeah we take it for granted when
computers give equality in a position
like this but playing when you're this
paralyzed going back and forth like Rook
C1 Rook A1 is incredibly hard for a
human to do now this is insane I'm on
they have this position
has been playing they literally are
going down this line I can't get over
that this it was with rookie six as well
okay it was specifically with Rook B6 as
you indicated that was the moment of the
comments very good job there we go we
got one there I wonder if Bishop F3 will
be played because it isn't forced you
can play like you know Rook deep one for
example but I think the the reason that
it was so surprising is because White
had the option to take the bishop why
did he want this yeah it's so
unnecessary you could have taken the
bishop and gone King E2 and okay maybe
you make a couple more defensive that's
a draw let's be real white shouldn't
have any problems securing half a point
why is doing the stem self following him
on Hamilton's I mean maybe he misheard
you yeah right he thought that this was
a good line for white right under what
circumstance I'm on in what Universe
does he voluntarily opt for this
position he might still be able to draw
but now he's in for a long and torturous
defense it doesn't make sense to me
because he had to draw there look the
match is 4-4 no one needs to be a hero
right now it's clear that a draw against
Alexander grishook is not a bad result
um he just had to make that draw in
front of me you had to take the bishop
but he felt compelled to do this and
guess what he is already in full regret
mode
oh totally and the great thing about
being Grisha cure and this is what I
would do I would just take the rook and
play Rook A2 I would start by
eliminating the risk because you're
going to win that pawn one way or the
other white probably should play A4 and
try to use that pawn as a bargaining
chip and force the bishop trade but in
ditch I still think he should be able to
hold half a point and he's gonna have
his work cut out for him unless of
course grishook decides to take this
Pawn quickly and white somehow gets his
King out of the cage but no question
that grishook is in the driver's seat
here
and we'll continue to push this yeah or
not yeah no it looks like Bishop A4 is
it's just presented itself okay he's
gonna he's gonna take it if you ask me
indic kind of got off scot-free there I
think he'll be happy to have made the
draw that easily let's say
um yeah but okay probably the expected
result overall
and I think the expected result is a
draw in our other heavyweight game
between Dash and mvl which is heading in
the direction of a Time scribble bogdon
once again is No two minutes but that's
not the only game which is catching my
eye my health Boyer is also in some
trouble against shuvalova his Central
pressure did not turn out very well and
I'm also looking at the bottom board
bottom right looks like bardia is still
very much in control against Demonte
corn Adam on I know I've made too many
decisions today
um no I've made not enough decisions but
you've made such good decisions that if
it ain't broke don't fix it I I think
it's clear we we got to check out the
game of mahel Boyer against Paulina
shivalova I think there's just okay
still a lot to play for in bardia's
position and the other one does look
very drawish this one however I'm
starting to see a potential for uh you
know an advantage developing here we
have an extra Pawn for Paulina and my
Hellboy or he's faced with the tricky
situation he thought he might have been
uncorking tactics with Knight to F5 on
the previous turn right yes that exposes
yeah I mean imagine Queen D7 right just
to sort of show what he was probably
thinking these are going through his
head takes and takes again in 97. that
was pretty extreme no no that's a fork
we're staring you Maddie Savage
the win the queen Governor how you doing
Arena and she's not phased by this no
she she saw this and said okay yeah yeah
that's cute but I have my own tactics
Queen F6 and guess what now you can't
take me because your back rank is uh all
the maybe all the way yeah there you go
that's normally have the strength to
drag the queen all the way to A1 but
Molina would and this would be Chuck
mate what's even more concerning him on
is the clock situation again Boyer is
under a minute I don't see him pulling
this one out I mean defend this position
down upon forever and a minute on the
clock don't see it happening
yep I I'm I also see just from the
bird's eye view that another game
features time pressure as well and it's
it's our crowd favorite Baghdad Daniel
Dash oh he's meeting him he's made a
draw okay that's a good sign I saw the
time pressure nearing 10 seconds for him
and I got a little concerned you know
forgive me but he does make a draw so
the top two boards of draw Dania it's
the bottom two boards that are gonna
decide everything this round
well I actually think the Nashua is
probably going to win and chevalova has
great chances to win this might be a
huge round for the Croatia Bulldogs I
think my hell Boyer of the two remaining
games has the best chance of saving the
position wait he's down to 10 seconds
he's not moving we gotta go back to his
game what the heck is happening just
five seconds
make a move one second oh my gosh are
you gonna move with two seconds he
played Knight H6 Jack and he's trying to
go down upon in the end game
how do you save this with two seconds
left make a move I did
God
he's like addicted to this feeling I
guess I mean there was no need to spend
three minutes on that move
that's I mean yeah I think that's
something that Kevin bordee looks at and
you know he wonders why you know he's
having so many heart attacks watching
these games it's stuff like that
yeah Jesus and what I would do with
black hair I'm on and let's be clear
what Black's work is not over right you
actually need to convert this Rook end
games are all drawn so paulina's not
thinking of this as a done deal Rook C4
and Rook A4 I think would be a
worthwhile maneuver to force Dwight's
Rook to get passive right that's what
you always want to start with because
the last thing you want is white to work
running amok especially with uh some
weak ones on the king side
absolutely yeah the the last thing you
want to do is black is trade uh you know
the a pawn for your a pawn for example
you don't need to make it that simple
for what I like your idea every okay for
and don't play for a White's clock
because I've had some time scrambles
against Boyer he is really good at
keeping a cool head with no time on the
clock in an end game that's a little bit
easier to do and pulling a she keeps her
objectivity she's gonna get that Rook to
A4 and maybe start bringing your king
into the center maybe start pushing your
queen side pawns but you gotta do it
very very carefully don't go A5 and
allow Rook to B3
would have been a good pre-move there
I'm I'm a little surprised that
um that Boyer has brought the Rook to F3
and like given that check because it
seems like Black's King wants to go the
direction it's going like why are we why
are we forcing this
I think he's trying to gain some time
and he suddenly has 11 seconds that
seems so luxurious but he's 11 seconds
will not be enough if black makes a new
Queen
yeah I've really got me thinking about
moves like King C4 the funny thing about
King C4 is White's probably gonna keep
pushing upon like H5 H4 and H5 those are
useful moves because when you take all
these Pawns in Black's position hey you
need your H Pawn pushed anyway
in Boyer's Minds he thinks the only
chance is in fact for him to create a
passer as long as that process would
take he has no other way to defend so
he's delaying where it takes F7 and as
you set him on maybe he won't even go
for the F fun maybe he'll go for the h
puns instead
if that will allow black to achieve
connected past pawns unless Paulina goes
before which I by the way would not do I
would not play before prematurely maybe
start with King C4 but where are you
going from there how are you making
progress if you're not going to play
before I think black could even get in
serious trouble playing King C4 after H5
something doesn't feel right about that
position because white has a pair of
connected pass pawns that are arriving
with the G and H Pawn as well so King E6
I have to say that feels like the move I
would play as well that's a good sign
for Boyer but I like it true Oliver is
resetting and maybe now it's a good time
or even Rook C4 yeah this looks it makes
sense to me I mean getting that Rook out
of A4
sign me up for that and boy are doing
what he has to do that F7 Pawn is the
only Target right now and he keeps
training his Rook at it what about King
D6 Rook C7 Rook C7 guards upon play Rook
B7 and B4 I like The Rook behind the
password just like your mama taught you
hey that's right I tell you it's the
lessons are ingrained Dania Brook behind
the pawn and just that's the easiest way
that you can play I think uh-oh Rook F7
here we go here we go this is a three
result game now this is absolutely a
three result game now I would take H7
take H6
and push your H1 go
yeah there's no Rook F5 it just doesn't
doesn't feel right
not at all I think after Rook H7 White
had winning chances Boyer might end up
actually wasting a Tempo here if he's
not careful yeah I can't take C4 what is
he doing what okay he wants Rook at four
check and if King he wants Rook B4 check
I think King D3
then still Rook before but then you've
got Rook B3 yeah he's definitely missed
something King D3 and black is getting
the same position but like 20 moves
ahead I this is Unthinkable after doing
so much and now he has to play Rook F5
which he does Rook H5
Black's gonna take the pawn with his
King
and we are gonna get a pawn race them on
wait a second It's Not Over
Rook A6 H6 wait
H6 go push move
but this can't do it no what is he doing
or is that interesting H6 Rook A3 I
think he was worried about but there was
H7 there H7 why on Earth would you give
away your pawn and shovel might have
left upon through oh she's going what
the heck is happening
oh my God it's check on G8 it's just
gonna win this he's gonna win he's gonna
trade the queen back he's forcing the
queen trade after promoting oh my
goodness it's forced no King A3 what a
great movement she stays in the game but
take the Rock and this is indefensible
with four seconds left
what did we just see shavala can't
believe it and she's gonna walk into a
queen trade
where are the danger squares I guess
there's not that many for the moment
King F4 well E5 right Eve Queen E5 check
forces the queen trade oh
shivalova trying to sidestep it I would
go back there no he borders the pump
are you kidding me
[Music]
I have three and there are no more
checks I mean white has great chances
there
now watching now slip 24. believe it
he is both players are holding their
heads this is the most rarest result
I've ever seen I I see him hanging his
head but shufalaba was also hanging her
head and you and I were both grabbing
our heads no one was happy with that
result
and I will say that winning this was not
as easy as I thought you actually had an
only move here so I take back what I
said Rook d8 G5 and Rook h8 wins on yeah
I have to interrupt it because there's
one more game oh my gosh underway
and it's probably in a Time scramble at
this point what and it's just finished
it's just unfinished bardia dineshwar
won his game thank you for letting me
know oh my God he won a crucial game for
the Croatia bulldogs and he's the only
decisive game of the round this was nuts
I can't believe it that that round ended
with like time scrambles for everyone it
was the bottom two boards that were just
scintillating this round we had some
kind of you know whatever round beat
around the bush draws by these one of
the GMS we're here to watch the action
Daniel the bottom two boards delivered
they did indeed Rook end games always
result in some craziness
oh my God Paulina and bardia and mahel
are gonna have to push what just
happened out of their minds uh not
bardia he won a relatively smooth game
against De Monte cornet the score before
the final round ladies and gentlemen is
six and a half five and a half in favor
of the Bulldogs and the silver lining
for the blitzman is that Alexander
grishook is doing okay mvl is having a
fantastic performance so really it's up
to Boyer and Cornett to deliver for the
bottom boards because they need to win
the match two and a half one and a half
to force the tie breaks
that's right and from what we've seen
here I think anything is possible I mean
mahel Boyer has been playing some very
enterprising chess definitely getting in
Balance positions he's gonna be up
against bardia and uh right at the top
there the opponents are just gonna
switch so they're gonna be just as
serious of matchups grishook is going to
be playing against board one in Bogdan
Daniel dayak and everyone is going to be
matched up against their counterpart on
the other team Daniel this final round
is going to be so intense because I mean
the Bulldogs still need two points to
win this thing so it's not like oh we
only need a draw to be nice and easy no
I mean anything can happen in this final
round and the blitz could absolutely win
I mean we've seen a 4-0 performance by
the yoga I mean we've seen comebacks of
Greater magnitude than this and this
match the way it's gone it's so
unpredictable folks you will not want to
miss the conclusion of our second PCL
match of the day but before we conclude
that match and watch this scintillating
final round unfold we are going to take
one more break we hope you're enjoying
our coverage of PCL Thursday we will be
back with round four of the Croatia
Blitz the Croatia Bulldogs against the
Blitz in just a couple of moments folks
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
consternation on the face of Uncle Sasha
Alexander grishook is board one for the
Blitz and he will have to deliver in
this crucial final round hopefully he'll
Deliver us some songs on whatever
instrument is behind him while his team
the blitz is down one point to the
Croatia Bulldogs the score going into
the final round is five and a half six
and a half Grand Master on Hamilton
Chris shook and mvl really need their
best performance in the Final Round Here
they absolutely do and this uh this
final round determines everything it
doesn't matter what kind of day you've
had so far what kind of form you're in
it's purely about this final round of
gameplay here Dania right now obviously
mvl and in ditch uh doing very well for
uh their their respective teams but you
can see the difference there it's that
board for performance Polina shivalova
she has been able to eke out a draw here
a draw there and that one point is the
difference otherwise equal and very
similar performances on every board so
that does point me to say Demonte cornet
might need to really step up here and I
could see that board for matchup
determining the entire thing that's the
beauty of the protest League every game
is worth exactly one point no more and
no less and in the final round board one
faces board one four two faces for two
Etc and it's by Design right you want
the final round to feature I think the
fairest matchups and that is what we get
here so what are the X Factor games
obviously grishook and MBL they need to
try to get I think at least one and a
half points between them and Boyer and
they Monte Cornett need to try to do the
same the matchup that I'm most worried
about on the blitz's behalf of mon is
that dineshwar Boyer game Dinesh frog
with white is just a force to be
reckoned with and shivalova is
definitely the favorite against Demonte
cornet so one of these two players is
going to have to outperform the
expectations let alone grishek and mvl
whose good performance is a total
prerequisite to a comeback in this Final
Round right
that's right and a little more work has
to be done on the side of the blitz they
are down a point going into this so even
if the the match gets you know for
example even if they win two and a half
one and a half we'll be seeing a playoff
tiebreak right you have to you have to
think from the uh from the blitz side
they have a lot more work to do to win
this in regulation so to speak I think
it comes down to the color of the pieces
though Dania white pieces for grishook
and mvl you have to hold them to high
standards here your team needs you you
have the white pieces the two lower
boards for the blitz have the black
pieces you mentioned you know bardia
with white pieces very tough to handle
and Paulina has been having a day so far
so I think you've got to lean on your
top boards if you're the Blitz
and obviously they can't lose I mean if
either grishok or mvl loses the game
technically mathematically they can
still win the match but I feel like it
would be exceedingly unlikely that
cornet and Boyer get two out of two
between them but that's why we watch the
PCL right you can never predict the
course that these matches are going to
take well you could predict the course
that this game has taken because Dash
has been essaying the Petrov pretty
consistently especially when he's needed
a solid result he played one B6 in the
first round something uh I'm not that
surprised that he hasn't repeated this
experiment against Christian that's
right yeah I think uh I think that was
more of a board one versus Board four
kind of decision rather than a board one
versus Board one kind of decision
um but speaking of I mean grishook he is
trying to avoid just an obvious draw
right he he wants a position where he
can play he's imbalanced it already I
think this is what he was looking for
from the opening yeah yeah he wasn't
looking to play a petrol trade Pawns in
the middle and play symmetrical no not
at all and he's gotten the sort of
asymmetrical position he would want now
obviously this isn't the type of
asymmetry where you get opposite side
castling and attacks on both Kings this
is largely a positional structural type
of asymmetry where you often see white
repositioning the knight from E2 to G3
this is a common idea in most of these
rui Lopez Italian type openings and then
white could slowly but surely try to
accumulate pieces on the king side but
largely Amman I think this position is
pretty stable and I think it will be
decided in a long and drawn out middle
game
yep that that's something I completely
agree with we're going to see a lot of
maneuvering in this uh game right here I
think Knight E2 is uh indeed and it's on
the board so indeed it's a nice plan and
it also ensures that there's going to be
clear imbalances Knights against Bishops
black might have had the opportunity to
play Bishop takes C3 in some lines you
know not the best but it was it was on
the the table now bishook insurers with
that Knight reaching G3 that things will
absolutely be in Balance both uh with
the minor pieces and the pawn structure
for the rest of the game so this should
be kind of slow moving going forward it
should and slow moving literally because
both players are obviously taking their
time not a surprise when you've got
grishook against thatch I'd be surprised
if this wasn't a Time scramble by move
15 so as Dash contemplates his next step
I think it's a good time for us to take
a swing back to the bird's eye view
because all four games are now
officially underway the clock was just
started on that bottom right board
between shravalavo and Demonte it we
have another Sicilian on the docket here
between mvl and indige that's top right
and a very strange opening at the bottom
left I don't even know what that is I
was about to slide me
closer look at that we got we have to
take a look at that because I've simply
never seen this and even looking at it
now I'm not sure I could produce what
the opening moves were like how exactly
did we get here I think it involved the
moves G3 and B6 but I don't want to be
too controversial here I want to keep my
commentary job okay so this started out
normally but black played a relatively
unorthodox move the immediate B6 here is
relatively uncommon and white tries to
punish black by striking at the center
immediately black takes on C4 also
pretty uncommon you usually see white
declining that quote-unquote sacrifice
with E6 Knight A3 E5 exploiting
obviously the pin on the bishop yep and
after Knight C4 he just goes towards
steps on the gas pedal and develops his
Knight to H6
my head hurts nothing about this is
normal yeah give me like two Advil
please and a tall glass of water what
the heck is going on so everybody there
actually has not been a night so like
it's all on the night on B8 he could be
the only Knight developing that's not
touch the side of the board night A3
Knight H4 Knight H6 what the heck is
going on here white is fixated on
playing the move Knight to F5 and also
had to be sure not to lose the Knight as
you're highlighting I mean G5 was
literally threatening to win the game
yo let's just castle and keep developing
G5 it's zero one now G5 is met with
Knight hf5 but that doesn't mean black
shouldn't play G5 I think G5 is still a
very legitimate move expanding on the
king side and the Knight on F5 in the
subsequent position I'm on can be
targeted with a well-timed queen D7 the
last thing that we need in this position
is opposite side castling and yet that
is exactly what we might get that's
right oh look at this idea if White
Castle's here if we can pull up an
analysis board it appears that white
runs into G5 but I think white can still
play Knight hf5 that's after Knight F5
Bishop H3 The crucial detail although
the queen hangs is that Bishop takes D7
of course comes with a check
yep that is that's a nice line because
Queen D7 I have to say it looks like
it's played to threaten G5 so it's
always very cruel when you make a move
that threatens something and your
opponent makes a move that allows you to
play it and you're like wait and one of
us missed something
yeah Castle's short ignoring the thread
and if white doesn't Castle the only way
that I see to prevent a G5 is the move
F4
ooh this is tricky now wait a second G5
Knight F5 is there some tactic there
after Knight takes F5 Bishop H3 or does
this still work for white it appears
like it does still get the job done it
doesn't really matter where White Queen
is Black's Queen is still on D7 with
chat so I'm kind of wondering
what move they want here
they all they engine enthusiasts
the Silicon fiends yes F5 has been
played that is the best move F7 F5 has
black heard of the term development
clearly not but clearly he knows this
better uh than anyone with a normal view
of the position because now Amman
finally well G5 might still not be a
threat yeah five is not possible because
the pawn will land on G6 and support the
Knight on F5 yeah it's ironic that G5
looks like it wins the Knight but it's
actually the only move that loses if you
do nothing you're fine but G5
specifically creates the losing position
because the pawn don't go backward and
you can't play G6 I think the larger
problem for white is not G5 it's the
fact that well black will first of all
Play Bishop E7 Knight C6 and what it's
easy to miss him on is that white is
doing quite badly in the center but yeah
it hasn't occupied the central squares
with any of his pawns so black is
dominating in the center and if black
plays Bishop E7 and Bishop takes H4
black will be dominating on the king
side as well Boyer has a great position
here out of this ridiculous opening he
does I see Knight C6 Knight D4 I mean
not only is that gonna come with Tempo
attacking the queen it's right directly
in the center it also guards F5 and on
top of all that D3 is a normal like
freeing move to uh to get out of you
know this nasty Pawn on e4 the black has
so many moves to play against that
whether it's Bishop B4 spec haking and
hitting the queen G5 hitting the Knight
there's just so many moves to be scared
of
I think G5 might finally be possible if
white plays D3 because we don't have to
show this but at the end of the line
after Bishop H3 which white plays anyway
straight away but what's the follow-up
gonna be look at White's pieces all of
them are trained at this Pawn chain
they're literally biting on granite I
think dineshwar might have lost the
threat of this game completely I think
he did because guess what Bishop to B2
Bishop G7 can be played it's guarded by
the queen so can you just continue in
stride here Knight C6 and even Bishop B2
maybe even Knight D4
even Rook G8 I mean you could move your
Rook away and White's pieces have no
Rhyme or Reason behind the way that
they're developed White's not going to
lose in three moves but he might lose in
10 once black Castle's Queen side him on
and puts a knight on D4 and these pawns
are set in motion yeah this might be a
disaster this looks like it is I'm just
gonna call a spade a spade this looks
like a terrible opening for bardia uh
mahel Boyer look we can't call it too
early but we can definitely say a
serious real Advantage here with the
black pieces in such an easy position to
play oh
but apparently Bishop G7 wasn't the most
accurate move the evil bar has just shot
back up
that is Queen takes E4 oh oh
Queen takes you for you yeah
let me reword that Mahal had a very real
and noticeable advantage and he doesn't
have it anymore
this is a disaster now from the opposite
side Queen takes E4 and the reason this
works is because the bishop on G7 not
only hangs but once you take it black
and simply resign yeah because it's the
fork on the bishop the rook and the
Knight that was a great spot by you
always pay attention to the pins however
insignificant they might seem so after
Queen takes the Forum on it's not like
the game ends black plays King f8 true
and we've got total pandemonium on the
board maybe white could even sack on F5
I would like to let the players
calculate this out I'm part of an
eliminated team I don't think I've got
any business uh looking at this position
the one thing I'll show is a funny mate
I was looking at this line Knight D4
castles and Knight takes these huge
checkmates so these kinds of mates are
all around this crazy position
yeah absolutely and I am happy to let
these guys do all the heavy lifting and
calculate everything from here
go ahead go ahead oh he doesn't see it I
missed it yeah honestly fair I mean what
the hell is Queen takes E4 what the hell
is Queenie for
let's get off this game back to the
bird's eye view let's we enough we have
to be careful Daniel's getting uh too
trigger happy with these puns yeah I
mean all of the boys and girls in the
chat really liked that pun so we go back
to the bird's eye view and my eye is
caught first of all by the bottom or top
right with a rook sitting on G3 that
Sicilian is looking real Sleek for
Alexander indich isn't it Yep this looks
like a uh this looks like when we should
probably drop in on because mvl with the
white pieces I said I think the blitz
have to lean on their top boards and
right now mvl is probably looking at a
world of pain I'm wondering what exactly
the opening was it almost looks like one
of those con positions where you sit
there you kind to have like D6 E6 or G6
and H5 yeah and when white plays F5 to
challenge everything black says okay
hang on I'm not planning the castle at
all I'm actually gonna use the open G
file against you so even though I feel
like mvl opened things up it's really
not worked out from
believe it or not this started out as a
night or and it was a rare night orphan
which black initially played G6 but then
didn't find keto his Bishop in fact he
had played it to control some key light
squares but that's far in the past
because right now we're locked in this
middle game struggle where indage has
set his Center Pawns in motion and
everything else says bring it on Cowboy
you go D4 I dare you because I'm going
to sack presumably his Knight for those
two pawns and open up the e-file and I
feel like evaluating those positions as
hard as it is when you're playing
someone like mvl who blitzes out these
sacrifices it takes some guts to play
the move d4 you know who's got guts Mr
Alexander indich I think I think that
indich also understands that look if D4
is a blunder like you know lock me up
take me away right like if this is not
how Jess works then I'd like to find out
right now
now he's taken with the Rook as mvl and
the reason is that H4 is hanging that's
an important Pawn because that pawn
anchors The Rook to G3 and not only that
if white White's Rook lands on H4 Rook
h8 might become a serious problem
apparently the best move here is Bishop
E7 to C5 I think if vintage plays it we
actually might lock him up literally
Bishop C5 saying okay I see your queen
on E2 and I raise you uh an open file
it's like insane I allow you a thousand
different discover checks including
Bishop H6 which almost looks like
Checkmate but the king can duck away
behind the Knight with King to d8
and Bishop C5 I wonder I I really am
curious what the next best move is
because I have a feeling if there's
going to be a drop off after that
because Rook takes H4 is such a
significant threat it undermines The
Rook threatens rook h8 and it also
brings the pawn count to three pawns for
the piece which is actually pretty good
calm
well Rook takes C3 actually was one of
the top moves this is amazing attacks
The Exchange and he just slams that
Knight right where it hurts in the
center of the board using the fact that
White's Bishop has no longer has not yet
moved away from E3 now I believe this
attacks The Rook I'm on I really don't
want to say anything with certainty in a
position this crazy Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe The Rook isn't actually hanging
but if it moves back when indish might
gobble up the pawn on C3 that's not out
of the question yeah I'm thinking about
like Rook where's The Rook of Rook F3
you can also just continue to support
the knights in the center right you're
gonna have moves like Bishop D6 coming
in uh Knight C5 Knight F6 to support the
uh the knight in the center first uh
yeah this this looks like such a good
practical decision nobody's playing
Bishop C5 in that previous position
Daniel this makes way more sense and
practically speaking mvl is not happy to
see Brook C3
oh he definitely isn't and once the
Smoke Clears and the situation
stabilizes it'll be a lot harder to keep
the position complex enough to exploit
Black's time pressure and mvl actually
is barely even up on time for the first
time in this entire match so very
practical decision for endic who does
have one bar of connection so hopefully
uh that doesn't cost him as we move
further and further toward the time
scramble and we'll let mvl Ponder this
ridiculously complex position we'll try
to get him get him an Advil I might need
one myself after like two minutes of
analyzing that
is not getting any less crazy and
another crazy thing Paulina chevalova
has a minute on her clock and we're not
yet out of the opening let's jump into
that piece I I need to see this game
Paulina where oh where is the material
gone
she's down she's down a full minor piece
no but apparently Diamante just made a
big mistake herself what's how do we
even get this position Jesus Christ so I
think it's takes and queen C3 to take on
G7 and just maybe like mess mess Black's
position
I think most people would assume that
it's Queen a fortune that's right if you
play it immediately then the bishop
blocks if you play it after the capture
then the Knight blocks the check on C6
let's fast forward I'm sorry rewind you
definitely can't fast forward this and
see how this actually happened so what
happened was it was some crazy regosan
with a lot of tactics in the center but
Knight C5 is what caused Molina to spend
all over time because after Knight takes
E5 I'm on the bishop is hanging but also
Knight D3 wow is a huge positional
threat so much so that Paulina decided
the Desperate Measures were necessary
she sacks for peace
goes Knight D5 and instead of taking on
B4 she chases the bishop away to a safer
Square
yeah and now A4 I guess I can kind of
understand what she's doing like the
knight in Bishop like both are kind of
trapped there on A6 and B6 respectively
so I understand what she's up to this is
not that easy for black to play
C6 to hit the Knight I'm like trying to
save the bishop here I'm struggling
so if you play C6 I assume that white
will transition her Focus From the
bishop to the D6 Knight so maybe I'll
play Knight B6 a b and maybe some slow
move like Bishop B2 yeah I think it's
important for Paulina not to forget that
she can use the G7 Pawn as a Target as a
Tempo to gain and use that Tempo let's
say to situate the bishop on E5 yep I
will say despite the engine eval and the
extra piece this is not a uh you know a
clear shot at a victory here for the
blitz but it is the best chance that
Cornett has had uh all matched to score
a point and boy would this be an
impressive and needed point for the
blitz I think I said it before the match
this board four might determine the
entire thing fournette needs to get on
the board
I mean would you say boy this would be a
big one you mean do you mean by any
chance foyer or this one here
I mean you got another chance to make
the pun that I've already made six times
in the span of five minutes come on why
wouldn't you do it at seventh it's not
oversaturated or anything
absolutely not five minutes now for De
Monte Carnet and Amman I feel like these
games are always frustrating because on
the one hand you feel like you have to
punish your opponent for getting into
time pressure on the other your ultimate
Allegiance is to finding objective moves
but in the blink of an eye the time
situation is already getting a lot less
lopsided than it was just two minutes
ago that's right and you know what's
remarkable if
if we take the results the expected
results according to the all-knowing
eval bars in the in all four games
honestly we might be looking at a tied
match Daniel I see two promising games
for the blitz I see in ditch we look
took a look at that earlier great
position for the Bulldogs of course not
decided but he seems to be playing
phenomenally and then just a neck and
neck board one match up between two
heavyweights
but the batch that's not neck and neck
is dineshwar against Boyer I've had that
on my mind ever since they played that
crazy opening and white has indeed lost
the Knight on H4 black found the
opportunity to play G5 yeah and white
sacrificed on F5 so we were anticipating
this type of position and the big
question Aman is whether or not white
will be able to win back the F5 Knight
and I think the answer that we're
getting is actually no it looks like
black will maintain his extra piece yeah
I mean the king moved out of the way
next step is the queen moves out of the
way and that's it right that's all she
wrote you could even play Knight takes
on E3 next right and just sack
everything and you'll still be ahead
no that tells you a lot about how
desperate the situation is for white
danishvar takes on F5 how is he gonna
follow this move up you're right I'm on
if after Knight takes F5 white plays d e
the key winning move for black is to
give the queen away for the two rows and
black will have Oodles of material in
return for the queen I think as the
evaluation gets worse and worse it's
it's actually pushing Dinesh far down in
his chair the the eval bar is slowly
he's gonna be off screen soon
yeah yeah he's just gonna keep slumping
down that does look like a comfortable
chair I can't really blame him if he
plays de his head might disappear from
the camera yeah fair enough de would be
too much and and honestly uh it might be
uh
it might be over okay we're getting word
that we need to go to the Grisha game
immediately because it's reaching a Time
scramble and Alexander grishook has an
incredibly promising position here
against Bogdan Daniel ditch so let's
watch this will unfold he just made an
amazing move or did he
Jack
okay which seems pretty normal and then
he drops the screen back to G5 and has a
long-term attack against Black's King
what do you make of this
yeah I'm I'm immediately drawn to a move
like Knight F5 just just first move on
my radar because if you take it with the
pawn there might be e takes F5 and queen
H5 is check you have a pawn maybe
arriving to F6 Rook lifts are are coming
with Rook at four this looks scary
this absolutely looks Gary grishek is
investing the rest of his time and you
can sense the wheels turning in his
brain he's definitely calculating that
F5 but he also could double Rooks on the
file I think given the time situation
maybe Rook F3 and Rook F1 would be the
more conservative approach either way
he's got to make a decision he's now
down 15 seconds I'm like didn't he just
have a minute and if he knows the Rook I
think Rook A1 was happening by by black
to trade pieces and not let the Rooks
double up so he does go with Knight F5
initially I I mean queen H6 funny enough
is not a winning move I know it looks
like you go Queen h8 here and we need to
status quo Queen E5 same idea there's no
mate on G7 that's right Grisha moves
back to H4 he sort of resets his attack
and definitely he's eyeing the G6 Pawn
to Edge defense uh oh is there a win
here Rook F4 maybe yeah Rook F4 was
initially coming to mind but it's
actually oh hey bishop h35 Bishop H3 you
just take it I think
I think you've taken you go Knight H2
and you meet no Rook A2 doesn't even
attack the Knight because the C2 Pawn
exactly stands between the rook and the
Knight so black is no way to increase
the attack here he's trying yeah but
grishek is completely winning with Rook
F3 I think
yeah Rook F3 hitting the queen reshook
you know he's getting that Queen away I
mean at this point every single game is
in time trouble here Dania this is the
bird's eye view you can see the eval bar
is just on a full workout in every
single board I have no idea how things
are going to finish
well listen Boyer is completely winning
Demonte Cornett is completely winning
and grushook is completely winning so
that's three points right there
Alexander image is also completely
winning so the Bulldogs are gonna take
that game we might get a win by the
Blitz and the most unlikeliest of ways
with indage defeating mvl but the rest
of them losing but their needs to be the
shook is messing up he's just messing up
we gotta go to his game Rook takes C6
Dash might be holding this
she has zero pawns on the board I don't
think I've seen people win without Pawns
he literally gave away all of his pawns
this should be a very holdable draw even
without all of the pawns this is a drama
and it's an easier draw to achieve than
if White had a bishop we might we might
even see them
we might see did they hatch win
one of the the bottom two boards they
are completely winning positions oh
Boyer is messing up boys I might be
messing up he's got two seconds let's
take a look at that game he's got an
extra piece but things are not so simple
E3 and White's got that past F Pond move
that pawn forward Rock'em cowboy and
White's got chances here practically
speaking Knight takes E3 though is a
that's a great pickup guards the G4 Pawn
for the moment
still completely winning for black and
the pawn is
Untouchables B5 there we go that you
gotta get those things going great stuff
by Boyer he's so cold-blooded C4 push it
yeah King C6 is a great move as well but
eventually the pawn has to move
still some chances practically oh
nc7 doesn't want Rook C8 to happen
maybe go back to C6
oh that's true I would have I would have
gone rookie five there because with the
Knights trying to stop past pawns it
ain't that simple
Knight's under attack but King C6 makes
a lot of sense
beautiful and now C3 has met with King
D3 so you don't want to push the pawn
prematurely unless you've understood
that the pawn can promote by force
Knight E3 or Rook D3 is completely
winning I think he's showing great
technique thus far and actually the
Monte cornet and Boyer are demonstrating
the technique necessary in their games
this looks like we are going to see a
potential tie break here I'm calling it
right now it looks like the most likely
result
and A6 last chance for Dinesh bar but
he's gonna get checkmated before the
pawn even reaches A7 or is it Rook B2
King C1
where's the decisive blow maybe Rook B2
King C1 Rook A2
can you take that pawn no you can't
because the BlackRock stops the pawn
from C8
and ooh Knight C4 here
and C1 Queen and Rook A2 at the very end
oh and that's like an only move King C3
also released this is nice very nice
finish here
okay now we gotta go to our last
remaining game no that's it Madame DD
known as has checkmated Paulina is about
to check Maple into chevalova we gotta
go to that game though because it's
never over till it's over it's never
over this is an absolute necessary
result here let's not forget two seconds
is still playing Knight B5 he's still
playing he's trying to torture white two
seconds for Demonte cornette who could
have taken White's Rook it was literally
hanging a little bit earlier I can
imagine totally winning oh my goodness
Bishop E2 is coming Bishop
oh
oh she played that with one second again
Bishop E2 oh my goodness
B5 Bishop d8 is almost made oh my God
King has B8
Bishop B6 yeah you have to go Bishop B6
right this is insane it's sidestepping
all of the checks Knight C6 Bishop F6
wait a second oh my goodness E6 he's 67.
Bishop B7 it's not over no no no no no
take submission oh my goodness Bishop F6
she might mess this up it still might be
winning though Amon
it says draw but I feel like this is
practically great chances this game is
completely oh no
C5 just push that pawn
she's got this being C4 she's C5 Bishop
B2 wait a second if you play C4
prematurely you're gonna get blockaded
this has to be winning though King James
was winning but I think now the pawn
just advances she does have it gracious
and you know what white at some point
might throw in H5 to make that pawn
capture and I'm saying just in case it
was necessary it would be the right
color wait a second still trying is
Paulina I would go bishopy too there I
would not have gone B2 but this works as
well a draw official in the grishook
game by the way which means
going to go to uh tie breaks unless we
see a insane stalemate here
um
bolina should try no she resigns this
might have just been the most insane PC
all around I've ever seen the heck did
we just witness every game was crucial
we we got a 8-8 result at the end from
some of the most unlikely results on
each board I mean look at this
I told you that unless mvl and Grisha go
at least one and a half out of two the
blitz have no chance yeah yeah exactly
they go fifty percent
minus
sword against India
bogdon holds a draw with black and
somehow Boyer and connect go two out of
two with the black bearded opposition
with black to tie this crazy freaking
match I can't believe it it is now eight
to eight overall and you can see first
of all a credit both sides but look at
endage there or two three and a half
points that is a tremendous performance
and I said it earlier cornette would
have to get on the board for the team
navigating chance I didn't realize that
boards three and four were gonna carry
the final round and that's exactly what
they did
They carried it big time they will take
me some time to to settle into what we
are seeing but what we are about to see
ladies and gentlemen is an overtime
tiebreaker match the time control will
be three plus two if you thought this
was crazy you ain't seen nothing yet
well you will want to see the tie break
match between the Blitz and the Croatian
bulldogs and we will be bringing you
that match as soon as we set the players
up we'll be back with more PCL action in
just a couple of short minutes
use gifts from the biggest chest stars
on all of your favorite platforms
just search chess.com and your favorite
chess star on Discord Twitter WhatsApp
and more to find hundreds of gifts from
chess.com's biggest broadcasts and
events Hikaru Magnus botes Hess and even
me Danny try it today
my name is Ethan Curry
you know we all have nicknames
Chicago is naturally where I'm born and
raised so that's how I got the name I
guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently they
don't make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up they don't matter
we're trying to do is to let them know
hey we playing down here in Houston
Texas and if you come down here help
step in trust me we're going to beat you
you better bring your game
[Music]
I understand 18 seconds for a black so
not too much time there either Rook C7
a7's falling uh it is E4 he pushes the
pawn this is getting a little messy
takes a knight F1
[Music]
move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played
it takes it right yeah
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that wasn't there and instead
he played here
oh my God A7 wins for white oh my gosh
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
it's overtime at the pro chess League
this match between the blitz uh and the
I'm like Bulldogs the pueration of
Bulldogs has gone completely off the
rails and if you think you've seen crazy
you haven't seen anything yet because we
will have a three plus two overtime
match where the uh boards are repeated
as in the fourth round these are the
tiebreaker rules ladies and gentlemen
the time control is lowered to three
minutes with a two second increment the
round four pairings remain but the
colors are swapped we're gonna Master
them on Hamilton
seat belts fastened and tight across
your lap absolutely necessary I I think
a few people would have found themselves
shifting during flight during that
fourth and final round of Regulation now
it's important to note that the pairings
are the same but the colors are
different that honestly changes
everything I was going into that fourth
round and saying okay you know the blitz
have to lean on their top two boards
with the white pieces everything that I
thought I knew was out the window uh
completely different
um Daniel what do you make of the
tiebreaker knowing that if it's still
tied the time control goes down again to
one plus two you think it favors either
team to keep prolonging this
I think it depends on the player I think
there are some players on each team who
would appreciate a shorter time control
I honestly think that the blitz have to
be incredibly thrilled to be where they
are because they have Mahal Boyer
deliver a win of the black pieces
against brezzie adonisfar they achieved
some of the most unlikely results of the
entire PCO on that final round with
Diamante cornet and my hell boy are
delivering two incredible wins an mvo
losing a sicilian from the white side
everything about that round was crazy
and I think mvl and grishek once again
are going to be the X factors although I
said that in the last round and that was
not just out the window in fact the
opposite was the case they were not the
X factors they were the least important
games that's right and I don't know what
it is with the blitz but they have been
in tie breaks before so they seem to be
addicted to this I don't know what it is
they just have the most exciting
matchups so for everyone in the chat
right now you are witness to an
extremely exciting treat today eight to
eight which means now Danny it's first
to ten and a half points for the win and
obviously the first team to win around
they keep going back and forth switching
the colors making the time control even
lower if we see another tie two to two
but otherwise two and a half points will
win the entire round and the match
and folks when we have a three plus two
time control it's impossible to see all
of the games at once we will do our best
to hit on the games as they reach a
climax we can't promise that we cover
every single intriguing moment of the
match but once again we will do our very
best I'm sure all of the games are going
to be uh entertaining to an extent quiet
openings positional chess essentially
goes out the window as we look at the
lineups one more time you can see there
the most important bit is that the
colors have been reversed out now has
white in ditch now has white and they
will need to repeat the success of the
previous round in particular I'm really
looking forward to the English mvl game
both of them are incredibly strong and
experienced Blitz players they play
title Tuesdays every Tuesday this is
where that experience I'm on really
really comes in handy this moment right
here absolutely this is going to be so
intense I'm immediately drawn to the uh
top boards because I mean mvl I think
when you start to play these little mini
matches right where your play opponent
and immediately you have a chance this
reminds you of you know when you just
log on to chess.com and just play a few
games you know you immediately hit the
rematch button that's essentially what
these guys are doing except the time
control is way different so they
probably have never experienced this
type of a rematch clause before
no they definitely have not dude you you
said it where the blitz there is
Intrigue Bogdan Daniel Dash I think he
might be the magnet for this kind of
craziness anytime he plays a match we
get the craziest stuff on the board we
get off the board but all of that
doesn't matter because Dash has played a
relatively non-crazy opening he's played
the Catalan so he wants to keep it
relatively quiet and Alexander grishok
is blitzing out what I think can safely
be called the most popular variation
nowadays uh where the bishop is aiming
for C6 and the Knight will stop by the
parking spot on D7 that's right and uh
three plus two kind of an interesting
time control because
um you know ironically a lot of the
chess.com tournaments that are held
whether it's you know titled Tuesday or
even speed Chess Championship that these
strong players might be used to you're
dealing with plus one nowadays so
actually plus two as a as a Time control
which is like kind of feed a standard
you don't actually play it that much
online
yeah two second increment online is
pretty hefty you can build up a
significant amount of time with a two
second increment and grishook has built
up a significant time Advantage I think
someone needs to tell Bogdan that this
isn't a 10 minute game anymore he's
already burned 30 seconds of his clock
and more disturbingly it feels like
grishok is still in his preparation he's
pressuring the pawn on D4 and I like the
clamp that black has achieved along the
light squares on the queen side I think
this is a positive outcome for Alexander
grishook out of the opening yeah I mean
the the funny thing about this is we're
on I don't know move 12 13 and we shook
has three minutes on his clock so
nothing seems to have changed from the
previous time oh my gosh I have to
interrupt you I'm on we gotta go to the
bird's eye view because barely has the
mvl game started he is already
experiencing major problems out of the
opening remember that the colors have
reverse so mvl has black and he's got a
very difficult position after only 11
moves in a grunfeld his most uh noted
opening indich has somehow forced the H
file open and the eval bar is Sky High
it's higher than the Empire State
Building well the the thing about the
thing about this opening I'll take it
with a grain of salt this is the
grinfeld after all Daniel we can
tolerate plus three advantages but no in
all in all seriousness this is a a real
issue I mean there are basic moves like
Bishop H6 right just Stone Cold trade
the bishop off bring the queen to D2 and
go for checkmate that's not good enough
for you I mean I don't know what is this
is plain and simple chess and remember
this is Blitz it's even easier to
execute these types of attacks I can't
believe this Enfield clearly confused
something because not only is he getting
checkmated on the king's side he doesn't
even have something to suffer for him on
in fact he's actually down upon to begin
with he's got nothing going in the
center his pieces are barely developed
and I think his only chance to get back
into this game is to do exactly what
he's doing right now he brings his
Bishop to G4 get the night out to D7 and
I hope just pray that there's no mating
tactic I think h8 is a threat followed
by 286 Knight G5 there might be no
defense to it Rook h8 is such a nasty
threat and if you go Bishop takes F3
you're dreaming of Knight takes F3 oh oh
that's mate Rook hat is made it's
literal mate this was one of the worst
Blitz Games I've ever seen from mvl and
he just put his percentage to play the
move I'm going to show the line I'm on I
don't need to show it Alexander indich
is showing us the move yes it's over
it's over it's on the board Knight F6
take it no checks
one even is fine but I would take back
on E2 because black can't even Stave off
mate Knight F6 ef6 and if you take on G5
I'm on even that doesn't help because
there's a mate on G7 but yeah exactly
King G1 is like it's crazy precise way
to go takes Queen G5 and queen G7
okay hello
there we go wow that that is a
tremendous just went 2-0 against mvl
like he's looking around at his fellow
Bulldogs like hey come on guys let's go
like I'm leading by example here
well step up your game he says to his
teammates it looks like bogd and Daniel
Dash is stepping up his game because he
seems to have a pretty hefty advantage
against Alexander grishook and I think
the top two boards for the Bulldogs have
already over fulfilled their
expectations right if they can go one
out of two the bottom two boards are
pretty heavy favorites but Bogdan might
do even better than that he actually
might win this game yeah this this looks
like a position where it's so easy to go
wrong as Grisha this is a Blitz game and
you know with a minute approaching on
the clock you have to like White's
chances here even Bishop takes f8 just
playing that position gotta be good for
white
oh my gosh Bishop f8 black could try
Queen take C4 the light squares are
terrifyingly weak but so all the sides
are getting made into both sides exactly
who comes at who First bishop f8 is on
the board and a big decision for
Alexander grishook he can play Rook
takes f8 Iman but that might allow the
White Queen to get into the action and
the Queen and Knight combo against a
wide open King not what you want to deal
with with one minute on the clock that's
right I think this is the right decision
Bishop C4 and Bishop D5 is one way to
sort of set up the threats
um there's a lot of danger here on the
light squares and surprisingly black
might be one move ahead of white white
might have to trade Queens soon
I think you will have to trade queens
and the question is always are the team
members aware of how their teammates do
I don't think they are in a three-minute
match so Dash he's got to just play his
own game Queen G5 takes G6 and rookie
one forces a draw which would be an
incredibly positive result right now
before the Bulldogs that means that
means we need to look at the other
boards the bottom two boards were the
heroes for the Blitz in the previous
round can they repeat their heroics here
Aman what do you see yeah it basically
we saw the bottom two boards being
Heroes for the blitz well guess what
they're they're gonna have to be uh
heroes in a different way once again and
this time with the white pieces though
the Hellboy seems to have a very
balanced game but very closed off as
well I'm looking at Demonte coronets
game as one that we should take a look
at because it looks a lot more open and
I see some aggression on the king side
here uh being launched by cornet
and I see the same narrative being
repeated with paulina's very poor time
management she's down to 30 seconds but
material is equal black should be better
because of her Bishop pair but does she
realize it's a three minute game she's
down to 20 seconds we're only on move
15. maybe she's trying to find a way to
win the Knight on E5 but she can't
because the night worse comes to worse
can drop back to F3 because the queen is
protected by the other Knight but that
loses a pawn yeah I mean and yet neither
one of these teams wants to go quietly
into the night right these are teams
that are at one and one in the Pro chess
League they do not want to fall to one
and two and face elimination they're
putting everything on the line here
and to that end Dash actually refused
the queen trade so he's actually going
for the win very I love scramble and
this is not an elimination match but you
called it him on the stakes are still
absolutely huge you win you're
essentially in the playoffs I don't know
where to go 59 seconds now for cornet
and the last thing she wants is the time
scramble here
C4
reasonable Jesus Christ rookie E4
happens with Tempo now even though you
you jettison the B2 Pawn maybe rookie 4
rookie one just keep the pressure time
to jettison some stuff it's played great
called by you with 20 seconds on the
clock you want as much tactical
potential as you can achieve here I'm
also looking at Boyer who's got five
seconds the position's still balanced
but the clock is far from balance we're
gonna get a draw in Dash's game against
grishook by the way that's right draw
has been agreed man and just one more
point the blitz are really putting their
uh lower boards like they're leaning on
them like crazy putting them in a tough
spot they're saying hey why don't you
guys win on demand
the mvl Grisha combo has gotten half a
point out of two in the last two rounds
how crazy would it be if the blitz
nonetheless managed to take this match
all of it I think will come down to
Boyer's game this is the Bulldog's best
chance to put this match away right here
and right now yeah and every board seems
to be going in the Bulldogs favor right
now but what do you expect as the blitz
your top two boards go half out of two
you can't always rely on the bottom too
but they're still fighting but hell
Boyer he's got chances here time is so
so low and Paulina even has a crushing
Advantage at the moment
Paulina has won the pawn on B2 and
unfortunately for Cornett she just
hasn't shown uh any kind of fight as a
result but she's trying to generate some
chances I flipped the game on Rook to G4
is the last move she's threatening made
queen 64. queen takes D4 would force the
Queens off the board that would be
absolutely rushing move E6 Queen takes
f7s
she doesn't see it instead it's not a
bad rage though
Rook takes G6 sack that baby wow it does
work E8 is hanging does it Rook FM I
think I think E6 was still winning but
this might be winning practically
are you winning
I think she might repeat moves though
Rook F4 bring the rook and see one Forks
The Rook bring the rook in
Rook F6 your team needs you
gotta try Rook F6
although although maybe because by the
way my Hellboy is actually generating
some winning chances now Queen D5
Quinn A1 Queen E5 oh my goodness she's
gonna lose that's gonna be it no it
needed to be Rook F5 when the queen was
on G6 or queen on H5 that win surely
cements the entire round in the Bulldogs
favor and yes they have reached the
threshold ten and a half points I
flipped on the last remaining game how
sad would it be if Boyer actually pulls
this game out
and it turns out that a draw would have
kept the match tied this is unbelievable
the consolation though for cornet
[Music]
is this actually might be a win for
white yeah really no consolation they
only needed a point and a half right uh
from those two boards so ornette could
have won and mahel Boyer could have
drawn the game and then maybe he could
have win and she could have drawn the
game you can never plan it out perfectly
Rook to A4 would have been nice there
gosh but now White's Bishop is in
trouble after King D6 and staring at the
E4 Pawn which is protected by Black
Knight Warriors shouldn't lose this
unless he blunters into some sort of a
fork
oh my gosh
this is wild yeah the result of this
game definitely does not matter we can
we can say for the overall uh match it
has been decided already
you can't expect your bottom two boards
to bail you out every time right that's
just not the way the match can can go
they over fulfilled their Expectations
by a country model They Carried the
match in the final round but Grisha can
mvl particularly Maxima has got to be
incredibly disappointed with the way
that he played the finals and that Blitz
game I'm on he plays his best opening
he's losing by move 10 that just can't
happen if you're one of the top Wars if
you're over 2700 can't happen
yeah that's that's really unfortunate
definitely disappointing uh it should be
noted that ardia here he does not know
the result of the match especially these
are Blitz Games I mean they're the
results are flying in so he's playing on
because this could be a really impactful
result and the hell player doesn't know
either so these guys are playing like it
really matters
they're playing as if the match depends
on the results of this game you're right
they don't know that it doesn't this
actually might be a win for black no the
king is hiding on H5 hitting a four king
H4 would have been a funny line yeah
okay but this should be a draw Now by
force after G7 yeah yeah if white
doesn't do something ridiculous and win
like Knight F4 G7 Rook H5 mate
that's right
is Boyer playing for a win here I can't
tell I think they're both playing for a
win
exactly just repeat moves Dinesh far
yeah White's playing for a win yep which
is ridiculous
which is ridiculous because there's no
way to make progress here black could
even sack The Rook for the pawn and it
would be a draw
yep I think border might know that
they're losing the match but he might
not realize the extent or he just go for
the draw because there's nothing left to
gain here even a win doesn't keep them
in the match
all right time to repeat moves Gents
I don't know I I respect the uh I
respect the I mean it has been a drop of
repetition he just doesn't know the
results so I really love that mentality
that you're always you know willing to
because you can't lose as white
technically you can lose his black
because there's a Pawn on the board so I
I love the mentality but like what can
you do when uh you know the top two
boards here just aren't scoring more
than half a point back to back
unfortunately the blitz lose in tie
breaks after bringing it back Dania I
mean what what do you make of that
result I'm just beside myself with uh
with excitement that was so fun to watch
this honestly it was such a pleasure to
watch that match unfold really starting
from round three I mean the entire way
from the very first round we had sharp
games on all four boards everybody was
going at each other's throats and
honestly De Monte corn I had my whole
boy gotta hold their heads up high it's
not about assigning blame and it's
important not to assign blame them on
because the blitz are still in the PCL
and have actually shown that they can
absolutely win the next three matches
they are very much still in the
conversation they have to have better
performances from the top two boards
though absolutely and you know it's also
important to remember that mvl that's a
player that uh can go 4-0 right he
definitely had a terrible fourth round
and a terrible
um overtime round right you have to say
that point blank he knows it and he'll
probably hold himself to the highest
standards but you know you can't get
down on a player like that the same way
you can't get down on a board four that
goes and scores zero points one week
it's a team format and not everyone's
going to be playing their best chess in
a given week so uh you just have to
regroup realize you're still in the PCL
mvl is a player that I think any team
would be lucky to have so I mean you're
definitely not looking at him as a
player that you're looking to cut off
the roster but damn if you can't look at
him uh with a side eye after those last
two uh last two Blitz Games which I have
to say they will he will look himself
with a side eye but we will be looking
at the Bulldogs manager of Nimitz who we
will have for an interview after the
break he must be chewing whatever
objects are near him that must have been
wildly stressful for vehicles we will
find out the first person view but first
we're going to take a short break and
set him up folks don't go anywhere
because we will wrap up the show and
have an interview with the Bulldogs
manager in just a couple of moments
foreign
my name is Ethan Curry
you know we all have nicknames
Chicago is naturally where I'm born and
raised so that's how I got the name I
guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently
it'll make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up they don't matter
we're trying to do is to let them know
hey we playing down here in Houston
Texas and if you come down here help
step in trust me we're going to beat you
you better bring your game
[Music]
I understand 18 seconds for a black so
not too much time there either Rook C7
a7's falling uh it is E4 he pushes the
pawn this is getting a little messy
takes a knight F1
91.
[Music]
move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played
I was gonna say King C2 and run the king
93 four takes it makes it
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that was me and instead he
played here oh my God A7 wins for white
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the captain of the Victorious Croatia
Bulldogs I can't even imagine what
you've been feeling the last couple of
minutes love what is going through your
mind right now
I don't know my heart is beating so hard
I still haven't cooled down yeah I mean
it's a mix of Happiness this belief and
yeah a little bit of sadness for the
opposing team who was also so close to
winning but but ultimately I fell short
in the tiebreaker
yeah this this match had us on the edge
of our seats I think going into it we
would say things like you know honestly
I think this could be an 8-8 match well
then it actually was an 8-8 match and uh
in order for that to happen there was a
comeback mounted by the blitz so
vegaslev take us through that final
round in regulation when it was the
blitz that mounted a comeback against
your Bulldogs I mean what were you
thinking could you think you could
actually lose
oh yeah I was so tilted at that point
because uh in the previous round I think
it was in the previous round pavina drew
that game against uh against Boyer and
uh and I think alsoever in the match uh
uh they are blundered heavily against
boy and I was like already really
annoyed that their third board and his
resilience in time travel and then the
game started and I was like oh wait
bhardia is a piece down oh wait to win
is also pissed down and I was like
things are not looking good but then
ninjas came with the clutch win and okay
they had survived that against grishuke
I don't know how and I was like okay
maybe it's not over but at some point I
was certain the river was and that I
would still have to write some reports
where it's like oh my God I can't
believe he actually was this match in
this fashion but yeah it's just
thrilling really
take us love how proud are you of your
guy Alexander indage who gets four and a
half out of five and what could you tell
chess fans who are a little bit less
familiar with his playing style is this
kind of performance something that
you've come to expect from someone who's
very clearly underrated by probably
about 100 points
yeah I mean so in the region he's well
known like okay Serbia is always a
neighboring country for to Croatia and
uh everybody around has heard about
injured and knows of him uh he is known
for his very aggressive very sharp style
but I didn't really expect that he would
go for a win against mvo in the final
round and actually I didn't know what to
expect because I I don't know him
personally and actually in Bundesliga
over the weekend he was playing and he
actually was bought games so it wasn't a
good sign before the match but yeah what
he did today I think exceeded
everybody's expectations like it was
crazy like beating mvl twice in a row I
don't know many people who are capable
of doing this so get through respect and
definitely keep an eye for this guy
because he's not only playing very good
chess he's playing very enterprising
chess from all aspects opening wise
style wise definitely different uh
player to keep an eye on
yeah completely agree I mean you have to
be a complete player to beat mvl in
back-to-back games I mean plain and
simple
um I also uh can say that you know
you've moved on with uh the win you now
have that record of two and one uh I've
seen some other teams at two in one uh
one of those is uh the chess bras uh do
any of those teams uh you know tickle
your your interest we're looking at a
standings on our screen here you have
the Shanghai Tigers chess Wizards Norway
gnomes Canada chess bras and yourself
any of those teams uh you know are are
ones that you'd want to match up against
next week
although that depends is any constant
playing
well that that depends if Magnus is
playing I not sure he'll ever be allowed
on the same roster as him again so yeah
I mean I don't know like we know
seriousness I I it's hard to say like at
this point all the things are so strong
and super super stacked and I guess
there are noisy matches whatever I like
the fact that rating cup is sort of an
equalizer but we will see actually it's
hard for me to think about the next
match at this moment when the
repercussions of this one are still
going on my way from to my head
foreign
we have two quick chat questions for you
before we let you go the first one from
Bruce Mack who asks does the team get
together to practice or they or do they
do meetings via Zoom or something like
that or is most of the communication
sort of just formal by email
yeah I was actually thinking about that
and how maybe it wouldn't be a bad idea
to actually because I I don't know
whether the players know each other or
not no that there is definitely no
practice sessions I mean this is you
know first of all they're all
professionals and I'm not sure if they
would like to share their maybe Secrets
or do anything together with a team of
nine other players and also there are
schedules and geographical differences
and time differences and such uh maybe
it would be a good idea to hold a
meeting I don't know what's the practice
with other things but in my case I just
didn't get around it because I'm not
sure how much they would enjoy it I did
try it once in the previous seasons and
it wasn't like super good so for the
moment it's all formal but given the
results maybe it should change or maybe
not I don't know maybe it's the best as
it is
yeah maybe uh maybe keep it that way
um we have one more featured chat
question from Goran chess a question for
you how do you pick your weekly lineup
with basically so many great players on
your overall roster like you have so
many good options what goes into it as
the manager for the Croatia Bulldogs to
to picking the lineup each week
Yeah It's tricky because uh because it's
a you know there are many strong players
and like on paper would you say there's
a difference for example between engine
and humans or or durability they're all
great players of similarating similar
strength but most of the time it also
comes down to let's say the performance
in the recent matches obviously you know
party I was doing super well this season
so I it's natural to give him as many
opportunities as possible but also it
often comes down to the availability of
the players like for example last week a
few months was able to play but this
week is playing in the Norway chess
League this week English is playing but
next week he will play in the European
individual Championship so you guys from
Chase blah when we get paid you know
that you don't have to prepare for him
so it's kinda means of a boat but
ultimately it's also you know I mean
that's as a highest rated player
obviously usually against the
opportunity so yeah it's communication
some decision making and also scheduling
with the other obligations
well we appreciate the Insight Vehicles
it's been a long day a very
nerve-wracking match we will let you
take your risk congratulations to your
team and good luck to the Bulldogs in
their quest to win one more match and
make it to the playoffs
yeah thank you guys and yeah good luck
to you too and I know hope to see you in
the playoffs I guess
absolutely thanks
well that's all she wrote him on two
teams are now at a perfect score man the
Gotham Knights match it feels like it
was I don't know like a decade ago if it
feels yeah that was the same day I can't
believe that same morning I mean this is
crazy we just had six hours of
incredible Breakneck action the Gotham
Knights blowing the Shanghai Tigers out
of the water and the Shanghai tigers are
now joined at the score of two and one
from the Croatia Bulldogs who came from
the other direction but I think I'm on
are basically here to stay especially if
indish and dash keep performing this
well
agreed uh and the other interesting
thing about the PCL is teams can beat
each other and then still meet in the
playoffs so I mean yeah the Gotham
Knights are 3-0 they just beat the
Shanghai Tigers but funny enough look at
the Shanghai Tigers they're right behind
them literally chasing their tails so
Shanghai could win another match and
well there might be some interesting fun
rivalries that start to develop in this
protest League because you don't beat a
team once and never see them again it's
not a knockout format I think it's great
there's three lives available and uh you
you will see these teams again but
Croatia looking great Blitz need more
points from their their top boards it
seems like over these couple weeks
Daniel because right now they have
fallen to one and two in the standings
that's that's just not gonna cut it they
cannot afford another loss well they've
got that one-two punch mvl and grit
shook but they will be the first to
admit that today they were incredibly
underwhelming mvl he really destroyed a
lot of the blitz's chances with two
losses against Alexander endic in the
final two games but let me tell you
these top GMS they Savor the opportunity
for Redemption they're not just thinking
uh you know why don't you put me out I
don't want to play next week no no
they're gonna say put me in coach put me
in Captain because I am going to show
what I'm made of and that kind of
approach is what we live for as
commentators watching players who maybe
haven't had the best run so far but are
hungry for the opportunity for
Redemption that's what the PCL is all
about and the blitz are gonna be have to
be all about winning if they want to
make a comeback and somehow make their
way into the playoffs and perhaps get
another chance at uh the Croatia
Bulldogs who they will try so hard to
beat but all of that is in the future
because folks the time has come for us
unfortunately to wrap up today's show so
tomorrow though we will have two more
matches same time start times 7 30 a.m
Pacific and 10 a.m Pacific we will have
the unicorns against mgd1 in the morning
followed by the Berlin Bears and the St
Louis archbishops who yes Aman r2o so
anybody who's experiencing PCL
withdrawal you will not have long to
wait until the next set of matches I'll
pass it on to you one more time before
we wrap up for your final thoughts on
today
I mean today was just insane uh I mean
there's no other way to describe it
riveting matches we saw a blowout and
then we saw an exciting uh overtime
match at the end as well I couldn't have
asked for you know more action better
action uh and the best part is that
we're not even at the end of the week
right we can look forward to tomorrow
and everyone who's here as just a PCL
Enthusiast and chess fan uh Tomorrow
there's another big matchup and probably
one of the biggest I think of the week
we get to find out another team that
will unfortunately be eliminated from
the entire Pro chess league and it's
gonna happen tomorrow so St Louis or
Berlin Daniel I can't wait to sit down
and watch that one from twitch chat
among everyone else but today's been a
pleasure always great commentating with
you man likewise I'm on this was so so
much fun so thank you to you thank you
to everybody in the chat and of course
to our incredibly hard-working producers
holla and Bick who get up early together
with us and our integral really
responsible for these shows being as
professional as they are so thank you to
everybody who makes this possible we
hope you enjoyed today's PCL action and
we hope to see you tomorrow bright and
early at 7 30 a.m Pacific for the first
of what will promise to be two more
scintillating PCL matches thank you to
all we wish you a very pleasant rest of
your Thursday and there is more PCL to
come tomorrow but for now this was
Grandmaster Daniel naritzki and
Grandmaster Ammon Hamilton bidding you a
great rest of your Thursday so long
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]